[Music]
sh
oh
you've heard the sayings The Road Less
Traveled rubber meets the road I'm on
the road to nowhere that need to get up
and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
a we see a reaction Magnus mous Magnus
Mouse slipped oh my gosh look at
Jordan's face some have pulled over but
some what is he doing slam that foot to
the floor just kept going any second
Nakamura is the winner not a ofd maxim
vaj the Frenchman he wins the AI cup
after six stops along the way it's time
for the greatest proven ground and
online chess to drop that final pin in
the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play get
the best players in the world it's
always a challenge and I enjoy it it's
going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
now
[Music]
it is the Champions chess tour final in
the year
2023 we are here in Toronto the
beautiful CN Tower looking pretty right
there the weather has been beautiful
here in Toronto we cannot wait to dive
in cuz we are in the building we are
here here baby eight players will be
joining us very soon right behind us
it's the Champions chess tour KY are you
pumped oh I'm flexing sorry yeah I'm
very pumped right now Danny of course we
got eight of the best players here money
on the line rapid chest blunders nerves
everything you need and we in Toronto
we're going to have so much to break
down and preview just this first round
let alone the whole week here from
Toronto I cannot wait to dive in but as
we said he's GM KY I'm Danny rench and
with us here in Toronto also will be Ka
and we go to her right
now yeah Danny it is so cool to finally
be here I have to tell you when I
covered my first ever chess event 9
years ago I fell in love with the sport
because of what's going to happen here
in this venue just the intensity when
two players are sitting across from each
other their brains just going uh crazy
thinking about the moves over the board
and I think we're going to see some
blood here there's going to be pieces
flying when we do hit the Armageddon I'm
looking so much forward to what's going
to happen here in tono I'm going to
throw it over the Atlantic to Tanya and
the boys are you guys ready for this we
are so ready Ka and so excited the arena
looks absolutely fantastic and everyone
Welcome to our studio in Oslo where
we'll make sure you stay on top of each
and every move played in Toronto
alongside me grandmas David Howell and
Grandmaster Robert hes Robert you're
back for the season and final what are
you expecting from championship week
well I think we can expect a few things
we have one clear Underdog one clear
favorite and six hungry competitors
looking to take this Crown in Toronto
absolutely that's what it's going to be
about and David we've been building up
to this moment this in-person season and
final how do you look back to the
Champions chestar season 23 it's been a
fantastic season this brand new format
has really been a success we've been
treated here as well there have been
Thrills spills blunders Galore upsets
Armageddon the play-ins for me were a
big high and it's all been building up
to this this is where uh everything will
be decided absolutely six Majors battles
across divisions and eight of the best
players of the season have earned their
spot to
Toronto under 1 minute now for Hikaru
and wow what a move Magnus has had no
struggles against Hikaru over the board
he should be happy we have a winner
Magnus Carlson takes it he wins the air
things monsters the very first event
he's
trading London isce it's time to go
check oh and we see a reaction
Magnus oh no Hikaru Nakamura he wisar
Nakamura is the winner of the chessel
Masters Fabiano caruana resigns what an
armagen game by
Hikaru oh you oh my godar is about to
get eliminated I like to look at
this it's funny as I think he checked it
right after the game and he reacts to
that moment and that's it we have a
winner not a be Abdus satro wins the
chess kid cup what a match performance
this has been by the world number one oh
look at that oh my gosh the pain and
Wesley he leaves because it's over there
we go oh my God and we have a winner
Magnus gson checkmates Wesley so and WI
the a chess
rapid and he's not it in about 11
seconds we did see some increment but it
looks like he knows exactly and that is
it unbelievable black queen on the board
now is going to win this game Magnus
he's got it he's got it in the end wow
what a fight though that was amazing
over Magnus Carlson he takes it this is
the winner of the Julius bear generation
cup that's we're expecting the fact who
paused Queen sacrifice Magnus Carlson
surprising us Yan's going to get flagged
and Yan shaking his head checks dry up
it's game over and Yan loses on time NV
is starting to let the emotions come to
him he is starting to realize he is the
winner Maxim vajra the Frenchman he wins
the AI cup he banks the ticket to
Toronto I don't know how you cannot just
be absolutely hyped after watching that
reminding us how we got here in Toronto
of course we will be in USA we'll be in
Toronto the Champions chess tour is
global so we are Global in our footprint
of this event and those are the eight
players from all around the world they
came here listed right now currently in
the CCT points that got them here and we
highlighted the top two and bottom two
players to illustrate that at the end of
this round robin stage whoever is left
in one and two will move directly to the
semifinals and the seventh and eighth
players will be going home obviously
that's likely not how the standings will
shake out maybe it will be honestly who
knows so let's talk about the matchups
in this round one we start with the
double round robin right there at the
top you see Magnus Carlson versus Dennis
lvic Nakamura and so OMG that is going
to be a match up I expect to go to
Armageddon fuia abaturov and BOS lra
Carano all right Kenny it's time for us
to talk matchups it's time for us to go
right at the top all things start and
end with the greatest player of all time
Magnus Carlson the goat the goat of
course is the goat is the go for a
reason obviously laic is going to have
to bring it to Magnus here he's just
going to blow him out of the water yeah
this guy is just the best in every
format he's doing it and doing it well
he's been doing it for a really long
time at this point just won the FED
World Cup this year that was kind of the
last stop on his classical chess goal
tour if you will knowing that Magnus
felt that way we know that he also
dominated the CCT with three individual
event wins KY 11 total match wins of
course that's most than anybody boy 51
games played also more than anybody cuz
that's what happens when you get to a
whole lot of finals that's right he's
the overall tour winner in 2021 and 2022
so in that in that sense he's defending
his uh his title right now and uh what
can you say about Magnus Carlson at this
point before we talk about the match up
versus last mean the only thing like is
uh his s like my only competition is
myself type thing of course is it really
is like that I mean he didn't want to
play the world championship because he
didn't want to it because he wasn't
qualified he didn't want to so of course
it's going to be lavic up against maybe
a double Magnus here of himself with his
mind and everyone else has to kind of
not think about it cuz if Magnus does
start hot it would be even harder to
maybe not think he's going to run away
with it but all right so much to talk
about Magnus and everyone all week and
we know that Kaa has already caught up
with Magnus this week and here's how
their interview went
down yep hey Danny yep you're right I
sat down with Magnus he is the two tight
CCT Champion Magnus Carson and he does
not want to be knocked off that Throne
this means something to him that is
definitely the feel I got from Magnus
when I did sit down with him two days
ago here in Toronto for the tour finals
with the reigning Champion Magnus
Carlson so with this field with uh the
format that we have here uh what do you
think is in store for the fans who will
watch this uh I'm sure there'll be
plenty of um exciting matches maybe I
have a couple of exciting matches and
the rest
or uh what would it mean to you to win
it again I think this is the strongest
final there's there's ever been I think
to find anything that would top the um
final of the inaugural season with the
seven set match against Caro would be
would be tough now we do hope we have
new fans watching as well so if we do
have that uh how would you describe your
playing
style um I would say I'm fairly fairly
Universal probably I lean slightly more
technical than than tactical um
depending on the day I can play I can
play in any sty perfect my miners we
wish you best of luck in Toronto thank
you for joing
off the strongest CCT finals there's
ever been that definitely sounds good
Danny back to you
great interview there catching up with
Magnus of course we'll have more of
those all week but yeah this is uh this
is going to be Magnus Carlson's event
maybe to win or lose a lot of people
feel that way let's talk about his
matchup though against the youngster
Dennis lvic as we break down the tail of
the tape of course you could talk about
the rating disparity uh five D1
appearances you know compared to two but
really I look at the age KY I don't know
that Magnus has ever played someone with
this high of stakes on the line who he
nearly doubles up in terms of the years
yes of course I mean he does have the
experience in the age there I mean also
having a five-time World Champ right
just doing his thing here laic is going
to have to you know bring it to him here
having only like two games to do it and
they only played one time so yeah well
but catching up with Magnus I know that
he said he purposely threw down in some
casual Blitz against the youngster we
see there on camera we've gotten to know
that view well cuz he kind of wanted to
feel him out instead he thought he was a
very very strong Blitz player super
solid a lot of people know he plays this
Catalan rep are getting a lot of
positional chess we're used to seeing
him in that position but now he's going
to be in a new position behind us that's
Dennis laic but your thoughts in the
mindset a young player has got to have
going up against the goat here yeah you
just got to play your game of course
right you made it this far you've won
title Tuesdays before I mean you've
played these guys right just a little
bit more extra time right really just
play the board and that's all you really
can do especially against the goat hard
not to let the nerves get to you hard
when you're young and and playing in the
biggest event biggest stage ever but a
guy that has been on this stage before
quite literally he was in Toronto and
has played on the biggest stage many
times that's aaru Nakamura we usually
move from Magnus to Hikaru when you're
talking about the Chess World hierarchy
and there he is the uh the man with the
pineapple the birthday boy by the way
birthday it's my birthday happy birthday
hiar Nakamura we're going to be talking
more about that maybe even a little bit
of a surprise for hikaro later on in the
show I don't know you'll find out nice
looking shirt there but you know the
rumors of his over theboard career have
been coming to an end have been greatly
exaggerated as we've learned he's a
streamer first claims but really this
guy is getting better as he gets older
he's a five-time US champ he's a five
time SEC Champion he is the riging world
Fisher random chess champion by the way
we do have a reigning world champion
here in the building KY he like look
bullet chess champion champion champion
everything say Champion up there it's
kind of ridiculous half man half
everything else we don't know the other
half yet of course but hikaro plays
great chess and he's proving it all the
time he also said like I literally don't
care I'm a streamer first right that uh
being calm and not really caring is been
helping this game maybe he's half
pineapple I don't know I don't know what
he is he's he's have something else have
something we don't know what to do with
but let's talk about his road and how he
got here to the championship chess tour
in Toronto Hikaru of course is known for
winning events online all the time
winning title Tuesdays and let's let's
see exactly what his path was to get
here Hikaru Nakamura has faced a roller
coaster of challenges throughout the
2023 Champions chess tour season his
journey is marked by intense rivalries
none more thrilling than the Armageddon
battles against Magnus Carlson we see a
reaction
Magnus oh no Magnus Mouse slipped
blundering into that queen look at this
classy move from Magnus he's just trying
to swapped things off he's now managed
to get rid of the Bishops rid of a set
of Pawns and Hikaru is he going to try
and flag Magnus the answer is no it's a
draw Magnus takes this arm again and the
match and believe not Hikaru is actually
the one who offered a draw that's the
ultimate sign of respect from Epic
showdowns to impressive comebacks in the
ches bable Masters Nakamura was knocked
down to the losers bracket by Fabiano
caruana but fought his way to the Grand
Final to get another shot at his fellow
American he had to win not only one but
two matches to be the champion yeah but
it's all about the white D Pawn if he
keeps the central porn alive he
might oh my God you said in a blunder
Checkmate in one and a car immediately
does your commentators curse a one
Checkmate and that is going to cost
Hikaru the whole match how is he going
to fight on okay another night check and
this black porn is going to completely
paralyzed the white pieces and I think
he's had enough he Nakamura is the
winner of the cheser Masters Fabiano
Karana resigned with his chessel Masters
win Nakamura earned his well-deserved
place in the tour
[Music]
finals you can only hope that this match
between hkar Nakamura and Wesley so will
be half exciting as that epic Thriller
we remember between Nakamura and Carana
but what can you say I think I think
Karu is Now 37 I don't know it is his
birthday but what stands out to me KY as
you look at the tail of the tape is
definitely the 57 draws especially
knowing when we caught up with Hikaru
that he said he doesn't really get
excited when it comes to playing Wesley
so because of all of those draws I
wouldn't either Danny I don't want to
draw you any I'm tired of playing you
Danny come on 57 draws bro yeah yeah
this is probably going to go to
Armageddon and they going duke it out
there it's going to be interesting cuz I
I agree that this matchup of all of the
ones in the first round probably has the
most the highest likelihood to go to
Armageddon there's Wesley so he is so
solid he's the reigning chess.com Global
Champion when we talk about this merging
of what was two separate online tours
he's uh he's tough to beat CU he doesn't
beat himself KY he's so accurate so
technical in his approach to the game
and fast time controls he's just a rock
which is why I do believe of all the
first round matchups Nakamura so
probably has the highest likelihood To
Go the Distance yeah 100% I mean go in
the distance as you say like Wesley's so
solid he just doesn't lose and accuracy
was extremely high through the Champions
chest T even title Tuesdays I mean it's
just a very solid repertoire and of
course sometimes Hikaru gets frustrated
by that yeah well we'll see Wesley sent
Hikaru home at the global Championship I
don't think hikaro wants that to happen
and he probably wants revenge here in
this first round but all right we got
more matchups to get to let's move on to
the third matchup we haven't previewed
yet that is Notre Beck Abdus trra versus
oi Resa fuia two youngsters two faces
that you better get to know well if
somehow you've been hiding under a rock
take a look at who will be two of the
best chess players for many many years
to come these guys haven't played a ton
yet in their career but KY I expect this
one to be a thriller with two Dynamite
approaches two very aggressive players
on the board and of course they're both
very good at fast time controls oh 100%
especially fuja being in in the faster
time controls playing in in the
candidates playing bullet with Daniel
nitki right we remember that of course
but Abdu Satur being just such a fighter
that he is even taking out Fabiano right
in the chess kid cup with that Ali Resa
being 2,800 playing in the candidate so
it is going to be a Clash of Titans in
that one for sure I think this will be a
clash for many years to come Notre Beck
of course uh is is here in Toronto as
everyone knows he had a long road to get
here Kaa had a chance to catch up with
Notre Beck and we're going to toss that
interview right now I'm here with nck
abdor ready for day one in the CCT
finals we know your travel here was just
insane orderb so how are you feeling
today when did you get up this morning
um no I already forgot yesterday's so um
yeah I feel very good and I'm I feel in
very good shape so yeah I'm looking
forward to uh to Great to great day what
should we expect from the big battle
with your you know fellow generation ala
fusa here in the first round um yeah I
mean we should just see and watch how
how it goes and I think it will be a
very interesting battle and yeah I'm I'm
I'm ready
we're so happy you're here in not to be
best of luck today thank you thank
you I have to admit after such long
travel we know that he had a lot to get
here I expect to see someone who's more
tired less excited but Notre bck seems
fresh and ready of course it looks like
maybe works out a little bit you know
what I'm saying maybe working out a
little bit taking some stuff from you
Danny of course but also he's a young
kid and just working out doing his thing
man of course I think he's playing in
like having all these games playing so
much he's just used to it you know he
made a little jet lag but he'd be all
right well we know the players are about
to start playing games everyone saw
Magnus Carlson the goat enter behind us
we're going to get back to that matchup
in a little bit but there's a fourth one
we haven't had a chance to preview of
course that is Fabiano Carana versus
Maxim bash the grao the tail of the tape
here has two players the same age
they've been doing it for a long time
together playing chess at the highest
levels in the world but the CCT there
that stat at the end shows you how
consistent Fabi a Carana was everyone
knows Maxim B the grav got here because
of this epic Double match victory over
Magnus Carlson now behind me but Fabby
really was the more consistent player
throughout the year can't he absolutely
I mean being very consistent obviously
counts here you have fabbi and mvo they
almost kind of look alike through in the
different universes playing so many
games you just kind of blend together as
you see there right the Spider-Man meme
you you you right so but of course MV
being with the tactics as strong as he
is and probably with the calculation is
going to make a very great match up for
sure maybe a slight Edge to one if I if
I had to preview a matchup that I think
has the second highest likelihood to go
to Armageddon I actually do think it's
this one in the first round behind
Nakamura so these two guys both come in
here playing some of the best chess of
any two players in the world right now
Fabiano's rating surging back above 2800
this year as we talked about MBL got
here in just incredible fashion beating
Magnus twice at the AI cup it's really
hard to pick one of these two guys right
now maybe Maxim is the is the shakier
player historically in their career so
he needs to maybe get off to a start
maybe it's more imperative for him but
Fabiano is so consistent and again I
just I think this one has a good chance
of going the distance as well there's
gonna be tactics there I cannot wait to
see what happens in those games me you
have two games one and a half wins the
match anything can happen for
sure yeah all right well we saw Magnus
Carlson he's the first to arrive the
players have to get here early in order
to go through our fair play checks we're
going to talk a little bit more about
all the stuff we're doing there the fair
play checks are uh they're intense
they're a little intrusive and so
yesterday in the players meeting we kind
of did a random drawing of lots and and
the world champion had to go first there
uh the
the highest rated player of all time
getting set sitting and ready to play
but we've talked about everyone's road
to get here we' we've previewed the
matchups now let's remind everybody of
what's going to go down here in Toronto
what is the format how are we going to
ultimately arrive at a champion let's
let our explainer video take it
away the Champions chestor finals are
here eight players who have earned their
Spot Will face off in an epic battle to
determine who will be this year's
champion of champions up for grabs will
be $500,000 in prizes with first place
taking home $200,000 for the victory the
action opens with an eight player round
robin the top two finishers Advance
directly to the semi-finals while the
bottom two are eliminated the remaining
four players will do battle in a double
elimination survival bracket again the
top two players Advance while the bottom
two players will be eliminated the final
four Champions are headed to a single
elimination bracket the winner will be
crowned our champion of
champions
[Music]
it is going to be quite the gauntlet to
ultimately determine our 2023 Champions
chess tour Champion hopefully you you
understand what's about to go down here
in Toronto we're going to predict what
we think is going to happen in the first
round here in Toronto and KY Europe up
first predicting Magnus Carlson versus
Dennis lvic it's going to be a hard one
I got to go with Magnus got to go with
Magnus there to go right yeah 100% okay
going to disagree with that I'll go with
Magnus also Dennis the youngest one has
seemed a little nervous in the start
here I think Dennis would admit that he
probably is nervous and knows he's the
underdog so I don't think I'm going to
break any news there by also predicting
Magnus as the favorite in this one but
now let's move on to one that as I said
I think this is going to Armageddon your
thoughts on Nakamura versus so well on
your birthday it is proven that you get
100 ELO so in fact I'm going to go with
Nakamura is by birthday I mean hey
yeah well I'm going to break something
to you so in the sit down interviews I
did with the players I asked Wesley so
what was your reaction when you learned
it was going to be over the board and
Wesley said it's not over the board is
it he didn't know this was going to be
an OTB event so I'm going to put my
money on he car in this one I think
Wesley will be good either way online or
OTB but I'm also going to go with the
birthday boy although now I'm saying I'm
worried we're jinxing him on his
birthday but hikara Nakamura I think is
going to get this one because I think
it's going to go to Armageddon and I
think hikara will have the slight nod
there but all right Notre Beck versus
fuja notc Abdus turov versus Alli Reser
fuia your thoughts that's a hot match up
for sure of course class the Titans for
many years right but got to give the
edge to Ali resin for this one okay got
to go Al I was impressed with how fresh
upor of seeing when he got here but that
long travel I'm going to say Al Resa
it's funny I'm worried that we're all
agreeing too much I also thought the
travel might be something that Notre
Beck was struggling with though I admit
after talking to him last night seeing
him this morning maybe we're going to
regret this pick but I'm also going to
give the slight Edge to fuia last match
up we haven't talked about is Fabian o
Carana versus Maxine bash the grav KY
your thoughts he MVP mvl the p and a
kind of look the same so you know I'm
going to go with mvl here he's been very
sharp okay I'm going to agree with you
again so from those sit down interviews
one players stood out to me maximov he
seemed so calm so confident just in a
great state of mind I think he's going
to win this one I think this one is also
going to go to Armageddon these are two
friends two coin flips I don't know what
to say I'm actually going to give the
slight nod to Fabby I think it's going
to go to Armageddon I just feel like
something about the 2023 tour has felt
good to Fabby we saw the consistent
performance there so as hot as Maxim is
I'm I'm going to give the slight Edge to
fobby Levy what what do you think what
do you think Le what do you think
Buddy great answer great answer for
those who don't know Levy Rosman will be
joining us at some point here right now
the matchup is currently one- zero Co
over Levy but Levy will get here soon
don't worry we miss you Gotham but all
right it's time for us to throw to the
studio they will be having the chess as
the moves are about to be played here
from Toronto we'll see you in between
games our halftime report until then
Tanya and the boys across the sea take
it away
wow we've got some hot taks coming in
from Toronto and we'll keep checking in
with Danny and the Gang for all the
action happening on site first time ever
that I saw Magnus being the first to
arrive in the playing Arena yeah it
wasn't by choice he had to go through
the fair play scanning first so he was
at a seat first we got a very very cool
day of Chess coming up and there we see
Magnus Carlson who will be taking on the
17year old uh Dennis lazek as he gets
ready for what is well the tournament of
his life so far such a big platform for
the young Grandmaster and he starts the
day against the world number one and we
got Wesley at the back there yeah Wesley
looking pretty confident um he and
Hikaru have played each other countless
times they know what to expect uh we're
seeing the players trickle in now but
Dennis lavic the nerves imagine just 17
first time over the board getting stared
down by Magnus car
wouldn't want to be in his shoes and I
think the one guy who's happy to be here
is Wesley so one of his biggest career
wins the chess Global Championship
happened at this very spot where he took
down Hikaru Nakamura in the semi-finals
Robert what is the mindset for Wesley so
today taking on Hikaru at the very exact
playing Arena we caught up with Wesley
yesterday and he has fond memories of
Toronto he won a huge prize there by
beating hikaro in the semis Neil sarin
in the finals the tournament of his life
and you see Wesley there he's always
calm and Hikaru himself said no fun
playing that guy he rarely loses he's
that solid yeah for me it's about how
Hikaru reacts to it being his birthday
uh from my experience it's hard it's
hard to focus uh you want to be out
there you want to be celebrating you
want to be relaxing but nobody gives you
gifts over the chessboard what do you
think is Hikaru going to be able to
celebrate o that is the big question
Hikaru has been on fire it's hard to bet
against Hikaru now Hikaru versus Bley is
a rivalry that we are very used to
watching now one rivalry that we are
going to be seeing over the many coming
years is going to be Abdu satro who is
taking on Ali RZA fuja and nck is ready
to go waiting for his opponent how close
is this one to call well fua reached
2,800 everyone was talking about him but
when we look at these two players who
actually has the best title between them
it's the de abusar he won the world
rapid Championship a head of many of the
players who are sitting across the
boards in Toronto so Abdus satarov he is
unbothered unfazed undaunted he is a
champion in his own right and he's an
absolute Beast over the board they all
picked Alara I think that nybeck could
surprise people wow and as you said
Robert that NRE is ready to go he wants
a big start he is playing against his
colleague his compatriot the same
generation there is rivalry both players
feel
ambitious in this in their play this is
going to be fireworks now another big
favorite coming into this tournament is
the world number two in front of us
Fabiano Carana the reigning US champion
and what a fantastic year Fabby has had
just amazing incredible chess he's just
fresh out of his victory in the grand
chest store he's already booked his spot
into the 20 24 candidates and today he
will be playing against his good friend
the
2021 World rapid Champion he's up
against Maxim vasher lra they're friends
off the board but over theboard there's
no friendship you don't pull any punches
it doesn't matter who you are playing
fabbi knows that just as well as anyone
and Maxim VRA let's be honest he's on
fire the way he beat Magnus Carlson not
once but twice just to get here we know
what Maxim has in store for fabbi but
look at fabbi he's looking fresh as ever
I think he feels like everything's under
control yeah there's no friendship here
just breeed past his good friend
Christian Cilla he barely blinked he's a
man in form maybe the man of 2023
especially if it comes to classical
chess and both of these players have
such high ceilings for me it's about
whether Maxim can ride that wave of
beating Magnus whether he can keep that
form that confidence going if he can
it's going to be a big big match but uh
Fabiano I mean nobody can match him for
his results this year yeah and speaking
of ceilings the one player who needs to
raise his floor is Dennis lazic for the
first time he plays against the very
very best in the world over the ball
this is a huge huge platform for Dennis
Robert what does he need to do today to
make you think that he'd hang around
this week well we spoke to Dennis the
Menace yesterday he admitted that he's
nervous he's playing the best players on
the planet it's his first super
tournament like this but he's a boss
right this kid won title Tuesday when he
was 15 years old I was like who's that
then he's become a grandmas he's made
his way here through the series of
events he didn't win one but he was
consistent he's hard to beat he's kind
of a m mini Wesley in some ways he draws
a lot but he is very difficult to take
down and I think it's good that he plays
Magnus first because he's expected to
lose to Magnus so if he does lose he's
like H well okay let's get the next one
and speaking of that Magnus tends to be
a little shaky in the early rounds at
the early start could that give Dennis a
little bit of Hope here David yeah you
have to take hope where you can get it
when you're playing Magnus Carlson and
you're right Tanya historically
throughout the Champions chest tour
throughout other events it does take
Magnus a bit of time to click through
the gears uh to really hit Top form
Magnus looks pretty focused but uh yeah
Dennis he has to Hope and uh he can take
solace from his results throughout the
season online chess is of course
different over the board but uh he's got
a chance if he plays his best so Magnus
Carlson nothing but a t Victory would be
enough and one player who will be giving
her him a big fight for that another
huge favorite in the tour finals is
Hikaru Nakamura who is ready for his for
his big first round matchup the birthday
boy uh he's probably had his birthday
cake is he going to get it get to eat it
too he starts with the white pieces what
are we expecting in terms of opening
plan from Hikaru well hikaru's birthday
and he'll make Wesley cry if he wants to
because hikaro Nakamura sees Magnus as
the favorite he admitted that to us
yesterday but why not hikaro he has been
able to take down Magnus in extended
matches before against Wesley in the
opening probably a Berlin hopefully not
a Berlin draw though absolutely uh
Robert I think we're all hoping that we
don't get to see those early quick draws
by uh from Wesley with the black pieces
we've seen so much of that and uh we saw
some fair play checks earlier on Hikaru
takes his seat he's ready to go we're
all hoping for a not Berlin game but
Wesley he's so solid how do you create
your chances against him well uh we were
lucky enough to sit down with Hikaru
before the event and he was saying the
secret or one of the secret to his
success is the fact that he feels free
he can take risks in the opening he can
freestyle uh he can kind of bluff his
opponents everyone expects Hikaru to try
and stay in control but he's been
throwing out new openings this past year
um he's been playing every opening Under
the Sun pretty much and uh if you can
surprise wle that's the start yeah that
is definitely going to be part of the
agenda right in this format you want to
try to at least get your opponent to
think early on burn the clock a little
bit do you also feel that this is
perhaps a little bit of a grudge match
from Hikaru taking what happened exactly
a year go in this exact very spot yeah
Hikaru can say he literally doesn't care
all he wants but you know he cares that
Wesley so was the person who knocked him
out of the global Championship a year
ago for Wesley how did he win that match
he capitalized when when hikaro went all
in and at that moment the tables turned
Wesley was able to seize the advantage
win that and then win the whole thing so
for Hikaru he knows when to take his
chances and for Wesley he's always ready
yeah I think for Hikaru he might
actually enjoy the fact it's a shorter
match this year um Armageddon would
happen just after two games if it got to
that point and um that does lend itself
to thinking he might start solid
especially on his birthday you don't
want to maybe take too many risks but
we'll see we'll see he's looking calm
he's looking confident the players
getting ready to start any moment now
any moment now and we will see in just a
couple of moments as the fair play
checks are still on we've got two
players who are right now undergoing
that and I have a feeling that Magnus
cannot be too pleased about this
situation now he's someone who comes
barely second before the start of the
game sometimes not even on time today he
was the first to arrive through the fair
play checks and he's been on his seat
for quite a while this is not something
that makes Magnus Carlson happy I would
be happy seeing there it looks very cozy
right that looks like a very comfortable
chair so for Magnus he's settling in
he's taken on Dennis lawick but you know
this whole field is just so strong and I
think they're all anticipating the start
absolutely Rober and each one of them
has earned their spot right here and
Maxim VRA who had only one chance only
one opportunity uh to make it through to
uh Toronto and he did it and he did it
in style taking down Magnus Carlson the
only player to have done that throughout
the tour in the finals not once but
twice uh getting punching his ticket
into Toronto he starts against Fabby
we've been talking about Fab's form but
Maxim as well has been on fire he
finished second in the overall standings
of the grandchester had a big win in the
Tata Steel uh chess IND there a very
convincing performance we've seen him be
adventurous with his openings uh
throughout the season are we expecting
more opening surprises from Maxim in
this final possibly um it's going to be
hard to surprise Fabiano who's a
well-known opening expert who has ideas
everywhere but Maxim has freshened
things up and it's really helped him um
throughout this year by his own
admission he's still a bit inconsistent
some opening experiments haven't worked
out so well but uh yeah in Rapid chess
it really suits his strengths having a
well-formed repertoire yeah for Fabiano
it's hard to surprise him but Maxim by
his own admission he's been inconsistent
Maxim himself believes that when he's
playing his best chess and the whole
Chess World would agree with this he can
beat anybody Under the Sun but then he
gets Rocky at times and he doesn't keep
that form we saw his classical rating
take a huge nose dive and he knows that
he has what it takes to get back to the
top five in the world we'll see if he
can start that Trek here in
Toronto these players are ready to go
now the one player who is waiting for
his opponent is nck Abdu s of as Ali
resa fuja is undergoing fa checks not
anymore it's handshakes and that is our
final eighth player who takes his spot
what you call being fashionably late
look at Ali reaza there there's so much
talk about his new career in fashion and
we spoke with him he is interested in
fashion but he's focused on the chess
yeah and chess is fashionable Alara is
fashionable and I think starting these
games would be uh on point right now
we're ready the handshakes you can see
the players we're off
we are off and Magnus Carlson he starts
with 1 D4 against Dennis lawick yeah you
just see the players I I'm just always
interested how they make their first
three moves because some people they
spend a little bit time others they slam
the first stage of the game but we do
see a Queens Pawn opening from Magnus
Carlson I wonder how Dennis is going to
play this game yeah solid has been uh
his trademark throughout this season
Dennis lavic uh we see him open as black
with the Queen's Gambit the Queen's
Gambit declined Rock Solid stuff Magnus
trades off a set of Pawns in the center
um really interesting that neither
player really showing too much speed
with the way they're moving looks quite
lethargic if anything the way they're
moving the pieces uh just calm start to
this game Robert and I'm looking at
Dennis who's holding his head already I
think something that he admitted to was
that when he's playing online he's not
looking at his opponent but here he has
Magnus Carlson the highest rated chess
player in history across from him and he
probably just doesn't want to look at
Magnus he said I'm going to focus on the
board let's be Ive about things let's
pretend it's off uh I was going to say
offline chess online chess even this is
offline chess over the board of course
but Dennis so strong uh with a mouse so
strong when it's online and okay this is
interesting black already ambitiously
attacking White's Bishop um this Knight
on the rim far from dim and uh a bit of
a rare position forcing Magnus to take
the first real think of this game I like
the choice because he is being very
clear in his intentions I want to take
that Bishop off the board and claim the
two Bishops Advantage the best players
in the world they prefer to have a pair
of Bishops rather than a knight and a
bishop it's equal in terms of point
value but Bishops longer range pieces so
Magnus is actually sitting in for a
think here David why would he be
surprised by Knight H5 yeah I'm shocked
Magnus is Big expert in this opening
with white and with black and to
surprise the world number one will be a
big psychological success for lavic um
either Magnus is totally shocked and is
out of book and has messed up his move
order or he just knows too much about
this position and is trying to juggle
trying to way up which option to go for
white of course doesn't even need to
move the bishop it is protected by a
pawn uh White has various squares for
that Bishop to retreat to move to even
go and capture Black's Knight over on B8
uh so I think Magnus probably not that
surprised uh but certainly not looking
too warm right now as he weighs up this
decision yeah as you said getting your
Bishop captured is not the end of the
world and black has spent too tempy with
that Knight so black has not castled the
king white has three pieces out black
just has two you can bring that fourth
and last minor piece in the game
developing your light Square bishop and
you see Magnus has take my Bishop on
four let's first go with the queen now
he's flexible David is he thinking about
cast and queenside definitely Magnus
Carlson uh he's Universal by in his own
words in terms of style he can play any
style especially I noticed against lower
rated players he takes risks he plays
provocative moves and uh always the most
ambitious ones so um yeah interesting
moment I would never dabble in anything
like this I'm a much more classical
player but Magnus he's really putting
pressure on lavic at don't know stage
it's smart play by him because he is
trying to put the ball in lzic court and
now there are going to be double pawns
on the board that sounds like a bad
thing but inherent to having double
pawns open files and also there's a four
on3 Pawn majority for white on the
king's side and if Black's King Ventures
on over there then we could see the
makings of an attack and this is exactly
the kind of outcome that we want out of
the opening a non-standard position
where there's already an imbalance with
a knight versus Bishop trade so we know
that it is going to be a well fought
middle game one of the things that sets
danis lack apart from his uh colleagues
his young colleagues is that his
positional style his strategic play and
Magnus Carlson how do you find your
chances of defeating the world's
greatest player with that style will um
tennis lack with the black pieces be
able to hold on in this one and make a
go of it with the white pieces in the
next round we will keep an eye out on
this one but we've also got moves coming
in from our other big matchups and let's
check in with the two players who have
been recently on fire and that's a
position on fire already a very
different front one from where we just
left there's a White Queen on 86 what
has happening here this is a crazy
position if you're new to it um this is
actually uh deep Theory old theory in
the grunfeld defense one of Maxim Vash
lra's favorite openings he's the world
leading expert in this one Fabiano
testing him going right for the attack
going for that black king which is a bit
vulnerable White's King meanwhile as
castle of Queen side it's wild it's
crazy uh level material for now but
anything can happen Rob I just watched
Maxim roll up his sleeves here his
understanding of this position his
pregame knowledge that preparation it's
just getting started and we're in a
position where both kings are looking
vulnerable the black king has that White
Queen sitting menacingly in front of it
and then the white King on C1 it doesn't
have so many Pawns in front of it so
there are open diagonals open lines this
one is getting very spicy because it's
getting so spicy if uh I was Maxim
vasher lra right now unfortunately I'm
not but if I was I would want to get rid
of that Queen on H6 a queen to F4 give a
check try and trade off the Queens
because I'm just really scared about
black king coming under so much fire
once that white knight jumps to G5 or
the H Pawn Harry the H Pawn H4 H5 coming
in uh is this the moment you try and
bail out with a check yeah I think you
might have to uh at least now if not now
then in the next few moves there's one
trick as well we should point out Tanya
you cannot play night takes Knight you
cannot take this white knight off the
board because look whoops loose pieces
drop off lpdo as uh Daniel always says
uh this would be a bishop check a
discovered check and once the bishop was
captured Black's Queen would disappear
white would emerge with a decisive
material advantage so yeah you got to
get rid of pieces you got to get rid of
attackers not this night however uh
trading Queens looks by far the most
sensible move but is it Maxim's style it
does he want to head for the end game he
would force the Queens off the board
that was a check and uh maybe at the
very end white would win a pawn still
some calculation to be done you just
have to weigh up whether you're
surviving this end game and black is
kind of playing without those Queen side
pieces so even if you trade pieces off
the board get to what looks like it
might be an appealing end game it's not
a full end game just yet because there
are so many Rooks on the board and minor
pieces and black is not fully developed
and that Center could collapse as you're
indicating so I would be nervous if I
were Maxim here and that's why he's
taking his time I said he was still in
preparation maybe he's out of it and he
reaches out and he doesn't trade the
Queens in fact he falls back with it to
a square to defend the seventh rank 87
is protected he step steps out of all
the checks the Discover checks along the
D line David that you were pointing at
and I think you raised a really good
point there that Queen to F4 feels like
the most human move and you really want
to make it because you don't want to
come under Fire with your King on G8 but
is it really Maxim style to go into an
end game well it wasn't his style
apparently but maybe it should have been
in this position because suddenly look
at the eval bar it's really risen for
white and you could imagine an attack
Brewing already uh the typical thrust of
Harry the hbor the hbor marching up the
board opening up this Rook on the H file
one more move and Black's King side
would fall apart the shelter would be
wrecked here so already Maxi might be
living to regret this decision real bit
I don't like Black's position at all I
think White's play looks quite natural
as you said throw the H Pawn forward
what can go wrong the black king is
going to be in some huge danger the
Knight can join the party as you're
indicating and at some point this Knight
on C3 can also jump into D5 and if you
trade the bishop suddenly opens up
towards the black king I'm worried for
Maxim in this position he's kind of
living on the edge it's his style but
Fabiano's proven in the past like
including in the candid tournament
sometimes he just out prepares Maxim
yeah dangerous position and uh it's just
one of those cases of wow Maxim away
from the board I just noticed well very
rare thing to do and very brave thing to
do in Rapid chess but uh I think he'll
realize how bad his position is if and
when Carana pushes the H Point yeah
maybe sometimes when you feel your
position is so bad that the only option
you have left is actually to walk out of
it and just to get up and leave but we
see he is coming back as action is just
getting started in this one Fabiano
Carana for the first time takes a pause
he can feel that he's got the momentum
going in this one an attack we're
expecting from the white side black
really can be in big danger in just the
next couple of moves once the H Pawn
starts moving forward uh Robert yeah and
there's just one thing I noticed you
mentioned lpdl loose pieces drop off
that Knight on B6 is not defended so
Pawn H4 as David was calling for
followed by Pawn H5 that Knight on B6 is
actually in the line line of fire from
the queen on H6 so uh so that could
actually be to Fabiano's Advantage here
just to quickly show a line H4 Bishop G4
thinking you're stopping Pawn H5 I still
push my Pawn forward and once you take
my Pawn with your Bishop I sacrifice my
Rook for that piece and then you look
not at the H5 Pawn but the B6 Knight the
queen gathers it and white wins the
game this is actually a really important
variation Robert and uh easy to miss
from afar but Maxine vasra in big big
trouble if Fabiano throws his H Pawn
forward and uh I guess we'll check back
on this one in a bit we will uh David
and H4 does look like the most natural
most tempting move that you want to make
in this position we will come back to
this but we've got moves on the other
boards as well let's check in with the
two youngsters nbec Abdus satov taking
on Ali Resa fuja a very different
position from the one that we just left
and this is a Berlin end game Berlin
endgame Queens off the board black has
the bishop pair but black does have a
fractured structure and a slightly oddl
looking King uh Black's King gets in the
way often of uh the Rooks connecting the
Rooks coming to the center and White's
Knight on D5 Robert White's Knight in
the center looks really strong right now
uh who would you pick I love the last
move Rook to A2 though from nck because
that Bishop on F5 was trying to go into
C2 the B3 Pawn is the base of White's
position if the Rooks go off the board
white could just be losing at that point
because of how weak that pawn is but
Rook A2 covers the square tries to
double slice across the second rank I
actually really like Abdu cataro's
position
yeah he's up on the clock as well just
uh putting paid to the fact that he had
that long journey he looks fresh he
looks sharp and this position despite
the fact Queens are off really dangerous
for black black needs to be accurate to
keep the balance just amazing uh
fighting Spirit there by nbec Abdus
satov this one's going to be a big
battle but NC has already had quite the
battle coming to Toronto and we're going
to head over to Kaaya who had a chat
with nck on his journey to the season
and final what it means to him H and how
he got here Ka what
happened yeah it's been quite dramatic
Tanya so I spoke to Notre Beck yesterday
he left usbekistan on November 30th to
come here to Toronto in Canada he uh
left for Berlin and he had to stay there
for a week waiting for his visa to be
approved when he finally was approved
after a week in Berlin uh his plane was
cancelled of course uh when he did we
finally uh got on a plane here to
Toronto that arrived here way past
midnight yesterday I mean imagine the
jet lag he must be be feeling the
fatigue and it's been quite dramatic we
didn't know up until very last minute if
Notre Beck would be able to participate
here in the CCT finals but he has been
so determined to actually get here to
participate in the finals to be here
with the best players in the world so
let's see Tanya how this works out for
him if he is fresh if he is ready to be
here and fighting wow thanks L wow that
is absolutely crazy a week to get his
WEA sorted and then we had the chat with
him before the start of the round and he
said he's already put that past him and
he's ready to go these youngsters have
insane amount of energy and passion for
the game there's endless determination
when you think of nck Abdus satar the
way that he looks at the chest board the
way he stares his opponent down and just
the way he plays and when we were
covering the event in Kolkata time and I
had the call and nck was offered a draw
in a position where he was down upon and
he said no he just wants to fight every
single move of every single game give
him a lot of credit I love the way he's
playing chess overall I love his
position this game with those Pawns in
the center I mean he has a shot to take
this whole thing absolutely and I think
a lot of that will have to do with how
these two start we had a chat earlier on
with Hikaru where he mentioned when it
comes to nbec and when it comes to Ala
uh if they get the momentum going if
they're able to get those early wins on
They Can Go the Distance they can will
the win the whole thing but it's also
easy for these two to go on a tilt so
this match is so important for the for
the 19-year-old NC and the 20-year-old
Ali Rea fuja and of course uh the other
match that is that we've got our eyes on
is Hikaru Nakamura taking on Wesley so
so much history between these two
players this is no end game this is no
Berlin uh this is fire on the board yes
it is and uh this actually looks right
quite peaceful right now compared to
what we had just two three moves ago so
I actually want to do a quick action
replay on some of the crazy tactics that
Wesley so threw at Hikaru Nakamura and
uh then we'll catch up with the current
position just a few moves back uh here
white developed uh his Queen Hikaru and
now gave a check it looks like a deadly
check hitting the king hitting the
Knight as well but this was simply
blocked um wow nice to have the player
mics there that wasn't me I promise uh
black simply blocked with a bishop this
is a peace Sacrifice from Wes so if
Queen takes Knight however this is not a
blunder simply Rook to C8 sliding across
and this is a effective skewer hitting
the queen and if the queen moves no
matter where she moves this check will
be devastating white has forgotten to
Castle and The Rook will drop off in the
corner this is beautiful vision and
after Bishop takes Bishop the same
tactic persisted Queen takes again Queen
takes Knight this was a poisoned piece
and this would have been a winning
tactic hitting the queen and a simple
check winning the game Hikaru had to
dodge these tricks he had to Castle and
if we catch up with the current position
now the offer of a queen trade what do
we think who would this favor I think
this is going to shock everybody but
this game is looking very level I think
these two players there's just not much
between them there's little separation
we saw the overall record in Rapid
heavily in hikaro favor that surprised
me because every time I see them play it
looks like they're making draws I hate
to call that uh to be the likely outcome
but we're looking at this position it's
evenly matched between these two y
relatively balanced hor structure here
not too many uh kind of deficiencies in
either side's position I'm looking at
Black's Bishop it does have great
potential but uh yeah on the face of
things when we look at these two players
Hikaru Wesley it's hard to imagine any
big blunders here uh looking relatively
even Tanya prove us wrong tell us what
we're missing I'm listening to you guys
and I want to always agree with what you
two say but I have to say it still looks
like there's fire in this one there is
some poison in this one you pointed out
the bishop uh the pond structure it's
even material but it's it's not com
completely symmetrical and white also
has control on the D file the knight
from B1 can come on to D2 can find a
nice post on the C4 Square yes I I would
agree with Danny's earlier prediction
that this is a match that's most likely
to go into an Armageddon but I think
there's still a lot to happen there and
this is a quick action replay of where
what's happening I can tell everyone
what just happened when they're playing
over the board and someone slides a
piece sometimes they kind of press it
against the square so looked like Queen
D4 happened that would have been a queen
blunder it said the queen went to E4 a
safe Square offering a queen trade Queen
trade declined the game continues no
Queen blunders here I like that I like
that the queen trade has been declined
it means it's going to be still a fun a
fun middle game there's a check on B5
being threatened it might be time for
black to consider getting the king to
safety go shots side Castle eventually
we might see the fbon advance to F5 to
open up the bishop now the queen on e4
yes you offered a trade but what you
also did was put the queen on a
vulnerable Square when hi AR's Knight
does come out it hits the queen on e4
from C3 or from the D2 Square we will
keep a check on this one as the players
continue to Blitz out their moves F5
without Castle does that surprise you
David it doesn't surprise me that Wesley
is being ambitious actually because it
looks like he's got a very solid
position and we will come back to that
one uh roughly objectively balanced but
uh still alive as you say Tanya in the
mean time Magnus Carlson against Dennis
lazovic this is heating up it's a crazy
position and it has evolved massively
since the last time we were here Dennis
lazic actually has some holes to look at
near magnus's King but Magnus does have
some beautiful Knights right now those
Knights are outclassing the Bishops in
many ways we typically say The Bishop's
Advantage there're two of them and white
has none and yet that Knight on C5 is
about to chop off the bishop on e4 down
it goes and even though black seems to
have good play around the white king I'm
more concerned about Black's Pawn
structure those are some weak pawns
double isolated eyes swords on the a
file the isolated C pawn and if black
can push through an E3 push and shatter
White's structure on the king side maybe
you'll have some chance to attack but I
do see the long-term Advantage here for
Magus Carlson really nicely pointed out
and that black queen it really doesn't
have that much assistance to actually
create threats against the white king
not traditional chess knowledge right
David is that you should place your Pawn
on the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop but here what Magnus has done is
actually placed a lot of his pawns on
the dark squares because the good side
of that is that you limit your
opponent's Bishop's AC activ ity and
what is he doing instead he is just
going to attack the weaknesses that you
pointed out Robert Black's Bishop
doesn't really have those many Targets
in the position White's Rook sliding
onto C1 doubling up it just looks like
it's the kind of position that Magnus
Carlson is going to enjoy and grind down
eventually yeah at least to me it feels
like Magnus he's a different generation
he's of course the favorite here he's
actually taking as much risk out of the
position as possible and he's just
playing strategically he's just uh as
you say tan trying to kind of limit
Black's Bishop trying to go for those
weak pawns and I don't really see uh
black ever winning this game and in a
two result situation where you have that
safety net of bailing out for a draw you
have quite a calm uh kind of position
where you can improve with very simple
natural moves that's where Magnus really
thrives uh it feels like Dennis tough
start to this game there's just no
weaknesses in White's position maybe the
D4 Pawn it's isolated itself it's on a
dark Square so the bishop on f8 in the
future can go after with a pawn F5 push
Bishop Bishop G7 and so on but with the
black king being where it is maybe it's
going to be exposed you might need to
trade the Queens but the black queen is
doing such a good job defending the
vulnerable pawns I just hate that
queenside pawn structure if you could
put that A6 Pawn back on B7 we're
talking about a whole different position
but with it those pawns split the way
they are it's all White's fun right now
he's already going for those pawns um
I'm slightly surprised by this one I
must admit because it does hang this
Pawn on A2 um perhaps this Pawn is not
as relevant as uh some of the other
pawns we're looking at in the position
but Dennis he's playing very quickly
I've got to say um it looks so tempting
to capture this Pawn if you take it okay
he hasn't taken it um if just if we go
back taking this Pawn I guess would have
allowed this Central Pawn to drop and
Black's Queen is so far distance from
its King right now that maybe this is
just a bit too risky but uh yeah Dennis
here taking some risks uh both
strategically and now dynamically he's
hitting this Pawn in the center okay
he's not dead yet he it's uh far from
decided I think we all would take white
here but uh he's fighting yeah he has
great chances because he's Dennis lzic
and the guy does not lose very often and
he also has a lot of experience so his
age may be small in number just 17 but
he's played so many different online
events that he gets that experience
trying to defend tough positions against
the best on the planet and now the night
is gone so the more pieces that come off
the board I think the more likely that
we have a peaceful result yeah I think
take that pawn Dennis that A2 Pawn that
I was highlighting try and remove uh as
much material from the board as possible
uh because essentially you're left with
weaknesses and longterm if you're
suffering you have to speed up the game
short term he's just been doing great I
mean considering his lack of experience
at this level over the board still
having 5 minutes left in a relatively
complicated position I think he's
actually going to save this one o that's
going to be a massive massive start for
the young grandm if he uh gets the draw
with the black pieces we will come and
check in on this one but things are
getting exciting on uh the Fab Maxim
Vash lra board it's the end game we've
got a Pawn on eav just one step uh just
one step away from uh becoming a queen
but it looks like Black's got enough
resources to keep things under control
the black king extremely close to that
E7 Pawn can start coming to F6 already
start targeting the pawn I'm just
counting the pawns really quickly so
it's even material both sides have Rook
bishop and Five Pawns that wasn't
immediately obvious to me and that E7
Pawn is it a strength is an asset about
to promote or is it a weakness because
black can try to bring the king closer
but I love the positioning of White's
pie if you bring your king up to F6 The
Rook on E1 jumps right next to it hits
the king with check also attacks the
queen side so I would say that white
still has some Chan to win this game
because of Peace activity yeah it looks
like that white porn uh it's very strong
at first then you think oh maybe it's a
weakness but uh it's really unclear and
I think it will come down to who
Maneuvers better in the next few uh
turns but yeah right now it's hard for
Maxi vasra it's roughly level on the
clock he just needs to find a few
accurate moves and it should be safe
enough we see the evaluation bar planted
in the center means it should be a draw
with best play but enough material for
now to cause some problems but the more
we look into this position the more it
becomes clear that it's not so easy for
black to actually start targeting the E7
Pawn because of the threat that you
pointed out of The Rook jumping onto E6
so it looks like Fabby has placed his
pieces beautifully the bishop on D5 Rook
on E1 coordinating perfectly well but
the question is how do you make progress
from here if Maxim just plants that
Bishop on8 stopping the pawn from
progressing any further The Rook on A7
ties down the active Rook on E1 to
defend the E7 Pawn yes you can go King
to F6 next but also Fabby how are you
making progress here well the essential
question is what are Black's moves going
to be and the bishop can't move because
the pawn promotes The Rook can't slide
to D7 because then white has Bishop C6
hitting the rook and the bishop behind
it so black doesn't really have moves at
least not obvious ones that I see so
maybe you try to improve this location
of your king maybe push a pawn here and
there and I don't see many options for
black black could run out of move so he
goes King F6 on the live board he's
giving up the queenside pawns and wow
his King is getting very active wow it's
getting very active but yeah giving up
these pawns feels fraught with danger
long term Fabian is going to go capture
them and watch out for this a pawn
marching up the board later if the
blackborn ever disappears so uh this one
really heating up in the end game now
White's up a pawn I was having trouble
counting before now I think it's pretty
obvious that The Rook takes A6 that will
be an extra Pawn for white and as you
point out David not just any pawn it's
an outside pass Pawn that will be
supported by the rook and that Bishop on
D5 maybe it'll slide back to E4
eventually the pawn and Bishop will
defend one another but it covers the A8
promotion Square this looks really
challenging for maxim unless he has a
quick initiative that will help him
survive yeah would you say this is
common theme in Maxim's games every time
I see him with black he's a porn down
and uh he's going active of course he's
prioritizing uh kind of Peace activity
but it's risky in this type of position
he barely thought about this massive
massive moment I agree with you David
though that this is Maxim style he's not
one who we think about when we talk
about passive defense he's always
looking for the initiative trying to get
rid of any lack of space lack of peace
activity even if it comes at the cost of
a pawn and that's what he just did he
sacrificed a pawn for King activity
getting rid of that E7 Pawn uh one idea
one plan that comes to mind for black is
of course you want to try and trade off
as many pawns as possible when on the
defense in these kind of positions I'm
at some point expecting those kingside
Pawns of Maxim the H and the g Pawn to
start moving up the board to challenge
that F Pawn that Fabby has to try to
destabilize that Bishop on e4 the big
question to me right now is do you go
ahead with that King to F4 start pushing
the G Pawn ahead then and strike with G4
is that a defensive plan I think we'll
see it on the B that would be right up
Maxim's alley just a very kind of linear
plan active pieces compensates for the
uh potential Pawn deficit but suddenly
he's paused it feels like he should have
paused earlier before going down this
route uh he's kind of walked down this
Alleyway and the there only one thing at
the end there uh he could have uh yeah
there was a fork in the road I don't
think he needed to rush for this Robert
he's in trouble and that move Bishop E4
check that's a great inclusion by
Fabiano so many of us myself included we
just taking the pawn on A6 why not steal
a free Pawn nothing's defending it but
instead he closes down the open file
from that Rook by giving the king a
check so the King has to move now and
only after the king moves you take the
pawn that is what the best players on
the planet do is they don't rush their
decisions over the board they make this
little intermediate move little in
between move and then grab the pawn so
it's captured under the best possible
circumstances yeah maybe Maxi missed
this uh just to prove your point Rook
takes porn and black would get active
black would come down with a check and
maybe slide behind and big big
counterplay so this has been eradicated
and Maxim now realizing he is in massive
danger in this game really nice
technique there by Fabiano Kyan and
finally Maxim VRA does go for the plan
that we discussed he wants to try and
trade off the pawns on the king decide
to make sure that his chances of
securing the draw uh increase in this
position meanwhile there is a lot of
action on the nardack fuja endgame it
started as a Berlin but the position
that I have uh in front of me on my
screen right now and there we see the
two players who are fighting it out it
looks like a crazy outcome of a Berlin
and definitely needs a deep dive full
concentration there look at that wow
Robert's pairing forward here I think
we're doing a material C we're wondering
how white Pawn suddenly magically got so
far up the board both players look super
focused Abdu satov here he's up on the
clock and up a material yeah he's up a
pawn and up about 2 minutes on time but
that D6 Pawn at some point black will
consider chopping everything off you
take the Knight first then you start
taking the pawn but that doesn't solve
all of your problems because that pawn
that was just captured by white is an
outside Pawn The Rook Pawn there's
long-term potential for white to move
the bishop out the way start running
pawns up the board and then we may see
an outside pass Pawn cause black some
problems so the king moves away the
Pawn's captur on C7 David why is white
not just up awn here I'm struggling to
understand here Robert as well I've
played the Berlin uh from the black side
my whole life and this looks like a
disaster you're just a pawn down I think
what he might have to rely upon after uh
trading off a set of Rooks winning one
of the pawns back is that he does have a
trick maybe he can push forward with B5
start throwing queenside pawns forward
because white is a bit vulnerable on the
light squares over here and actually we
see this whole variation play out for
example if white is slow if white just
makes a kind of random move B5 I think
would create enough counterplay to hold
the balance undermining the protection
of this night and counterplay for the
first time so it's not oneway traffic
yet that is a great find and Tanya when
I see something like that I'm like I
that was not even on my radar it's so
instructive right you want to try and
Target the base here and that's a
understanding that that's the B3 Pawn
holding that Knight on C4 that's such a
strong piece so B5 you sacrifice a pawn
again for piece activity
and for all these guys at the top it's
so much about this active defense in
these formats they're never just trying
to hold a position passively but finding
ways to create these Dynamic chances so
David in this position if white was to
advance on the king side try and make
something of the pawn majority it will
be time for Ali razza to try and strike
with B5 and that threat has been stopped
with this L move targeting the A5 Bond
really classy move there White's Bishop
was looking pretty on the edge of the
board but it's dropped back and actually
as you mentioned Tanya it's got an eye
on Black's Queens Side Pawn so trying to
slow down black on that flank on that
side of the board and uh yeah these
players that always not just focused on
their own ideas White's idea for example
to throw kingside pawns forward but they
were also balancing that out with their
opponent's threats and um this move
perhaps missed by fuia has caused him to
think and now down to one minute on the
clock that is the big element of this
position is about a minute left for
black you're down upon Pawn in your head
sometimes like how do how I get that
pawn back what can I do you may make a
quick choice you don't have time to
calculate everything and those pawns on
the queen excuse me on the king side for
white you could start throwing up the
board G4 maybe an H4 and F4 and there
could be a Pawn St you have four on two
majority on that flank yeah and uh we've
seen throughout this season players get
down to one minute living on the
increment but over the board it's far
more difficult we might start seeing
pieces fly uh we'll see the hands start
to shake and having one minute over the
board is no time at all this is getting
really dramatic now especially for fuja
has the pawn start flying forward
already for white as Robert predicted it
just feels like so much easier to play
with white you've got a straight up plan
you start pushing the F Pawn next F4 F5
coming up uh and David as you said over
the board with a minute so hard because
you don't have the option to pre-move
anymore you've got to be quick on that
and this position is going to be a
difficult one for ala but we know just
what a speed chest specialist he is he's
still eyeing that idea of trying to get
the B5 break in uh the other player
Who's down to a minute on the clock is
Dennis lazovic against Magnus Carlson
but it looks like Dennis with the black
pieces has managed to equalize
neutralize magnus's pressure look at
that it's he's going to lose that deep
Pawn or rookie 2 King after he ends up
losing that deep Pawn but it's not going
to be enough for Magnus yeah look at the
Evo bar it's in the middle saying that
this should be a draw but should is the
key word in my sense there Magnus
Carlson has won more draw positions like
that sometimes I feel like he could win
King versus King and the Rooks are
sliding across the board look at Dennis
bringing his Rook to an open file he
should hold this this is a position
where white can't create an Easy Pass
Pawn but if Dennis allows the trade of
Pawns on the king side then mag would
have winning chances yeah this is not
the position this is the position from
fuja Abdu satoro against Abdu satoro
let's hopefully get up this Magnus game
right now uh where okay we suddenly see
the eval bar we need to jump straight
away to the Magnus board let's bring up
the Magnus versus Dennis lasic as we see
the evalar shoot right up what happened
there it probably was I this keeps
happening today when players are moving
on a dgt board sometimes it gets stuck
on a square but it actually went back
and forth so we will try as soon as we
can to bring up the game between Dennis
and Magnus because if Dennis can hold
the number one player in the world to a
draw with the black piece is maybe he
could even take this match when he gets
white in game two and meanwhile ala fza
he broke with B5 in this game and it's
abusar on the clock but uh yeah this
game between mags and Dennis that will
be exciting yeah that will be exciting
it is a rook end game and there are
notoriously drawish Tendencies there and
there we saw the chair that the players
are sitting on comfy stuff trust me I've
had the uh luck to sit on one of them
myself and in the meantime um okay here
we get a playthrough of the game the
Magnus game for those who are really
fast of mind you can follow this but um
this is the current position I actually
believe Black's Rook is on a rather than
C8 behind Black's pass Pawn so let's not
trust the eval bar right now black is
holding this one Black's Rook on A8
makes the white Rook passive whites Rook
simply cannot move and I think this is
going to be a simple draw for Dennis
lazovic even with 10 seconds on the
clock even with 10 seconds on the clock
I think his moves are very easy white
doesn't have a clear plan and you start
thinking when your opponent has
something that they can do and The Rook
is definitely on eight and that's what
probably cause the problems when you
slide a rook from E8 to A8 sometimes it
get stuck on C8 sorry for the technical
issue but Dennis laic he's having no
issues at the moment he is holding on
against Magus Carlson y he is going to
draw this one you can see Dennis despite
the fact he has 10 seconds doesn't look
too stressed uh head in hands but he's
making the moves getting them out in
time and okay there is a critical moment
on this board we have had a few moves
since uh we see them happening maybe we
just get a up close camera on the
players on the board right now let's try
and zoom in let's try and zoom in let's
get a closeup shot of the board if we
can because this is the critical moment
can Dennis lazic secure a draw Magnus
Carlson is he down to a second what
happened there no shot no shot so we
apologize uh for what's going on we can
zoom in on the players there we see
Dennis lazic hunched over the board
there Magnus Carlson trying to figure
things out the Aon is gone the white
King has sprinted over there but if I'm
looking at this position correctly uh
White has two pawns remaining on the
king side and is there one next to that
black king that's the big question no
it's two pawns against zero so Magnus is
two pawns ahead but the white king is
cut off the white king is so far away
from protecting its porns and the
question is whether D Dennis can make
the most of that he's playing moves with
under 10 seconds on his clock he's going
for the white pawns now but he cannot
win them black king also unable to make
Headway towards those pawns maybe Magnus
now has the time to bring his King if
white can coordinate if white can use
his whole Army together he's simply
going to walk the pawns down the board
and it feels like that's going to be the
case you just start bringing your king
closer to the king side pawns because
black never has the opportunity to
actually pick up one of the pawns and
trade the Rooks all King Pawn endings
will be lost but there's something very
smart that Dennis lzic is doing he's
trying to provoke a pawn push because
then his King will step in front of it
and the King may go forward now the the
rook and king can team up on a pawn but
you can't capture it because if the
Rooks get traded then the other Pawn
will Sprint to the other side and become
a queen so Dennis is hoping for he's
trying to get some kind of Fortress
where the pawns can't go forward but it
looks like magnus's King it's venturing
closer and closer and after Rook F5
check here it looks like it's going to
be done in magnus's favor yeah even
without using the white king now as long
as the white keep King keeps itself safe
uh the pawns and Rook actually guide
each other towards the promotion Square
so Magnus has this he doesn't even need
to show much sophistication here
unfortunately for Dennis I think he had
the draw in his hands but the time the
clock that's it handshakes and Magnus
Carlson takes the lead with a win Dennis
lack so close to securing that draw yeah
so close yet so far unfortunately the
result is 1 in magnus's favor but Dennis
lvic he should be proud of the way he
played he got himself in time trouble he
actually still had drawing chances just
a few moves before the game ended but
the game is over Magnus is our first
winner here at the Champions chess tour
but they will get another game and
Magnus Carlson stops by to take a look
at the Ali rzan NB board he's got to be
pleased with that outcome Magnus Carlson
with his endgame touch wins it and let's
head over to the two players in front of
us who are still fighting it out duking
it out in an end game and Wesley so
makes that move with just a second on
the clock wow things are really heating
up we hear the pieces being knocked over
as Wesley starts to fidget nerves
jangling it looks like Wesley's actually
doing extremely well on the board but no
time and it's a scramble and you see the
players they're both nervous here Wesley
slamming down that move slapping the
clock Hikaru shakes his head there's
Magnus Carls the number one player
looking on and iar doesn't know what to
do so he brings a rook back and look at
Wesley go David ising looking really
good for Wesley Wesley is two pawns up
uh I'm hoping at some point we are able
to show you some of the highlights of
this one but Wesley two pawns up right
now Black's King is actually deep in
enemy territory and unless hikaro pulls
A Mir Miracle here Wesley will take this
game and russley is just knocking off
all the pieces not only on the board but
off the board as well you can feel the
nerves right the atmosphere the the
tension and uh moves being played so
quickly here uh we see on the small
board on your right the current position
Wesley's actually had to give material
back Black's king would have been
trapped otherwise and suddenly hikaru's
back in it he's got two Rooks against
one he's the exchange up but black does
still have those two extra pawns
unbelievably resourceful is hikara
Nakamura it's his birthday maybe he'll
get a gift because he was losing earlier
and if Wesley had more time he would
have been able to secure that point but
instead he's pushing pawns for in the
Queens side Rooks are running across the
board but I'd be most concerned for aaru
as that pawn on H3 looks so dangerous oh
it does but look at that black king it's
being chased to the edge of the board
now if white lands a rook on the H file
this is Checkmate massive threat on the
board Rook to h8 trapping the black king
you have to block the G file bringing
your own Rook to G3 you've got to find a
way to get out of that uh mating trap he
plays it but now Hikaru has a draw at
his disposal if he wants it have
anything more David he's going to go for
it I think Rook h8 is coming up it's so
hard to imagine with that pawn on H3
just two steps away this is looking
dangerous if you go for more he's going
for more he's going for more in this
position threatening mate again check
mate but Wesley just gets his King out
and Black's winning CaRu he gambled he
bluffed and the bluff was called
Wesley's porn is simply going to March
down the board oh my go there's no mate
the bishop slides back and you see a car
resign Wesley so the magic continues in
Toronto wow what drama
believable Wesley so does it he takes
down Hikaru Nakamura takes the lead in
his match Hikaru could have repeated the
position bailed out taken the draw but
going for more losers Hikaru he's going
to regret that losing with white against
Wesley so is uh what not to do
essentially and he should have taken the
draw he could have taken the draw Wesley
look at that bounce in his step as he
walks
out what catch our breath what a run
this has been just from start to finish
just incredible stuff all around danis
lazic almost holding Magnus Carlson the
incredible game the incredible end to
the Hikaru Wesley matchup what's the dot
for you robt well history repeating
itself in Toronto Wesley so was the
recipient of Hikaru nakamura's ambition
a year ago beat him in the global
Championship went on to win the whole
thing in that game Hikaru could have
made a draw by putting his Rook back and
forth black had no choice yet he wanted
more he tried to checkm his opponent
there was no mate to be had Wesley gets
the win Fabiano also got a win we didn't
even look at that but he played a great
game great games all around too many
moments to pick from David what what was
the highlight for you I think we need an
action replay of that game between
hikara Nakamura and Wesley so Robert
broke it down really well but let's put
those moves on the board and it was here
where black is actually up on material
black has three pawns and a bishop for
White's Rook however Black's King is in
Mortal danger and uh after a couple of
checks we saw a big threat on the board
black king forced to H4 The Rook now
threatening to come behind and um a
threat of Checkmate in uh just two moves
Rook h8 would be deadly however Wesley
found the only way to save the game Rook
to G3 and after a couple of checks this
is where Hikaru unfortunately
self-destructed he should have kept
giving those checks Perpetual would end
the game but instead Rook takes Rook A
Rush of Blood to the Head based on the
fact that there's still a Checkmate
threat in the position but black can
clear a path for the king simply
stepping back with his Bishop there's a
safe Escape Route now and after a rook
check H2 was the killer blow based on
the fact that a check can simply be
blocked black makes a new Queen and
Wesley so won the
game what an uh amazing finish that was
and it is only a best of two for these
players and look at that three have
already taken the lead weso wins against
aakar Nakamura Magnus Carlson with his
endgame touch takes down Dennis lazic
Fabiano Carana takes the lead in his
match against Maxim Vash lra these
players have to strike back in uh the
final second game while nardack Abdu
satov and aliar fuja what a game that
was it ended peacefully but the game
itself was anything but peaceful and the
funny part is that was maybe one of the
wildest games of the round and yet it
ended in a draw those two players gave
it the all nothing could separate them
was good defense from Ala and then the
other three matches we have a winner in
each
one the action is just getting started
uh in the season and Final in Toronto
and we' have set ourselves up for a
fantastic final from this city as the
eight of the best players from the
season are battling it out we've already
had three decisive games three players
are playing catchup going into that
final second round and we're also
celebrating the amazing community that
we've created at ches kid with a big
surprise coming up for all of you this
February it's going to be incredibly
[Music]
fun
chess kid is going live and in person at
the chess kid national festival bring
the whole family meet your favorite
Chess
[Music]
Masters solve
puzzles play kto five
tournaments compete for the chess kid
national championship title and so much
more this Festival is surely W for the
books from February 16th to 19th 2024 in
Charlotte North Carolina book your seats
now before they're
[Music]
gone this December they are back for one
more round chess GPT I'm already liking
this bot it's such a big troll dead lost
Grandpa Gambit decides to get a bit
crazy because he sacrif Place say the
queen Frank and Isa and everyone's
favorite Kitty mittens well if I go here
it's a fork if I go here it's a it's
another Fork so I guess the only safe
move is
this I didn't even see
that oh that is so sick that's actually
sick oh sh is 95 oh
my play them again while you can on
chess.com
[Music]
w
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now now with
the official collection from chess.com
Mount them in seconds with a tool-free
magnet kit and swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
those are some really cool CH and if you
saw the players earlier you know that's
an easy way to boost your ELO rating
getting yourself a secret lab Titan Evo
Champions chest door 2023 Edition and
we've got a very cool giveaway for all
of you one lucky winner will win this
beautiful chair and all you got to do is
follow chesc and secret lab a chess
you've got to like this post on
Instagram tag a chessmate that's also
watching the tour finals and we will be
revealing the big lucky winner on our
final day that's December 16th one of
you will win that very cool chair and
the best part it is signed by none other
than Magnus gson so get ready to enter
that giveaway how cool would it be I
want a secret lap chair where are our
secret lap chairs I need a break tany I
need to write in I need to sign up for
this competition I want one too I feel
like it'd be a lot of pressure though if
Magnus siger was in the chair and I'm
playing chess and I'm not nearly his
level that would kind of hurt me a
little bit well you know one player
who's hurt right now has got to be
Dennis lazic how close was he to secure
that draw in the first round with the
black pieces Magnus Carlson doing Magnus
things in that end game what was the big
takeaway for for you Robert from the
round one action that we just saw well
specifically in that match my take away
is Dennis lazic is legit everyone should
remember that name he is just getting
started he's 17 years old but Fabiano
Carana in great form the way he played
we didn't see the conclusion live in
front of you all but I looked at that
game he is just a stellar player in some
of the prime of his career yeah it just
feels like everything he touches right
now Fabiano turns to Gold just he had
one chance against Maxim he took it he
never gave Maxim a look back in after
that moment we showed actually uh in the
end game where Maxim rushed his King
forward it was a flawed plan and Fabion
made him pay the price he's looking like
the man to beat right now wow wall
number two Fabiano Carana looking
Unstoppable with the other player who's
always Unstoppable no matter where he's
playing Magnus Carlson Ka did catch up
with Magnus earlier in the day let's
take a look at what he had to say here
with the reigning Champion Magnus
Carlson coming from setting a fresh
rating record on chess.com so that must
give you some confidence Magnus I don't
know uh but it was good to get some reps
in sort of uh before the tournament
since I felt a bit Rusty but I expect
you know still the couple of first
couple of days maybe to uh not be quite
as sharp as I as I am sometimes but I
think you know eventually I'll I'll get
there yeah you start off with the
youngest player is by far lower rated
than you and the other players here at
Dennis lovic what are some possible slip
UPS against him I think he's very strong
uh he's obviously not as experienced and
you can see that sometimes when he gets
shorter on time that he starts to get
nervous but I think he plays like very
ambitious positional chess and when he's
on his game he can compete with
everybody wish you best of luck Magnus
thank you for joining us thank you all
right that was Magnus Carlson back to
you
guys big praise there from Magnus gson
for his uh round one opponent Dennis
lazovic there and he mentioned an
interesting point that Dennis it's about
experience for him he probably lacks a
little bit of that and when he comes
under time pressure that's when Dennis
gets a bit shaky yeah I felt like Magnus
is being a profit these top players
they're not just great at chess but
they're great at understanding Styles
reading opponent strengths and
weaknesses and Magnus pinpointed
something there I mean it came to pass
on the board uh as soon as Dennis ticked
down under 10 seconds that's where the
small mistakes started to creep in and
was able to pounce so um clearly he's
done a good read on Dennis laic and
Dennis told us when we talked to him
yesterday that he was nervous it's
different sitting across the board from
somebody versus playing in the comfort
of your own home and Magnus he picked up
on it he smelled it he was able to get
that full point but Dennis as Magnus
himself just said he is legit he is
great and he can take down anybody
including Magnus himself right well
Dennis do start with the white pieces in
the next game his task is clear if he's
got to go to the armagard and he's got
to take down probably the player who's
hardest uh to beat Magnus Carlson how
will Dennis do that well the other
player who had a great start was West
Lisa against Hikaru Nakamura a Clos
match at the end but Hikaru getting
ambitious at a wrong moment and then it
was all Westley so Kaa caught up with
Wesley after the game Let's uh go to
Toronto well here with Wesley so coming
now from win here first game
congratulations Wesley yes thank you uh
was a weird crazy game I think uh I
think I was playing decently like I
didn't get much problems and uh he got a
bit lower in time so that gave me
confidence but uh I was playing very
slow in the end and was very ner rcking
so I I need to play a bit faster in
because I almost messed it up totally in
the end and I think in the end I
blundered somewhere and it was a total
draw but then he got too ambitious with
six seconds on clock so great CRA this
must give uh you some confidence though
heading into the second game being in
the lead now first round against Hikaru
yeah for sure I mean it's want I wish
him happy birthday so fortunate he has
to play in his birthday but uh he's been
very
impressive throughout all the last two
years I'm very impressed by the way he's
playing the way he's doing so uh
hopefully I can I can do well in the
second game against him yeah finally
what will you expect from him now coming
into a must win game a go out play the
king's Indian probably fetto his
kingside Bishop like he did last year uh
he got he got nothing to lose so I have
to you know have to take it as if it's
the very first game of the match W say
good luck in the second game thank you
for joining us and uh back to you
guys and Wesley so needs only a draw to
take his first match Victory against
Hikaru Nakamura and these are our uh
results going into the final uh game of
the first round as we see danis lazovic
has to win against Magnus Carlson to
take it to Armageddon ala fuja nck still
equal Maxim vasher lra loses to Fabiano
in the first round and Wesley saw
needing only a draw how surprising was
it for you David to see Hikaru not go
for that repetition at the very end I
mean it was a shock I think to all of us
uh if this wasn't the first game of the
event if Hikaru was a bit warmer if he
was in the swing of things in the Rhythm
already he would never have made that
under I think as soon as he played that
move he realized he was lost on the spot
but uh yeah Wesley he's going to take
anything he can get small margins at
this level they say you got to risk it
to get the biscuit but in this case all
he got was a zero next to his name so
for hikaro you have to applaud the
confidence the way he tries to go for
Glory but unfortunately for him he gave
a win to Wesley so Wesley went with
black and you know winning with the
black pieces that's a treasure it's a
big treasure and defeating Wesley plays
white next he needs only a draw a player
like Wesley one of the most solid
players the hardest to beat on the
circuit I this is a this is an uphill
task for Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru did
almost take him down in the global
Championship with the black pieces so
Wesley knows that what he car is capable
of that said Wesley so may be the
hardest player to beat I know Magnus
Carlson is higher rated but Wesley just
doesn't lose he doesn't win as much as
Magnus of course but the guy like never
loses so I don't envy hikaru's task
whatsoever yeah I see two possible
scenarios right now either Hikaru does
play something a bit wild a bit
wonderful and gets punished for it or he
is able to kind of bully Wesley Wesley
plays a bit too passively goes too much
for the draw and actually gives Hikaru
some chances in the process uh Hikaru
has to hope it's the latter of course
but it's not going to be easy this is a
real uphill struggle is Wesley is sorry
is Hikaru going to be hoping that Wesley
starts with 1 D4 so that he gets to play
his pet Kings Indian defense Wesley gave
it away in the interview he said he's is
going to be a king's Indian Wesley
basically told hearu I'm going to play
D4 wow that's really some Next Level
trash talking there giving away the
opening prep but Wesley will he stick to
his uh interview with Ka and actually
start with one D4 allowing the Kings
Indian we will find that and Fabby what
a thought for him against Maxim Vash
grab he wins the game and this has been
some of the best chess that we've been
seeing from Fabby I I think about 2018
that was the year of Fabiano karwana and
then he was a little shaky he had a
couple of rough years there Robert the
23 has been the resurgence uh for the
world number two and I think people
forget that he is dominating so much in
classical chess that they don't look at
his rapid success he won the St Louis
rapid and Blitz very recently he's been
a Mainstay of the top division here in
the Champions chess tour and so Fabiana
Carana he was so often maligned in the
past he can't play quicker time controls
Magnus beat him in the rapid it was just
a walkover he's actually improved his
Blitz and Rapid skills tremendously and
he's proving game after game that he is
a man on a Mission and he is hard to
beat and he can beat anybody he can beat
anybody and you mentioned St Louis rapid
and Blitz do you know who finished
second in St Louis rapid and Blitz this
man in front of us Maxim Vash lra who
was in fact leading the event until the
very last day what a performance it was
by Maxim who ended up finishing second
in the overall Grand chest St as well if
anyone can make a comeback it is the
French Maestro he is the 2021 World
Blitz Champion David what does he need
to do to take this one I think he just
needs to do his normal stuff Maxim is so
powerful with white he has a very fixed
repertoire he has ideas there he knows
everything deeply all the pawn
structures uh all the middle game plans
and I've always seen him as a player who
actually overachieves with white because
his black repertoire sometimes let him
down it was a bit too predictable
meaning that he had uh he has great
experience vast experience in these
must-win situations with the white
pieces so I don't think he needs to do
anything too different he needs a bit of
luck he needs to hope that Fabiano's off
his game which at this point looks
unlikely but uh yeah I'm not going to
rule this one out yet and one of the big
questions when you're Maxim Vash gra and
he's looking at the wall what do I play
against maybe the best prepared player
on the planet in Fabiano Carana I mean
Fabiano has shown that he's versatile in
any opening but if I'm Maxim I think I
play something a bit wild something that
Fabio probably hasn't looked at recently
I just don't know what that is yeah and
here we see Hikaru Nakamura hoping to
bounce back needing to bounce back
against Wesley so but he's got a lot to
take away he's got a lot to be happy
proud about in the face first game as
well he got into trouble but resourceful
play as always what Hikaru is known for
he managed to survive for the most part
of it and then just got too ambitious
well this is the moment for him to get
too ambitious is that the queen Pawn
opening will we see the Kings Indian
defense by Hikaru Nakamura well liso was
not bluffing he did Play 1 D4 in the
meantime here we see a clash between
lazic and Carlson and looks like a
queen's porn opening in this one as well
lazic known he's renowned for the catch
the issue though is when you're young as
Dennis lzic is you may not be as
experienced a variety of openings you
can't be predictable Magnus he prepares
for his matches and if you're playing
something that Magnus expects and
something Magnus himself has played in
the biggest of stages he may able to
shut it down by that you mean the world
championship the Catan we saw that so
much by Magnus Carlson himself with the
white pieces but the thing about Dennis
lazic is that he's got a narrow
repertoire uh Robert but he has a deep
understanding of the positions and the
Catalan middle games that we do see it's
going to be really something if he
manages to achieve something out of the
opening uh coming out in this one with
the Catalan and it's Magnus who plays A5
and Dennis going into the first think
yeah really trendy move A5 for black
just defending the dart Square Bishop I
played it myself just last week and uh
Magnus he knows that if he's able to
equalize uh in these early stages I
think he'll be able to guide this game
towards a draw so actually more
important than ever um this opening
right now for lazovic and slightly
strange considering he's played this
opening his whole life that he's paused
a bit but maybe it's just uh trying to
come up with a new strategy uh in this
must-win situation and I was about to
say there's not too much tension in this
game and suddenly Magnus pushes his Pawn
forward challenging White Center White's
King has not castled so magnet is taking
this opportunity to seize the momentum
in the center of the board things are
clarifying at the moment and the D pawns
are gone this is actually becoming a
position that's going to get
messy this is an opening that I've
played with the black pieces I quite
like this uh facing the Catan and black
before capturing on D5 hits that Knight
on D4 the usual standard move is to push
that E Pawn uh to E3 you can also fall
back with the Knight and that's when
black captures on D5 develops that
Knight on C6 and I'm expecting uh he
does fall back with the Knight to F3 a
capture on D5 I like these positions for
black I think U Magnus should be pleased
yeah and remember he's uh played all
these world championship match mates
Magnus Carson he's even played the
Catalan from the white side as one of
his uh kind of main weapons so he knows
everything under the sun he studied this
before in depth this looks difficult for
Dennis lazovic you can see head in hands
already he really really does need
something special to throw the world
number one off uh off his rhythm and one
thing I'm very curious about if Dennis
can make a draw does he go all in
because a draw versus a loss he still
loses this match so I kind of want to
see what he's made of here because why
not take your shot at the number one
player the highest rated player in
history you don't get this opportunity
so often so why not test him and try to
take him down that being said Robert you
did remind me in the break this
tournament is fed rated for rapid and
Dennis lazic look at the ratings there
just below the or just around the player
cameras he's so far lower rated than
everyone else any draw he's going to be
gaining points he's going to be climbing
that rating ladder um of course he wants
to win of course he wants to uh fight
back in this match but uh yeah nothing
to lose at all for lasic it's going to
be about the chances that he gets on the
board right that will determine how far
he is able to push and it's uh things
are just getting started in this one
white has just got the king to safety
but it is a dynamic position because
black has created this isolated Queen's
Pawn on D5 and what is the compensation
for that is peace activity you get your
Rook on the open E Line you start
targeting that E2 pawn and we see the
players are blitzing out their moves
both very familiar with this position
but given the structure how Dynamic is
it is in a must-win situation for white
should Dennis be happy with the opening
outcome I think it depends on how much
Magnus knows uh simply there is actually
one uh trap for example in this position
having studied it myself and Magnus will
never fall into opening traps of course
he just calmly pushes a pawn the problem
is Magnus he's taken on this uh kind of
deficiency he's taken on this isolated
Pawn with black he's got such great
pieces though to compensate for it and
often in chess targeting one weakness is
not enough um also Magnus Carson he's uh
kind of on record as a big fan of these
types of positions he says even if
everything goes wrong you just defend a
slightly worse end game and you're fine
and uh with a draw being sufficient here
feels like more than enough maybe I'm
being too negative maybe Dennis will
surprise us all here with some deep
preparation but uh now is the moment he
needs something special before it's too
late well he's gone into a think right
now and we will check in with this game
meanwhile we've got moves coming in on
the maxim V lra against Fabiano on board
Maxim with the white pieces in a
must-win game this one it was uh the
Spanish the Royal Lopez and uh David
break it down for us because it looks
like to me that black has made a lot of
progress on the queen side Fabiano just
one of the best prepared players in the
world as we've mentioned and uh I think
proving it here black has no problems at
all he's undermined white center as well
um if we jump in and just highlight a
couple of key factors in this position
uh we saw just a few moves back if we
rewind here black has space on the queen
side but often this amounts to nothing
Fabiano did actually find the perfect
moment to throw the C Pawn forward and
after a trade we realized that White's
Central uh structure here is a bit
flimsy you cannot for example play the
desirable move d4 occupying the center
because black could simply trade off and
now win the pawn on e4 I don't see any
reason not to grab this Pawn maybe white
has compensation but uh here Fabiano
would be happy instead he's been forced
to play the move Queen to E2 and if for
example Fabiano continues just keeping
the tension how is white going to
untangle there's a bit of a traffic jam
with his pieces and I think Fabi Fabiano
will be extremely happy really
instructive by you to defend the pawn
rather than capture on D3 because what
white actually is perfectly set up for
is Bishop takes back on D3 and then the
queen and Bishop line up against this
Pawn on B5 there may be some tactics in
the current position where allow black
to escape but that would be something
that I would be concerned about if I
were Fabby so he's choos between these
options he in fact took on D3 He is a
sometimes considered a machine at
calculating and the engine backs him up
this is apparently good for black even
though the B5 Pawn does look a little
bit loose you mentioned uh tactics
Robert I would have been reluctant here
but as well I agree this is a weakness
can be targeted but suddenly boom D5 and
I talked about the traffic jam suddenly
white pieces are real targets for this
these black pawns if you capture on D5
now it's a simple fork and white would
lose a piece so already tricks in the
air and uh maxi in a must-win situation
has to dodge them the desirable move
here might actually backfire Bishop
takes pawn and I think black is just
doing extremely well uh something is
going to come to E4 something's going to
land and win one of these two white
pieces tricky times already for the
Frenchmen speaking of Tricks I'm uh also
trying to get my radar on on this
position after Bishop takes Pawn can the
Black Knight also jump to B3 creating
some double attacks uh on White's
position you probably have to take on
eight E4 is hanging it just doesn't look
like white will have enough time to
capture on B5 in any of these lines yeah
simple and strong Tanya I think you're
right this looks good for black as well
and that's not good news for maxim if
black has multiple options to give a
good position and Fabiano quickly played
Pawn T D3 He was not phased he didn't
think about the B5 Pawn he saw through
the position and noticed that D5 push or
even just Knight B3 so if Queen takes D3
as your best option you look like you're
going for a Checkmate a bad than
diagonal there's a pawn in your queen
and bishop's path you're not getting
there I think that Black's pieces are
going to come into play and I would say
that Fab is definitely not worse here
yeah we're expecting Fabiano to be very
comfortable in this ensuing middle game
and already big questions to answer for
maxim wow and it looks like it is a
dream start for Fabiano karwana up in
the match this is the final one Maxim
vasher lrav not happy with the position
that he has out of the opening Fabby
looking strong in this one uh the other
player who has to win the the second
game is Hikaru Nakamura against Wesley
so did we finally get the Kings Indian
that we were hoping for and that perhaps
Hikaru was hoping for we did not we got
a bonon structure instead and you can
also see in the bottom right hand side
of your screen the eval bar is up near
hikaru's face which is actually going to
cause him to frown rather than smile
because Wesley has a dream position from
the white side of a bononi you can't
fault taru he needs to win this game he
doesn't want to make a solid draw but
that Knight just went down to D2 hopped
forward into C4 at the right moment the
D6 Pawn is off in tender and again
hikaro played Rook B8 he wants to strike
with B5 so if he gets that pawn break on
the queen side he has chances however
Wesley is covering that for now yeah the
bone defense it's got a bit of a dodgy
reputation at top levels it's often only
employed in must-win situations and uh
in Wesley's defense he did say that he
did kind of name drop the Kings Indian
but he did say hiar is going to Fe ketto
his Bishop he's going to put the black
Bishop on G7 so he was semi- right with
his opening prediction and it is
imbalanced enough this position to give
hikaro some hope long term if uh black
can survive what might be a bit of an
onslaught in the center for example if
black can uh trade off a couple of
pieces free up uh the space there then
still chances long term I like hikaru's
Choice despite what the evaluation
process so would you say it is an
interesting opening Choice by Hikaru
it's always interesting when Hikaru
plays CH I actually do agree with you
though that even though the engine is
suggesting the white is significantly
better this isn't advantage that it's a
great practical try because it's going
to be a chaotic mess for Wes to deal
with and he prefers those solid
structures where he's ever so slightly
better he would rather have Dennis lavic
type of position against Magnus where he
can just press a little bit against an
iated Pawn so hiar is doing the right
thing and for now Wesley's dropping
below him on the clock and that could be
a big part of the story yeah and these
types of situations especially when the
nerves are really uh playing a role it's
all about control and control here it's
never really going to happen um that's
the beauty of the bononi I've dabbled
once or twice myself not with much
Fortune but um yeah you simply do not
allow white to create a bind and that's
why Wesley's pausing look at the clock
times already uh you can see Wesley's
not as comfortable as uh he would like
to be and that's exactly what's so
fascinating about these openings right
like the Boni and the Kings Indian we
often see the evalar favors white in
these openings but the waters can get so
muddy and things can get so complicated
that it's extremely difficult to prove
that engine evaluation uh and things can
change very quickly and I have to say
hiar Nakamura he looks very confident
right now on the screen like you pointed
out the Knight the white knight from D2
does want to land on the C4 square but
right now it's not such a tempting
option because that allows the pawn to
move from B5 meanwhile black also has
these ideas of trying to advance that F
Pawn to F5 at the right square at the
right moment Wesley does take the
decision of clamping down on the Queen's
side but I've always felt once you
commit the move A5 you actually invite
black to open up the B line with
striking with B5 immediately is that a
possibility in these positions
definitely I think uh black needs
activity if you look at the black pieces
only one of them has crossed your first
two rows that's the Black Knight on H5
on the edge of the board which is a bit
misplaced in uh certain positions
certain variations so Hikaru needs
something active he needs something uh
to give his piece's life and we might
see him take a long pause now because
it's all about planning often these top
players in the world they they kind of
invest their time when it's these
maneuvering positions rather than the
calculation which they're so quick so
fast at but uh once Hikaru does decide
on that that pawn push T I think the
position Will Spring to Life we'll see
fireworks potentially uh on the queen
side on the board it is all about trying
to get activity and for activity we off
we often talk about Pawn breaks that's
what you're looking for uh and here it
feels like black has two of them Robert
you either Tred to get F5 in or you try
to get B5 in and that's definitely on
hikaru's radar now to move the F Pawn
forward you first have to get that
Knight on D7 out of the way what do you
think are the options going on in
hikaru's mind right now which one would
he be more tempted to try to make a
reality given the Matt situation
currently probably opening the queen
side but Wesley knows that he just needs
a draw so he's allowing a queen side
break understanding that there's a
downside there that if you push your B
Pawn your a pawn is Left Behind and will
become a Target so I'm looking at this
position as one where Wesley if he had
drawn game one I'm not sure he would
have played A5 there of course hiar
wouldn't have played the Boni to start
with but for Wesley he knows that he
just needs to keep everything under
control and he actually can meet both
Pawn breaks successfully I don't think
he's actually that worried he just needs
to keep an eye on his clock all right so
Wesley so down by a minute on the clock
we will check in with this one but let's
get a quick update on the Ali Resa fuja
nck board uh currently the match is even
after that first round draw nck with the
black pieces there head in hands it is
not back's move right now uh what are
the chances of this one going to
Armageddon I'm going to say quite High
both players looked in great form uh in
the first game of the day that being
said this position is kg as anything and
uh it will explode at some point we see
both players just camped out just
waiting waiting tiptoeing around each
other as soon as white decides to pull
the trigger and push the eorn forward or
as soon as black does the same and push
the C PA
forward I think we're going to see some
action Robert well KY has been saying
that no Beck looked like he's been
working out he's clearly been Rook
liting cuz this is second game in a row
where he brought his queenside Rook up a
square to then reroute it towards the
center I love the way he's playing in
this event thus far it's only the second
game but he's got his eyes against Ali
reay's King their Queens on the board
unlike the Berlin in the first one look
at the bishop the dark Square Bishop on
B8 it's aiming all across the diagonal
towards White's King side the bishop on
C8 it's on its starting Square also
heading in the direction of the white
king so I don't see how white gets a
pawn break normally move E4 would be
available but that seems like black will
meet it by maybe T taking on G3 then
going on e4 there's a lot of things
hanging in this position so I don't
really trust it for white and I think
that notbe with his lead on the clock
he's in great shape Yeah you mentioned
that Rook slide at some point it will
land on the E7 Square maybe even on the
D7 square if the Center opens up and uh
I like Black's position as well this
Black Knight looks beautiful on B4 nice
Outpost there by far the most active
piece on the board and yeah it just
relies on whether white can push
successfully if not and wh's pieces just
look a bit stuck a bit silly in the
center of the board U so anything can
happen it's really in the balance and
fuja his clock time is a bit of a red
flag right now I think that might be a
big factor later on when someone spent a
week getting a visa to a place to a
tournament you know he means business
he's there with his determination to try
to win the whole thing and even in the
first game we were talking about how
alira is the one who's pushing in the
Berlin end game and this one with black
as well he's got the peace activity
going all that said I I also feel that
once white does get that Central break
in and I don't really see a way for
black to stop it from happening uh I'm
expecting E4 to arrive on the board at
some moment I think Ali RZA will also
get his chances in this position all
right I'll have to get very Chessy for a
second if we can analyze the position
I'm looking at an exchange sacrifice I
put my calculating cap on and I'm
thinking after Rook E7 Pawn to E4 I'm
going to take your knight on G3 and then
I'm going to keep taking on e4 until I
can't anymore because all the pieces are
coming off white will get a rook um
black will get a pawn and a minor piece
and at the end of the line he didn't go
for this by the way at the end line I
think that black is such great light
Square control that uh it should at
least be balanced with some Dynamic
chances but how can I blame no nearb for
avoiding this you don't want to go down
material when you've drawn game one he
plays Bishop E6 it's the more solid
approach the more solid approach but
sometimes solid isn't the name of the
game in these positions sometimes you
don't want to wait too long and big
question Tanya you called it is white
going to push this Pawn or not
I would really want to see that on the
board and I think the problem with that
is that once the bishop is on E6 and the
trade happens on e4 what nck wants is
that Bishop from E6 that gets really
active lands on B3 you're attacking the
rook and it's not very pleasant I see
the I doesn't like this move but it does
discourage white from playing E4 perhaps
this is something that uh that's on
nauck's mind I would have wanted to go
Bishop B3 but the evalar disapproves
right now maybe it's rushed maybe you
start with Rook D7 so it's a good idea
just in the wrong order because you
start with Rook D7 then you aim for the
B3 Square in the future the D4 Pawn does
feel very loose with Bishop takes G3
still on the agenda and we have a move
played from Ali RZA Knight C3 back to E2
he wants to go Knight F4 in the future
just like Magnus against lazic in the
first game he doesn't mind to capture
doubling his pawns because it brings
another Pawn towards the king side maybe
for an attack so this is a double-edged
position both players have their chances
here I love the way these two youngsters
are duking it out
yeah balanced position and it will come
to life sooner rather than
later wow really tense stuff just looks
like these two just bang in for and we
mentioned their High ceilings whoever
wins this match is going to be thrilled
and uh it's going to be a hard man to
stop yeah I completely agree with that
it's not only like the confidence boost
that comes from uh taking down well
another grade of your generation but
it's also just the fact that you know
things are this this tournament means so
much to each one of them uh and we've
seen these two players once they start
on a high note there's no stopping them
Knight E2 played on the board nck in a
think it's a game that Anything Can
Happen playing for all three results all
four minor pieces on the board and we
see a quick action replay appear again
just as nck doubled up The Rook on the E
line and it's really the whole game is
centered around this E4 break black is
fighting it white is trying to get it at
the right moment we will check in on
this one meanwhile action getting pretty
hot on the Wesley so Hikaru nak Amura
benoni that we checked in with and it
looks like all the breaks on the board
that we were discussing have arrived wow
we were tossing out random ideas and
suddenly it's overload here Hikaru has
thrown all of his pawns forward he's
also thrown a pawn away Wesley is a pawn
up right now and it's reminiscent of
something that fiser did many many years
ago he just allowed a capture of the
Black Knight on H5 at the cost of
White's light squared bishop and uh
White might have won a porn on the king
side but actually Black's pie is Super
Active now I think great compensation in
Practical terms David before we deep
dive into this Robert can we do a quick
action replay of what just happened from
when we left it last sure I mean it
looks like uh at some point white
retreated that Bishop on the light
squares to attack the Knight and Nar
says I literally don't care take it and
grab the pawn with it because he wants
to open up the position and that's
exactly what happened F5 was played
white took twice on H5 was now upon
ahead black plays on The Queen side and
look at Wesley's response instead of
taking on pant for those new play
players out there learn your on pant you
can do it right now and right now only
he says I don't want to open up the
queen side let's instead of allowing
that Rook to attack the B Pawn let me
play on the king side with Bishop to H6
I really like that choice from Wesley uh
he only needs a draw to take this match
and why shake things up let's just keep
things going on the king side where he's
up a Pawn Yeah and big moment for Hikaru
Nakamura because if he isn't able to
keep this bishop on the board and if he
isn't able to kind of Dodge some
exchanges Dodge maybe the position
opening up then the black king might be
the weaker of the two and he's a porn
down so uh big moment what to do next
does he open the position does he maybe
kick this white knight away does he
close the center down by pushing a pawn
to F4 a bunch of decisions and critical
moment for Hikaru needs to justify his
sacrifice it's clear he's going all out
right for the initiative he's given up a
pawn to try and get peace activity to
try to create his chances really the way
to go when you're in a must-win
situation but who would you pick right
now would you rather be white or would
you rather be black in the this position
I'd rather be a point up in the match
what Fair though the position is
starting to get a bit dicey and I'm
looking at the clocks both players at
around 5 minutes 40 seconds so if they
get into time trouble I think hiar can
turn this around because that Knight on
D3 not just pokes at the B2 pawn it can
also slide back if the bishops get
traded to the F4 Square so there will be
tactics at play here Wesley needs to be
careful and needs to keep an eye on that
clock and you were talking about Rook
lifts I think that's also on hikaru's
mind picking up that Rook from f8
getting it to F6 trying to get it to the
G line I can see this becoming very
tricky for white yeah either way no
matter the end result I think this is
really instructive what hikaru's done
he's chosen an opening where Wesley
cannot force a draw cannot force any
exchanges cannot force the Queens off
the board and he's saying maximum
tension maximum practical chances and
I'm going to make it complicated I'm
going to sacrifice pawns I'm going to go
for you no kind of no backing down and F
for forward it's Wesley so who throws
the f Pawn forward and this feels a bit
scary that white king might live to
regret this but I think he has another
Rook lift in mind T you said Rook lifts
I guess for who right call the ambulance
not for me Rook F3 is coming your way
and that Rook will slide a G3 after the
black king so this is looking uh quite
dangerous and for aaru I mean he needs
to find a way to get his queenside
pieces into play that Rook on B8 not
connected with the Rook on f8 and if
white is going to bring another piece
into an attack as Wesley so he clears
his throat and he's ready to go for the
jugular and go for Black's King you sure
that's Wesley I'm not so sure it
probably it is it wasn't me we trust you
David all right well f4 on the board so
it looks like both players are wanting
to get the Rook into the attack but
Wesley's Rook is uh the one that's
coming in with the Power Attack on that
Knight to D3 things looking like they're
getting out of control for Hikaru how
does he keep this going with initia it's
really tough you need to play actively
and normally that means forcing moves
threats captures and checks I don't see
any good checks right now this is one
check simply the white king would be
extremely safe on a square like H2 and
suddenly the black king is bare um so I
think you need to go for some threats
maybe a move like Pawn to B4 attacking
attacking kicking away this white knight
from a good post maybe it's that Rook
slide you mentioned Tanya trying to use
the Rook as a blockader of the black
kingar is going to make a move is he
going to be greedy and take this Pawn
that looks so
the Knight will be so far offside in a
position like that unable to contribute
to the real action that's happening on
the king side you couldn't pay me to
take that pawn on B2 and when you need
to win you might have to do something
that's uh objectively not the best but
instead he takes on e4 that opens up his
Bishop that has not developed yet that
can get into play but you see the engine
it's starting to favor white more and
more a knight can take that Pawn's place
on e4 that D6 Pawn Yeah that's a Target
in the Bon but also the G5 square if you
want to head to the king side and make
maybe even to the E6 back towards the
center those Knights are just darting
back and forth I do like that dark s
that the uh the bishop the light Squad
Bishop that's arrived on F5 it not only
defends H7 you've got ideas of blocking
the G file once it does fall back to G6
so trying to keep everything under
control it's still pretty messy uh the
position and the big question right now
for Wesley so is does he keep that
Knight on the central E4 square or will
he get more ambitious and meanwhile I do
see a big EV Valar slip on the maxim
vasia lra Fabiano Carana board perhaps
we can jump to that one is Fabby about
to get his second win of the day it
looks like it's back towards the middle
so don't trust it at first luns we
apologize everybody sometimes things are
going to go back and forth like that I
have a hard time imagining Maxim making
those mistakes but actually the fua bar
versus abusar that looks legit I peaked
at that game quickly and it looks like
Ali Rea picking up steam in this
position and the match remember it's
only a two- game match so if he can win
this game two against Abdus satarov he's
going to take the tournament lead that
just looks killer his position and uh
yeah it looks like fua a big big
favorite right now um okay quick action
replay of the Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura game did you see the way Wesley
just grabbed a bunch of pieces and just
holding on to them that's a uh that's a
new way of doing the peace 12 that we're
so used to from the players and we've
got a completely crazy position what
just happened David wow yeah things are
turning things are changing and I think
we're changing Focus as well in this
game we're rushing over to the biggest
drama right now where fua is most likely
about to take a win against Abdus satoro
he still needs to be accurate it's still
Level material right now but it's all
about the black king and he's going for
it we see the White Knight closest to
our camera here on the board and uh it's
poised it's ready the black king in huge
danger Al Raza I mean he's looking sharp
everyone has been talking about his
fashion career he's said what about my
chess career I am still here I am still
powerful and that Rook that is on A3 as
you see in the bottom right hand side of
your screen it's going to switch flanks
in the near future Black's King is in a
world of danger with knights attacking
it The Rook will slide in the queen is
in the sight of the H6 Pawn oh boy I
think that um I was talking about Rook
lifting it was really out razor I should
have focused on and you're mentioning a
Knights jumping uh the queen targeting
the 86 Pawn which actually stops black
from making the only move that stops
Knight jumping to F5 G6 right now is
impossible because notice how the queen
just takes the king Side Pawn the A6
Pawn that Robert was pointing out and if
not G6 Knight F5 is a huge threat on the
board that's just going to collapse
Black's King side how is nck fighting
this very natural move that's about to
happen next I don't think he is that's
the problem if you think about the black
pieces they're all so passive the only
piece again that's crossed his first two
rows is that black knight on B4 but
suddenly it finds itself stranded on the
wrong side of the the board and if you
don't have any Defenders you do not
fight off an attack and especially when
it's allera fire rouer it's going to be
fire breaking through on that black king
and uh yeah I think he's going to go
down in flames here and how critical is
the clock situation in this one
defending is so hard when you have no
time on the clock he's got three and a
half minutes here Abdu satoro but
objectively there's no good defense and
uh trying to kind of work out a miracle
here it's going to be hard you could
give him three and a half hours he's
still not defending his position his
King is side is just going to collapse
Ian there's going to be a sacrifice
right in front of his King with one
Knight the second Knight will join the
party the queen will take that H6 Pawn I
mean you look at nybeck he always fights
to the very end but it looks like the
end is near for him and he's trying to
come up with an attack of his own I just
don't see it working yeah this is just
uh I mean I mentioned a miracle this is
praying for a miracle the black queen
and dark Square Bishop are now lined up
on a diagonal problem is there's a
knight in the way there's no way Alara
will ever allow a check he does it
Knight di spawn he's going for it he's
going for the black king and this is
Elementary stuff for fua and uh at this
level I think simple tactic if the black
king takes this Knight the other white
knight lands on F5 check the White Queen
joins the action and game over it's
literally a check mating
tactic no way to defend here n backck
Abdu satro is about to collapse against
Ali Resa fuja in the final game and that
would mean the end of round one alira
what a start what a game start to finish
this just looked like an Oli RAR show
this one I've been very impressed with
this play I during the break I quickly
looked at that first game his defense
was impeccable here in this game too he
just was able to bring his pieces the
forces on over he struck in the center
at the right time and you saw n back
there he's like this one hurts and is
nck secret lab CH just shaking a little
bit faster than usual right now it looks
that way it looks like the Panic has set
in the realization that there's simply
no way to even try and defend defend
this if you ignore this Knight simply
white is going to eat up everything on
your king side white can take the long
route round and start kind of retting a
knight going for pawns Black's King will
simply be be it's going to be stripped
of it shelter it's just game over you
cannot touch this Knight it is poisoned
that will lead to Checkmate and uh I
think we might even see resignation in
the next minute or so he's now down
under two minutes and like you said
Robert two days two hours he takes this
night will not save him though and a
night check should leave to the killer
blow very shortly yeah they're just
going to make the moves right now so
many options here for Ali Raza but he's
doing the right thing everybody at home
should look at him he didn't play his
move in one second he spent a little bit
of time he forced narbeck to part with
his Queen the king is still going to be
checkm in just a few moves so it's a
great showing here from Ali Rea as nck
he is just uh going to play it out a
little bit but it's over it's over white
can recapture this bishop uh if you want
to uh play Super safe but I think he's
going to play Queen takes Pawn
threatening Checkmate in one if White's
Queen lands in front of the black king
on G7 Kiss of Death Checkmate there
black simply has to play the move F6 to
uh Stave off the mate to delay the
inevitable but yeah everything's
dropping you're losing on material
you're losing on the board check mate
and he resigns fuia takes the win first
match winner of the day Ali rzza fua
with a big win against nbec Abdu satro
what a game this was uh and it finishes
their match they will of course be
playing the second round of the day ala
fu gets up and leaves he's got to be a
happy man right now uh first game was a
little shaky for him but quite a power
performance with the white pieces in
game two as he walks out and we'll start
thinking about the next game now yeah
you have another match today but for fua
a fantastic start could not have gone
any better looks like is that Dennis
lazic standing up there too his game
against Magnus Carlson has finished they
drew in their second game so Dennis lvic
draws the number one player in history
but that number one player play gets the
match win Magnus Carlson joins fua as an
early winner yeah Magnus was cynical in
that one he forced a draw with black uh
not much young Dennis could have done
about it put up a good fight today
ultimately he was up against the best
and uh this is a tth position between
Maxim Vash gra and Fabiano look at the
nerves both players looking over peering
over at the clock there this one uh
drama ahead we should do a deep dive
into this one Maxim vasher lra has to
win on demand to force an Armageddon and
it is his move right now he does have an
extra Pawn Fabby with the bishop there
but to me it doesn't look like it's
enough compensation for black what's
going on here yeah let's uh ignore those
engine suggestions below the board black
is not uh minus 14 up right now uh it is
actually white who's up a porn as you
mentioned Tanya and I think it's
actually all about this black king look
at the white Rook on the seventh rank
the black king is a big Target there
White's Bishop as well uh lining up
against the black king and Maxim should
be winning and here's David how we got
here just a quick action replay to take
everyone through all that just happened
and in that last position I think it's
such a critical moment the H Pawn coming
on to H5 did he make that
move no he didn't Maxim oh he's
retreating why instead of pouncing on
Fab's King instead of retreating his
pieces but Fabby see how quickly he
played that he's getting in time trouble
this is a nerve-wracking moment for
these two and Maxim suddenly the white
Rook finds itself almost trapped Behind
Enemy
Fabiano has broken the connection
between White's Queen and Rook Maxim has
to keep the material on the board he's
still a porn up but suddenly black has
the bishop pair suddenly white
retreating as you say Robert never a
good sign you've put your pieces on bad
post simply and Anything could happen
now it's all about the time scramble
we've got to keep half an eye on the
clock where Fabiano is really struggling
but on the board it's really improved in
the last few moves for him and white is
up a pawn and has been there's a Pawn on
B4 all the way closest to the clock if
pieces get trck then that pawn can push
forward try to become a new Queen but
for the time being the white king is in
some serious danger and there goes a
queen up the board for five what just
happened wow Maxim sacrificed the bishop
just to lure the black king out into the
open Maxim's going all in now in this
must-win situation he's checking the
black king but there's no Checkmate the
black king has to move it has to dodge
who there's got to be a Checkmate here
he's made that move with one second left
and there is a Checkmate I think look at
Fabby David oh my gosh you mean with one
second the clock the queen can't slide
over next to the king cu the bishop on
E6 covers the square I don't immediately
see a Checkmate does Maxim continue
thinking or does he make a quick quick
move and he goes up the board night
check oh the Queen's lost and that's
game just resigns Maxi makes a comeback
this one goes to Armageddon wow we will
break this down for you we will explain
elaborate on what just happened but
Maxim fighting back at the end it was a
simple fork and he wins the game stuff
players they're discussing the lines who
but there's not that much time to
discuss because we will have the bidding
armagedon as Maxim V lra makes a
comeback
with fabi's King marching up the board
and look at that they're actually
putting that bits right now guys this is
Maxim writing his Armageddon bid wow we
will delve deep into how these
Armageddon bids work but Maxim he's
writing High he's going to be feeling
confident both players winning with
white I think it wouldn't be the end of
the world getting white in the
Armageddon here wow and barely any time
to get their reasonings together to
really think about just immediately
after the game they had to place their
bids which had been handed over we will
get to that but there's one more game
still on will we have an Armageddon in
this one it's looking unlikely Hikaru
just pairing off to the side there not
uh in love with his position right now a
quick count shows that white is two
pawns ahead and we're in the end game
Wesley so a draw is enough as well
Hikaru offers a draw and Wesley takes
the win in the match that was a kind
acceptance from Wesley because he had
the upper hand pretty much from start to
finish in that game but he does not care
he won the match a couple rating points
and you'll get those later he takes down
hikara Nakamura once again in Toronto
wow that's that exact same Arena the
exact same spot and Wesley so does it
again he did it last year in the chess
chess.com Global Championship uh where
he did go on to be the winner he took
down Hikaru in the semi-finals and he
starts the Champions chest off finals
taking down the man who many would think
is impossible to take down what a win
for Wesley so and what a win uh that was
that we saw from uh Maxim Vash gra as
well yeah Maxim Vash gra when it
mattered most he fought back and the
Frenchman on fire at the end there let's
delve into that game show exactly how he
managed to achieve that fight back it
was in this position where actually
Maxim with white had lost a bit of
control but Fabiano here let things slip
he allowed a trick that uh fought uh
well fought back for maxim Vash gra
instead he could have banked it he could
have secured the draw with a move such
as Queen to E5 trading off the queens
and at the very end white simply has too
many weak pawns and I think black would
have safely drawn this game instead
Queen to D2 a slip up Bishop takes Pawn
check a sacrifice the pawn cannot take
because Black's Bishop would be loose
instead the king took this uh took this
bishop and now the big blunder King to
F6 would have saved the game for Fabiano
a fight still ahead anything could have
happened three results possible King H5
too brave Reckless allowing a check and
another check and here Fabiano simply
had to resign because his Queen is lost
on the next move just what an amazing
gamble at the very end sacrificing the
bishop but these are the practical
decisions that get the win in sure Fabby
could have saved with King F6 but good
luck finding that in seconds it's just
brilliant from Maxim because that
objectively was the best move he
sacrificed his Bishop exploiting the
fact that black did not have so many
defenders in front of the king sure
Fabby could have hung on there played it
out more it was actually doing okay with
the best moves hard to make the best
move with just mere seconds on your
clock great bounceback game from Maxim
lra which means we are heading to the
armagan and we did see the players right
after that placing their bids we will
get more action and news on that but
this is where we stand after our round
one of day one of the Champions chesta
finals Magnus Carlson making it look
easy uh there against Dennis lvic and
this man it's all eyes on him as he made
his big comeback against the world
number two the Unstoppable Fabian Carana
they will face each other in the
Armageddon and we will have the bids
right after this break don't go
[Music]
anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
n
have a friend or family member who loves
chess GI them a chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level you can choose a gold
platinum or Diamond membership for one
month or one year want your gift to
arrive on your friend's birthday or on a
holiday gifts can be scheduled to arrive
up to 90 days in the future all premium
plans include an adree experience
unlimited puzzles and lessons and unlock
all Bots go platinum to add unlimited
game review or Diamond to unlock
insights and Coach explanations give the
gift of Chess to
[Music]
today
sh
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
grow the game find your local group or
take the lead at meetup.com chest and
right now it is exciting chess uh on day
one of the Champions Chester finals as
we already have our very first
Armageddon with Maxim bashra making a
comeback against Fabiano Carana and we
did see the two players right after
their game placing the bids you could
see the nerves on both Fabby and Maxim
while they were writing it down they
barely had any seconds and the big
question is how low can you go to get
the black pieces and we've got the bids
coming in and it is Fabiano Karana who
does take the bid win with 9 minutes 52
seconds he will start with the black
pieces Maxim starts with white will'll
have 15 minutes on the clock black low
time less time but gets the result odds
a draw means Fabby takes the match Maxim
with the white pieces will have to win
Fabby 9 minutes 52 seconds to use think
that was too low a bid what is your take
on uh that Robert I think David had a
very good point that the players don't
mind having the white pieces
traditionally you prefer have the black
pieces the game is underway right here
we have liftoff but because both players
won with the white pieces you're feeling
pretty good about having the first move
Advantage yeah you got to feel confident
and uh Maxim he's done it once in a
must-win situation needing to win with
white and uh he just needs to do it
again so uh both players uh it's worth
mentioning noticeably higher bids than
throughout the rest of the season that's
because we're playing over theboard uh
so they want as much time as possible
but Fabiano needs to hold this draw
under 10 minutes and uh here we go game
is off and okay we'll get to it but it
looks like a scotch game a scotch
opening and uh a rare guest at the top
level yeah I see the hbonds already
moved forward on the board but I had to
ask you we saw the two players
immediately placing their bits is that
something that's pre sort of uh thought
of by both of by the players who are
fighting it out here that if it does get
to the Armageddon what are we going to
put our clock times to I think it's
entirely dependent on what just happened
in the two games because if they had two
solid draws maybe they'd really prefer
to have the black pieces and that could
change their bid and well Maxim just won
with white so he clearly doesn't mind
having the white pieces a second time
now this is a must-win game for maxim he
just had a must-win game it's more of
the same for him and for Fabby he needs
to hold he failed to do that a game ago
so I think both players in a familiar
territory including in this opening yeah
and for our new audience let's break
down what the Armageddon rules are and
what's happening right now this is what
their match has come to this is the
tiebreaker uh and uh well Fabiano kanana
he starts with a little less than 10
minutes on the clock starts with the
black pieces he's got the result odds
draw means he wins the match Maxim who
bid higher on the clock starts with 15
minutes and the white pieces but has to
win on demand until move 60 there is no
increment but after move 60 the players
will get a 1 second increment uh right
now Maxim still keeping that clock
Advantage continues to put the pressure
on the board uh and David we see a big
Rook lift there yeah Rook lift theme of
the day Robert uh you mentioned it
earlier you tempted fate there but uh
either way it's a really unorthodox
opening I think Maxim uh in Armageddon
chest when you have white there are
various strategies Available to You
Maxim has chosen one where he just
surprises the opp opponent goes really
direct creates Chaos on the board and
hopes his extra time really pays off um
that being said this can backfire if
your opponent is well prepared this is a
check from Fabiano suddenly throwing his
Queen forward White's King is hit how do
you block or do you have to move the
king big questions already Black's King
far safer than his counterpart what a
weird opening we have seen here because
white has this A2 sandwich with the
Rooks in A1 and A3 you would love to
throw that pawn off the board to double
up your Rooks on that line but the king
is in the center and you just saw Maxim
grab his head he's like what am I doing
over here I can't block this check by
developing my Bishop because that drops
a critical Pawn that actually would lose
a rook so the king slides over there's a
black Rook on d8 after the castle Queen
side if that D7 Pawn now disappears from
the board it's the white king that's in
huge danger I think Fab's looking at
this position like oh I must have a
winning move and he plays D5 o looks
powerful looks strong looks simple as
well Maxim Vash gra really on the ropes
here in the early stages with white he's
taken massive risks of course but how
does he survive on passant you said it
earlier Robert that was not a mouth slip
a finger slip it was a legal move taking
the pawn as if it just moved one square
but look at this white king in real
danger it slides across to C2 but the
black queen is lurking nearby Black's
Bishop Black's Knight Black's Rook on
the open defile wow this king is living
a Charmed Life already can black profit
that's the big question in an armag
garden with the black pieces I mean this
has got to be a dream position for
Fabiano Carana you've got to win this at
all cost and look at the placement of
the pieces Black's King absolutely safe
in the previous game it was fabby's King
that was out in the open now it's
Maxim's King but how cool and calm is
Maxim just moving uh quickly keeping the
pressure on the clock are we being too
critical about Maxim's chances here you
know Maxim he dabbles in poker right so
he is bluffing his opening has failed
miserably he has an awful position and I
promise you he is regretting playing
this line and Fabby you know he is
really perked up he's looking at this
board like what is my opponent doing I
know how strong he is but he is playing
a very bad game to start with he's not
developed he's not coordinated uh he
probably won't even bee on the clock
that much longer considering how tough
his position is to play David I just you
know it's one of these situations where
it's easy to sit in the chair and
criticize but you know that the biggest
critic for maxim right now is himself
yeah exactly and he veered away from the
strategy that served him so well
eventually in the previous game uh he
was just trying to avoid preparation but
ultimately it's backfired and already
he's forced to find only moves this last
move I think was the only way to keep
the going game going that's how narrow
this tight rope is right now for maxim
Vash graph his Queen was hit he had to
block by developing a piece but Fabiano
is the calm one this time he's opened up
his light squar Bishop Black's light
squar Bishop threatening to land on e4
with a nasty check this looks
terrifying looks like you're facing a
scary attack all of Black's pieces
really perfectly poised right now whites
meanwhile some of them asleep some of
them are on squares not making a great
impression he's trying to trade off
pieces survival is the name of the game
for Max Maxim Vash grav and the more
pieces that get traded off the pressure
against the white king eases off the big
question is what is our clock situation
are we getting are we able to get a read
on that one Maxim has been blitzing out
his move but has he managed to keep the
time advantage that he started with yeah
he does have a Time Advantage I'm
looking at 11 minutes and change for
maxim and nearly 7 half minutes for
Fabby so he does have quite a
substantial lead on the clock but I'm
looking at this position and Maxim is
one move away from castling by hand he
can slide his King back and then looks
like everything is under better control
so Fabby he's looking at like now is the
time I need to find this knockout I need
to find a tactic that works in his my
favor and he is really deliberating
right now because he does not want to
let Maxine back in the game and Maxine
by the way just grabbed his head he is
very unhappy yeah he's not happy at all
but in Practical terms if Fabiano
doesn't find anything in the next few
turns actually this could turn around
and wow Rook to E4 big attack now on the
C4 Pawn Black's Queen Black's Rook
Black's Knight all ganged up against it
and actually this could be a bit of a
knockout blow uh how does Maxine defend
that c
Pawn the H Pawn a bit bit vulnerable as
well if white moves his
Knight's got three attackers on the C4
pawn and White's only got the queen and
the bishop lined up on F1 and E2 which
is guarding the C4 Pawn a big threat on
the board not giving Maxim the time to
get his own King to safety uh do you
have time to retreat with the Knight is
that an option to keep things defended
on C4 it just make me
sad Retreat you don't want it Robert no
I don't want to retreat but you have a
point you might have to do that and if
Maxim can just keep this game going he
has legitimate chances it's a bad
position for white it has been a bad
position but it's the type of position
that if Fabiano can't deliver that Final
Touch then suddenly Maxim like well it's
double edged let's go yeah things can
only get better for maxim it can't get
much uglier than this the problem with
dropping the white nightback is at the
very minimum Fabiano can go up a pawn
take the H4 Pawn off the board Black's
Rook looking in two directions uh maybe
there's more maybe Fabiano will be more
ambitious than that but Maxim he's got
to keep his time Advantage he's on the
back foot he's defending the one
positive is his clock time and uh he
needs to move quickly and it already
feels like it's leveling down big
pressure on White's position currently
uh all of Fab's pieces in a play
attacking White's King on C2 C4 Pawn
dropping right now Maxim Vash lrav in
big big trouble after bidding for close
to 11 minutes and it felt like he really
wanted the white pieces but everything
went wrong from the start it did and he
now has to bring that Rook that was
lifted all the way over from the King
side of to the queen side Rook file back
towards in front of his King he's
defending he's holding on to everything
just for the time being and well if he
can again keep himself alive then he has
a legitimate chance it doesn't matter
what an eval bar might say if Fabiano
gets to say two minutes under that on
the clock that's where mistakes start to
happen but Fabby he's done well on the
clock thus far yeah I think if it gets
to that stage
Maxine will be the favorite because he
knows he will have survived the worst
momentum would have had to have changed
at some point bit of frustration there
from Fabby just scratch of the head
there maybe one hurdle is the fact that
he has too many tempting moves his
position looks too good for black how to
improve it how to land a blow how to
transform the advantage into something
uh more tangible right now how can he
win a pawn how can he kind of win
material he needs something and okay
he's burning a lot of time one minute on
this move alone sudden things less clear
wow big moment here for Fabby well the
first thing came to my mind was jump
with that Knight to the edge of the
board hit that Rook but that allows
Maxim to actually sidestep with the Rook
targeting Fab's Queen on B4 so Knight A4
really doesn't get you anywhere and if
blacks Whit's given one more move of
getting the king to safety Maxim might
be back in the game he's a player who's
always looking for activity he can't be
too happy about his position but the
King has stepped back whoa and so maybe
there's some tactic that follow wants to
rely on with the Rook on D1 being loose
in some lines but Maxim is playing this
quickly and these are the most
frustrating types of positions where
objectively fabbi knows he's ahead but
he has to find the right continuation
and he does just that great move there
from fa Carana and if we can get an
analysis board it would be great to dive
in but the point here is that the Rook
on D1 is loose so after Rook takes
Knight black takes back and it looks
like well black just Blended some
material but after Queen takes Rook
black says I'll do very much the same
thank you for your Rook on D1 and that
would be game over so for maxim right
now he's dropped the pawn his King has
found some safety I don't want to call
it much but Fabiano's still clearly in
charge yeah and beautiful tactics here
just to uh kind of push on your point
Robert Rook takes Knight it looks like
white can actually instead of taking
this Rook just Fork the black rook and
black queen but there are uh very uh
strong replies here very minimum Rook to
B4 pins this white pawn and uh kind of
bags the material so instead we see this
same idea but in a different move order
and KN check first White's King marching
up the board again Black's Queen finds
itself out on a limb slightly but can uh
use a safe Square it drops back to A5
White's King I think is simply the big
Target here it doesn't even matter that
blacks won a pawn there's uh always
going to be ideas on this diagonal for
example how is maxim going to survive
this Onslaught not looking easy looks
like Fabiano he has turned it into
something uh that he can cling on to now
this Advantage an absolute nightmare for
maxim lrav he's the player who wants to
play for the attack he wants to play the
one who's sacrificed material to get the
dynamic going bit here uh Maxim in big
trouble also down upon Queen D2 this
looks like desperation Black's the one
that's coming in with all the power play
is there a finish immediately because we
do see the evalar has just slid all the
way down in Black's favor I would be
thinking how can I move my Bishop away
from D6 with check because if I could
pick that Bishop throw it off the board
The Rook on d8 will win the Queen on D2
so I'm already looking at moves like
Pawn to C4 things of that nature just
trying to rip open the white king the
Eva bar seems to back it up and I think
that fabbi he is ready to take this game
and take the match yeah for example if
Pawn takes Pawn now uh just again to
push on your point Robert Knight takes
porn would be a killer blow if you take
this Knight back Bishop Lance with a
check you gain that necessary Tempo uh
to win the White Queen next move so this
would be a killer right now and actually
we see the engine suggestions just below
the board there Pawn to C4 is by far the
best move gives a winning Advantage
almost plus six for black anything else
and White's actually alive White's in
the game Rook to E8 and now suddenly
turn around wow white is suddenly
winning on the spot with a simple Rook
Retreat this is incredibly difficult
trying to trade off Queens the problem
is KN is trapped yeah that move was not
played because inste he brought his
Bishop out finally developing the piece
even that move Rook C1 it didn't look so
clear cuz the black Rook could have slid
on over to B4 things like that but that
is a Miss it's very easy when you see
the EV go oh my gosh Maxim how could you
miss that he's been defending since the
start of this game he's probably still
in that mindset and as a chess player
you need to be objective at every single
turn it's a new position and you need to
evaluate in the moment not about what's
been happening so for mexim maybe a
missed opportunity and Fabby may not
give him a second chance yeah uh as you
mentioned it doesn't follow the momentum
that opportunity it's so hard especially
with such high stakes with the clock
ticking to suddenly realize your
opponent's left something a bit loose
but uh now again uh momentum back on
black side still a porn up still the
white king is weak is a Target and for
white it's uh it's really hard to find
natural moves nothing instinctive here
for Maxi Vash gra so he has to burn time
on the clock and Black's next move is
the most natural move in the position
you just want to go C4 next regardless
of what white plays you've lined up The
Rook on the B line targeting White's
King the queen on A5 Knight on E3
beautifully placed C4 is coming up also
ideas of getting rid of that white
knight Bishop takes Knight on F3 and
then the black Dart Square Bishop
suddenly comes to life if it ever lands
on the same diagonal as that white king
black Dart Square Bishop it's game over
Bishop to E5 uh would be a deadly pin so
multiple threats in the position and I
thought Fabiano noticed that he
blundered at some point because after
Maxim made his move he looked like whoa
something happened there whereas Maxim
still seems to be in the same exact
shape he's been in all game so for maxim
he after the game will kick himself
because I just quickly looked there were
like four different winning moves for
white any Rook move over there even you
Rook on C5 was available but I just
don't think it was on his radar he's
instead grabbing Pawns in front of uh
the black side of the board it seems to
be irrelevant but I'm also looking at
the clock Fabby down to 3 minutes and 45
seconds this game is so far from over
yeah no increment over the board that's
incredibly tough these days players
always have increment when they're
playing uh OTB and it's not going to be
a pleasant situation if Fabby has to
just rush and uh no matter how winning
his position might be eventually a Race
Against Time is never fun there will be
increment but only after move 60 and
that's a far way off given the position
I don't believe we will get up to move
60 one thing black has to watch out for
the idea of take taking the Knight on F3
Landing with the bishop on E5 right now
doesn't work because notice how with
that last move Maxim has cleared up his
own Queen and Rook lined up on D7 so
whenever Black's Bishop does land on E5
there's a queen D7 check coming in is it
time for Fabby to strike instead with
the move that I'm hoping to see on the
board C4 looks so tempting hard to
resist go for that white king but his
clock is ticking he's under three
minutes and he drops back with a knight
also very natural attacking White's Rook
on C3 just hinting at a possible Queen
check Black's Queen could replace the
white knight uh replace its own Knight
sorry on A3 with a check and uh I can't
complain can't fault this move at all
white now wow according to the engine
there only has one move to keep the
balance not an obvious one white has to
sacrifice his Rook here Maxim Vash gra
he has to run randomize it even more
Rook takes C5 Rook takes pawn and
there's that tactic right that the
bishop takes Queen slides up to D7 with
check so the black king is actually in
the line of fire so you can actually
grab this Rook on C5 that's keeping
white in the game but to play Rook takes
D5 and knowing that your opponent won't
recapture right away then you're going
to have to move your Rook the next move
it's getting very tricky here this is
all happening and if you're Fabiano if
there's a force draw you play it
immediately maybe there's a rook takes
B3 at some moment after King to B1 and
that could lead to some kind of drawing
potential as the queen on D2 feels tied
Tethered to The Rook on D1 that show
that Robert Rook takes Pawn now would
this force a draw that's the big
question would be sufficient for kowana
in an Armageddon situation and I think
you're right how does white evade these
checks if you march to C1 still this
check and it's hard to block for example
if Queen takes then now finally Bishop
takes rook and uh I think black here
would emerge uh in good shape while Maxi
Vash gra in order to keep this game
going he might have to play King to A1
which the engine says isn't the best
move just to avoid that Perpetual check
and it's random but he's still alive and
still has two extra minutes on the clock
King to A1 he's got to do it it is the
best move right the engine says in this
game it's not but in order to stay alive
in this match you needed to play King he
King B1 Rook takes B3 check that should
allow five to force a drawing sequence
immedately instantly and Maxim he needs
to evade these checks but White Queen
cannot move has to defend the D1 Rook no
other way other than Maring your king to
C1 and then there's the line you just
showed where the queen goes A3 you pick
up the rook and White's not winning that
and I'm looking at Fab's clock he's
doing quite well we are what move number
are we on right now 28 so we're already
28 moves in almost halfway to that
increment part of the game but under
three minutes left for Fabby that's a
tricky territory I don't think he's
going to need that extra second on the
clock Fabby I think he's got this queen
to B2 played and does he just pick up
material now is it time to go for Bishop
takes Rook yeah take the Rook back was
The Rook you sacrificed now blacks a
porn up and an an ongoing attack if the
Queens stay on the board Maxim therefore
has to trade the queens and okay we're
in the end game now as uh Dr Strange
said I think but uh yeah it's anyone's
game especially with half an eye on that
clock the bullet Chess Championship did
not go well for Fabiana Carana he's
going to be in a type of bullet scramble
OTB his hands are going to be flying the
pieces may fly off the board that
sometimes happens so watch out for the
clock they only 32 moves in you need to
get to move 60 to get some extra time
and it's only one extra Pawn for black
and counter play it's not an easy extra
Pawn suddenly um I was kind of writing
this off I thought Fabiano would Bank
the draw that was needed but suddenly
white with the kingside majority three
versus two on the other flank could
become a race and anything can happen in
races especially with that clock ticking
he's trying to trade off now Maxi Vash
gra okay he's trying trying to get that
white Rook to the seventh Rank and
Fabiano says no but the clocks are
leveling out now just about a minute
ahead on the clock for maxim Fabby up
upon no increment at least for the next
30 moves and we see that there has been
progress by black the Bishops are off
the king is moving forward it just feels
like the next few moves should flow
easily he wants to start pushing the a
pawn next yeah and you offer the trade
when you're head material you often want
to trade pieces and that opens up the
Rook on e4 to the E2 Square venty you
can start trying to take some of White's
pawns if white goes after yours but an a
pawn T your point is well taken just
throw that pawn forward it may not be
able to be stopped yeah simple moves for
black and nothing easy for white here a
pawn down as well you can bully the
opponent in Armageddon with the prospect
of drawing motifs of exchanges of Trades
they always have to take uh the worst
way out and okay he there we go Maxim
Retreats his Bishop it will come at the
cost potentially of the F2 Pawn or black
can just push the a pawn that's your
trump card just push it oh and he does
it Fabby now under two minutes this is
going to be about flagging Maxim has to
keep the Go game going he has to try to
flag Fabiano Carana it is a dead loss
end game at this level it is because the
a pawn is just Unstoppable you're going
to have to bring your king in front of
it but there's still a rook in minor
pieces on the board so Maxim's doing the
right thing but Fabiano's unfaced he's
doing everything correct in return he's
protecting his only weakness and now
it's actually Maxim on the clock and the
time Advantage isn't very much he's
undone right now and uh Knight back to
E1 that's desperate he's trying to
somehow race with the white knight over
towards uh the queen side to stop that
black a pawn but Fabby just grabs
another pawn two Pawn Advantage now for
black only needs a draw this is getting
close now it's all about the clock
that's the only chance for white it's
getting close to the pieces flying off
the board territory right now as we're
about to touch the one minute Mark and
uh Fabby falls back with the bishop the
a pawn advancing next I'm expecting A3
on the board
he's got about a minute and 40 seconds
and the clocks are really leveling out
now and Maxine he's thinking too much
it's been kind of perfection though from
Fabby because he's what moved 44 and he
spent almost no time so all of these
moves have been happening in a flurry
that's good news for Fabiano and while
he's winning completely on the board
he's has plenty of time to get to move
60 and all he needs is the draw it
doesn't matter if eval bar goes to equal
if it means the game will conclude yeah
he's keeping control that's again the
main thing he's making his moves his
plans easy and here we go the black
pawns are just marching two pawns up
still and if he can remove White's
remaining pawns on the king side even at
the cost of his material advantage that
guarantees the draw and Maxim Vash
actually resigns wow and that's it it
was a double attack Maxim Vash losing
more material he resigns and Fabiano
caruana wins a dramatic Armageddon which
he did make look easy with the black
pieces from start to finish Maxim coming
under tremendous tremendous pressure
right out of the opening and Fabby doing
everything right there as we see uh the
players are leaving the board and we're
going to head over to Toronto with Ka
and
Fabby yeah Tanya I got Fabby over here
right away that was intense to be in
here and watch Fabi what was it like to
play that Armageddon match yeah it was
very very intense match and uh
Armageddon is always tough although I I
was lucky that the opening went very
well so usually I think if the opening
goes badly then you don't have much of a
chance but I got a huge Advantage
probably winning at some point and okay
Maxim was being very tricky so I had to
kind of go into an end game where I'm uh
I'm definitely better but it's uh
probably I had more but okay I only
needed a draw so I had this drawing
margin which was very helpful and going
as low as 952 in your bid take us
through your tactics behind that bid I
don't think it's so low like Magnus and
Hikaru were at some point going to like
7:30 or some but isn't it different when
it's over the board though um yeah it
could could be a bit I I haven't thought
about it too much usually my bids are
around that and the issue is I I wasn't
sure what to play against Maxim with the
white pieces and with black I was fairly
confident that at least I would know
what to do in the opening so I I think
that's the most important thing that you
have a game plan and with white I wasn't
really sure I have a very clear game
plan so how do you feel right now coming
out of this match with the win yeah very
good of course I I mean Maxim is one of
the best players in the world especially
in this format so it was I I knew it
would be a tough match and I'm very
happy yeah and you have another match
coming up as well you're going to play
ala verza in the next one what first of
all what will you do now uh leading up
to that match you have a little break
but it's not going to be that long yeah
it's not a long break I'm not sure so
I'll ask how long it is and then figure
out what I'm going to do yeah have you
prepared everything you need already for
that match against alza I guess we'll
see yeah okay well what should we expect
when you two face off he's also coming
from a match win yeah I think it'll be
another very tough match the thing with
Ali resa is that he's a huge fighter
uh so you always have some very uh
interesting games very fighting games uh
and I think also I'm similar in some
ways that I'm not opposed to an open
fight so that's probably what we'll get
how important is it to take momentum
from this big match win into the next
one I'm not sure how the momentum will
carry it's still the early very early
stages of the event so I I I can't say
for sure uh I hope that I'm in good
shape I mean I think this early match is
still too early for me to say if I'm
playing well or not because it was a bit
sh of course the second game and also
probably for ala he he's not exactly
sure where he's standing at so we're
trying to feel out the the event a bit
all right well I have to let you go get
prepared for the next one
congratulations and good luck Fabby
thank you all right that was Fabiano
Karana he is the winner of the match
against
M he's going to have a next one coming
up against alaa back to you guys in
Oslo thank you ka congratulations to
Fabby but as he said uh it's too early
on in the event and he does face uh the
first uh round winner fuja that's coming
up next there is going to be exciting
chess and this was round one we've got
one more round coming up Magnus wins his
match Wesley so wins his match Fabby
wins and there we see our standings
going into round two of the round robin
at the top of the board there with one
point Ali Resa Wesley Magnus Fabby and
then Maxine Dennis Hikaru nck they've
got to try to win a game and what a
start this has been what an Armageddon
that was I have to say Fabby did make it
look easy with the black beast as David
yeah very convincing performance from
Fabiano straight from the bid from the
opening right to the end only one slip
however and I wanted to show a cool
tactic that would potentially have led
to a turnaround but Maxi Vash lra of
course he was on the defense and this
one was tough to spot in this position
Fabiano had many strong moves he could
have for example played Pawn to C4 an
idea uh we were throwing out there but
Rook D to E8 looks natural there was a
flaw in this plan if White had moved the
Rook from C3 for example dropping it
back suddenly this queen trade would
have favored white if Queen takes Queen
might can recapture with a knight for
example attacking this Knight and this
Rook simultaneously however if the Rook
had blocked this was the trick easy to
miss in time scrambles in Armageddon
chess Rook takes Pawn would have been a
killer blow because the queen is
attacked and if you take this Rook
suddenly white is the one to land a
devastating check and would have won the
game ultimately however once this chance
passed Fabiano calmly skillfully guided
it towards Victory with the final killer
blow being this one Knight to B7 in the
end game if we fast forward and uh this
Rook is attacked if you move it the
black king simply slides back trapping
the rook and the bishop hit as well
really nice technique really nice
technique a really nice middle game a
really nice opening such sh play from
Fabby he's really on top of it Robert is
this some of the best chests that we are
seeing from Fabby yeah you know you look
back to 2014 the SFI cups seven out of
seven start that's the highlight of his
career potential then 2018 playing for
the world championship match almost Lea
frogging Magnus by rating and now here
in 2023 everything seems to be going his
way I think dinner on him when he and
Maxim go out because the winners of each
match get $1,000 so that feels like uh
for those two friends it's on Fabiano to
pay the bill wow well there's still a
lot of uh chess coming up as Fabiano
Carana will be a taking on fuja and not
just that we've got another big one
coming up as the youngest ever World
rapid Champion nbec takes on Magnus
Carlson and they mean business we will
be back from Toronto with these clashes
and look at that don't go
[Music]
anywhere hello V come V come so this is
where the magic happened happens and
this is where all the magic has already
happened yes that's a good way of
putting it that's my world
junior 87 it's difficult to tell you how
many doors that opened for me and what
uh what historical moment it was and
when I got back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them the
W five and there's one on top that is
the sixth one so since he had already
got five they didn't want to give him
the same trophy so they gave him a
trophy of a king with the world in his
hand this is anand's first ever mention
in a newspaper oh so this is his first
ever he was mentioned V Anand achieved a
national record by winning all the nine
rounds to notch a maximum of nine points
in the sub junior Championship but
imagine now TS ri's daughter rakita is
part of the West PJ Academy I mean it's
so beautiful to see how you know life
comes around so World rapid chess and
mind champion so this was nit gave me
this
nice why do I get the feeling that ARA
knows all the trophies and what you want
better than you remember it an cuz I
cleaned the because it's true because
it's
true did you have a favorite thank you
so much an I feel this is extra
motivation for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand Aruna thank you so much for this
[Music]
we developed a knight out to F6 and
after nearly any of White's moves for
example short Castle we play B5 Bishop
to B3 and Bishop C5 and this is the
introduction to the Archangel my name is
fa Carana and I'm a chess Grand Master
and here I welcome you to my course
Carana R Lopez dark Archangel this
course will provide you with a full
repertoire with the black pieces against
the Lopez so let's say after h 5 white
plays H3 cuz white can always take on B6
black plays H4 Bishop H2 G4 we seen this
idea we need to open up the king side we
need to play for the initiative take and
we take with the Knight and the idea is
to play H3 we also always have the
option to take on H2 and if Knight takes
B6 Rook B6 it doesn't really change
anything because we still have many
attacking pieces Knight on G4 Knight on
G6 Pawn H3 coming and Rook h8 coming all
of Black's Army is actually concentrated
at White's
[Music]
King
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved chess.com
game review is just a click away game
review is a fast fun and instructive
guided review of your games see your
accuracy and your opponent's accuracy
check out the eval graph for an instant
overview and scroll down to see how many
great moves best moves blunders and yes
brilliancies you have played learn from
chess.com coach who gives move
explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play with
retry mistakes you can get another shot
at finding missed opportunities try game
review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
just that ugly tape
is
[Music]
a new opening for your your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
this is the 1hour chess lesson you could
take to make sure that you have all the
starting tips strategies and basic
understanding to really be
ready by owning the defile white can do
anything that he or she
wants if you don't understand what to do
here you might move the queen to safety
on C6 and immediately lose the first
lady to Bishop to
B5 King on the 6th Pawn on the fifth is
a a winning King and pawn ending where
no matter what black does we are going
to be able to bring a new Queen to the
[Music]
[Applause]
board you can also skip the parts that
maybe you already know how to move the
pieces or the language uh and jump in at
a level that's appropriate to
[Applause]
[Music]
you
we are back in Toronto Canada with one
round in the books here at the 2023
Champions chess tour finals the weather
outside looks welcome it's not too
chilly it's beautiful and uh We've we've
had some beautiful chess played already
here in round one from the lovely city
of Toronto back here in the playing Hall
with James KY I am Danny wrench and Mand
we just have some crazy on the board
only one armag in battle a little
surprised about that but are you
surprised by any of the results here
from the first round absolutely if I'm
loic I'm like hey I drew the World Champ
I'm feeling good right I didn't lose
both games as expected first game
Jitters are kind of out first match
Jitters are out I got more matches to
play I feel really good I think one of
the maybe maybe not biggest surprises
but Wesley so beat hikaro Nakamura it
didn't go to Armageddon the birthday boy
not off to a good start of course many
Nakamura fans out there wanting him to
rebound he has Maxim bash the grav next
but to to me if there were any other big
results that maybe didn't surprise me
but we should quickly talk about is
Fabiana Carana takes down Maxim bash
lrav and Armageddon and then we have
Notre Becka DUS turov go down against oi
rard fuja either one of those surprised
you you know what the the nck one was uh
really tough I mean he was fighting
obviously in that game fuja found some
good things and also in an mvl game that
one was actually really crazy for me
because it made it to the uh the
Armageddon portion I actually thought
that in the game with the scotch as well
looking at E5 the lines got crazy he had
his chances but he wasn't able to
convert made it to the Armageddon
obviously 51 I think Notre Beck had his
chances in the first game and after that
you give Alli resid the white
pieces it seemed to go Fu's way the
entire time but all right we've seen
we've seen one round in the books let's
move ahead and look at round two the
pairings are changing but we still have
a lot of excitement ahead again you
start at the top Magnus Carlson will get
Abdu Satur off the second youngest
player in the field they're giving
Magnus all the youngsters here
apparently trying to get get the kids
out the way course right after that
you've got the birthday boy taken on BOS
the gra you know that Hikaru is going to
be he's going to be hungry to Rebound in
that one yeah not just for the cake of
course but definitely want a rebound on
my birthday here didn't get a good start
so I got to bounce back right now it's
my birthday Danny you can't do me like
that on my birthday probably the one to
really Circle though is fua Carana
because here you have two people who won
their matches whoever wins this match is
going to in theory be tied for tied for
first with Carlon I guess I'm assuming
Magnus is going to get it done maybe I
shouldn't do that he is taking on a
world rapid champion in Notre Becka DUS
turov so all right well we've talked
about whether Magnus will keep winning
will the birthday boy rebound when it
comes to talking about Magnus and Hikaru
we caught up with Magnus to give him a
little bit of Hikaru trivia a lot of
people saw the video that came out a
couple weeks ago where Hikaru was run
through a series of questions about
Magnus now it's magnus's turn to see how
much he knows about the guy who's
celebrating his birthday today and uh
let's see what we got up to in Norway
you ready for some hikaro Nakamura
trivia sure all right what's your
favorite hikaro Nakamura video I don't
know I I have any specific favorite but
anytime like he starts losing and he's
tilting that's that's the most enjoyable
for me
okay oh
no no all right what month was AAR
Nakamura born in
December I'm going to I guess 9th wow
got it ding ding ding what country was
hiar Nakamura born in I think hiar was
born in Japan what city of Japan oaka
okay we're killing it how many siblings
does aaro have uh I know that aaro has a
brother who plays chess uh I'm going to
guess that he has one more sibling no oh
no he only has one only and what's his
brother's name Asuka there you go what
happened first you winning the Norwegian
Chess Championship or Hikaru winning the
US Chess Championship well Hikari is 3
years older than I am and I I know he
won the US Championship fairly young and
I did lose the playoff twice so I'm
going to guess that he won it first
that's correct what year did he win it
say probably 2003 or 2004 2003 2004 he
had it though before chess.com Hikaru
was the highest rated player on the
internet chess club with two usernames
two handles do you know what those two
usernames were it has to be Smallville
and cap on the bridge nailed it bonus if
you can name his username on play chess
no I'm not going to remember that Star
Wars Star Wars yeah I yeah that's true I
definitely played Star Wars Hikaru has
authored one chess book do you know the
title I have the book that he's authored
it's about bullet chess I think it's
called like one minute Checkmate or
something yeah wow wow with uh like
Bruce Harper is that yeah you're nailing
it okay what is hiar nakamura's Peak fed
rating well he was number two in the
world where a lot of people were pretty
high
rated so I think it's got to be well
over
2800s
2017 oh man you are good you were close
286 point something so that was pretty
good all right which of these events has
AAR Nakamura won five of the speed Chess
Championship the jalter chess festival
and the US Chess
Championship uh I think that's the trick
question I think he's won all of them at
least five times only two did win jalter
five times only four yeah oh it was a
trick question yeah doing our best here
who did aaru beat to win his first US
Championship some reason the name that
pops up is kaidanov so I'm going to go
with that ildar
ibov yeah there you go close enough no
one would have known that one I think
all right which TV show has AAR Nakamura
made a cameo appearance
on uh I think Yar made um a cameo on uh
billions that's right cuz they could not
get me did which is a True Story by the
way what what is it they got him cuz
they couldn't get me oh really yeah
there you go I love that all right last
question when commentating on the xqc
moist critical match how many moves was
that game over in who was hikaru's co-
commentator and what was Hikaru
nakamura's final thing he said right
before the Checkmate I mean that's the
scotch game right like there was
probably made on
F2 How does it
go
C3 R
C5 yeah probably five moves then I think
that was was that four moves one two
three four five six it was six moves
inste of four moves who was his co-
commentator
uh who was com was that the first part
CH first po
Champs too soon Hikaru that was the
line uh was it you no bz Alexandra okay
yeah we tried to stump you in the end
but we really didn't do a very good job
I wonder if Hikaru is going to do as
well with Magnus Carls and trivia that
was impressive yeah I feel like I did
okay I have to say that in watching that
I really feel like we kind of tricked
Magnus more than more than once he was
he was right on several of those the
jalter one was really harsh um and the
fact that he remembered hik Caro's Peak
rating of 28 16 point something he was
basically right about that but anyway
pretty fun to see if those who didn't
see the Hikaru video doing a similar
version of trivia on Magnus back on
magnus's birthday on November 30th you
should check that out on one of our many
different channels but all right it's
time for us to play prediction again kle
you're back at the desk for a reason
here we go we're going to start again
with Magnus Carlson now taking on Notre
Beck of dusa turov Ky your thoughts
gotta go with Carlson he's hot I mean he
won the first match and I want to
consistently win here Abdul Satur has
lost the first match so we definitely
got to gohe Magnus on this okay I've
seen Magnus back in the players loung
chair he is so relaxed in a good mood
definitely Magnus Carlson this one again
it's it's hard because Notre Beck losing
that first very very close match to fuia
means he is up against it but again hard
to pick against Magnus Carlson at this
point so all right Magnus it is for me
as well hikara Nakamura is taking on NBL
the birthday boy looking to rebound your
thoughts then it's my birthday I got to
go with me every time hiar Nakamura all
right I'm going to disagree I still
think ml has some big things coming up
in this tournament I'll say ml all right
that would be a big start if AAR
Nakamura was 0 and2 we'll see if MV can
take him down I will I will take Karu to
Rebound in that one and uh and move on
to our next match up Fabian Carana
taking on o Resa fuia this is a match
between two people who won a huge one I
think for their ultimate finish here in
the round robin stage your thoughts
slight Edge on fbby slight Eds on Fabby
just feeling good after that armag get
and you just a good I can breathe a
little bit more so I'm gonna take the
Fabby for this I'm gonna agree with you
Fabiano Carano okay Fabiano Carana I'm
GNA take Fabiano Carana as well I think
I picked Fabby I actually don't remember
who I picked check the screen there it
says U oh I did okay I actually I
actually don't remember I'm sorry about
that that's live television right there
but it tells you that this because I
think this one could go either way for
sure right baruja also in fine form
right now looking fresh not maybe as
fresh as Fabby though I'm going to take
Carana and then finally we have the last
match up Wesley so Wesley so solid
Wesley so solid go with so have to go
with Wesley so here he is uh becoming
one of the favorites in the tournament
if you ask me I'm also going to take
Wesley I think that uh unfortunately for
Dennis lavic it's a little bit about out
of The Frying Pan Into the Fire here
Wesley so I think will also start 2
after beating hi car already so all
right these are just our predictions we
want to know what you think in chat I
don't know if there's any kind of poll
going but let us know your thoughts of
course aot A lot of these matches could
go either way as the players file in
we're going to file out right now as we
get set for round two from Toronto we'll
be joining you in chat we're going to
send this thing back to Oslo with Tanya
and the boys Tanya and the boys if you
can hear us take it
away D daddy James
round two is about to begin and we did
see Maxim VRA in the background there
perhaps getting a listen in on those
predictions well he did lose his first
round to uh Fabiano karwana and there he
is uh he already has to start thinking
about this game as he's playing against
the mighty Hikaru both with a first
round loss what do we expect in this one
well I don't think anyone had that in
their bingo card that both Maxim and
hikaro would lose their opening round
match but that's the nature of this
field what to expect when Max and H car
play chaos fiery chess these two are
super aggressive they need to start
getting some wins both of them need a
win here because you can't afford to
drop both your matches on the first day
yeah both have shown glimpses uh even if
things went against them in round one
Hikaru was tenacious hung around in
there if it wasn't for that first kind
of Rush of Blood to the Head kind of
avoiding the draw there against Wesley
in the first game Hikaru might well have
taken that and Maxim likewise did get a
win against kowana and in the end
Armageddon uh is a bit of a lottery but
um yeah tough one to call this might be
the closest match of this round O this
is going to be an exciting one and there
we have uh the world number one Magnus
Carlson who did make it look easy in
round one and Kaa did catch up with
Magnus after his round one
Victory Magnus Carlson did a job against
Dennis lovic are you happy with how this
went minus yeah I'm obviously happy with
the results um I think the games were
um decent but not not great I think he
played um he played well uh he only you
know failed to find the best
continuations when he was down on on
time in the first game and that you know
is not always so so easy so I think in
general he played uh he played quite
well and he also put a little bit of
pressure on me in the second game so I
think um yeah I think he did well I did
you know okay just about enough to win
the match and um that's that's what I'll
take with me we'll have a little bit of
a break now because there will be Arma
gon actually what will you do now will
you follow that will you prepare what's
going to happen yeah I'll follow it but
um I'll prepare as well because you do
have Abdu saturo coming up in your next
match what what should we expect from
that one yeah I think satov is uh is
really tough he's hard to um to break
down and he fights well when he has spad
positions so it's um it's not easy you
always need to be vigilant when you when
you play him but you know I've beaten
him before so I hope to do it again
definitely do you see the chances are
very big for you to to come out a day
one with two match wins well they're
better after I won one 5050 all right
Magnus thank you so much best of luck in
the next one and back to you guys Magnus
gon there looking uh to get in that
second win as well he does play against
NC Abdu satro of course the both uh both
Magnus and nbec have had some fantastic
games between each other uh and it's uh
it's going to be an exciting battle as
we are going to have our first moves in
just a few seconds as the players are
ready to go and we go into the playing
Arena handshakes and we're off round two
let's do this and uh okay quick start to
the game between Nakamura and Maxim Vash
gra Nakamura employing the same opening
he tried against Wesley so in uh game
one the trovy attack uh unorthodox stuff
not often seen at this level and both
players desperate Robert desperate for
the win in this one and this has shades
of the World Chess Championship Match
back in 2016 it started with a trpovski
and Magnus of course he ended that
remaining the world champion but it's
Rich it's not well studied at the
highest level because it's not so common
uh but these players they look at every
single line under the sun especially
Hikaru who plays so many games of
he's going for something that Maxim is
not as familiar with as say a grunfeld
which you talked about Maxim being a
leading expert yeah interesting strategy
surprise effect valued extremely highly
by these players and Nakamura forcing uh
Maxim here to be the first one into the
tank yeah and you've got to be into the
tank because hikaru's just grabbed a
pawn and now he's hinting at holding on
to that pawn for a long long time that
last move with the a pawn moving forward
the B Pawn is about to move forward to
defend the C5 and these positions it's
all about Black eventually proving
compensation based on the activity in
the center yeah that being said I
mentioned it earlier today every time I
see Maxine play Black he's a PN down and
uh he he does have uh severe
compensation actually serious
compensation uh active pieces
potentially Bishop pair porn Center and
uh some pressure now yeah big pressure
on the queen side and you see that
hikaro develops his Knight out giving up
this Pawn on B4 so he's is willing to
return his extra Pawn there are
definitely tactics in the air that he is
relying on but for maxim I don't see the
danger in the position and for M for
himself he better not Overlook something
because hiar wouldn't play down this
variation unless he had something up his
sleeve yeah do you think Max SE has
looked at this as well it's just break
neck speed rushing up to this moment and
uh all forcing stuff level material yet
again and now a check the black king hit
by White's Bishop this is really direct
stuff it could go badly wrong as you
mentioned Robert if Maxim isn't aware of
what he should be doing he needs to
block this check do not move that black
king it'll be too exposed in the center
uh big moment already but there is an
issue for Maxine that he's trying to
resolve right now is if you normally
block a check with your Bishop but then
after the white Bishop captures if the
black queen captures back there's a
check on the final rank that looks scary
maybe there's nothing more to it than a
single check but we actually see Maxim
allow Queen to A8 and it's played by
Hikaru and King E7 what are we looking
at here this is incredible Tanya I was
just going to say this has got to be
preparation we're looking at some
preparation you don't just make the move
King to E7 capture on D7 with your queen
put that Bishop to block there allowing
this line unless you're familiar with
this uh would that be an accurate
judgment David do you think Maxim knows
this position I think Hikaru definitely
does judging by the fact uh his kind of
mic drop just got up from the board
there Maxine probably is aware as well
it's all been very forcing stuff but
normally you take a bit of time at least
you especially if you know your opponent
has kind of cook this up at home you
smell a rat you sit there looking for
options you try and Dodge their
preparation but Maxim's confidently
played down this line he spent a couple
of minutes yes but um now the first real
think of the game the first real think
and it is quite a moment because you're
thinking about grabbing that C2 Pawn but
yes you grab the pawn but how is that
knight ever coming back Knight takes
Pawn the king just Sid steps I don't
believe maxi will go for that he did
pause but eventually does retreat with
the Knight the Knight on C2 would have
been trapped that's right don't get
overly greedy if you are Maxim V lrav
and said Retreats his Knight puts it on
the rim where it's aiming back towards
that C5 Pawn so we see both players here
this has been an interesting opening
thus far both players seem well aware of
the intricacies I will say though that
that black king on E7 it it's safer now
but it can come under Fire in
particularly the F5 square that those
Knights would love to jump in on the
squares cuz black has a dark Square
Bishop inherent to having a bishop you
can't compete for one color complex so
the F5 Square does look juicy for the
white Knights yeah I would say
objectively level Maxim should have
everything under control but looks in
Practical terms so difficult to play for
black and wow it's now move 16 Hikaru
has barely paused for breath just look
at the speed with which Hikaru is
playing this position I mean he did not
even blink before retreating the move to
A2 and giving up another pawn and aaro
looked up you know he's in his
preparation still he's trying to to
remember it but Maxim himself does
appear to be in his preparation you
don't play these moves this quickly
unless you've looked at it but I'm
looking at the evalar and that's going
up and up in hikaru's favor and I would
say practically speaking this looks
great for hikaro he's given up just one
Pawn his King is tucked at home on G1
castled safely The Rook that just uh
castled with can go over to the queen
side to help out in an attack and that
F5 square that is going to be a
vulnerable one for maxim who's still
playing quickly I'm unsure how confident
he is though that his position is good
Robert I hate it I hate what Maxim's
doing I think he should just slow down
now before it's too late uh simply
White's Knights are coming in Black's
King is going to come under heavy fire I
mean yes you're a porn up but you have a
weakness on B7 that will drop anyway so
that's not a long-term factor and I
think Maxim he's trying to kind of uh
Bluff his way here he's trying to say
toaru yes you've prepared I've prepared
too but sometimes you just have to kind
of P pause you have to dig deep and uh
just before the momentum starts to shift
you have to really go into defensive
mode I think Maxim might get punished
very quickly in this game well Maxim
just left his chair and I'm wondering if
somehow he's done such deep preparation
that even though the engine favors white
right now that if you continue down the
main lines pieces get traded maybe you
get into an end game where white is up
one Pawn but can't make progress Maxim
does have that kind of depth to his
preparation and right now it looks
really scary but Maxim just left and
maybe he's trying to leave his rook and
go from H depart on all the way over
there slide his King back to f8 and say
you have no attack I am up a pawn prove
it it's either great preparation by
Maxim VRA or a complete Bluff by him the
speed with which he's been playing uh is
it deception or does he know this
position that is the big question for
all of us in the studio and as Robert
pointed out white is dreaming of getting
that Knight to F5 it takes two moves to
do that and for maxim it takes two moves
to get the king to safety I don't know
what engine he's been studying this
opening with but the engine I have in
front of me says white is just
completely winning already so uh bizarre
stuff to play this quickly this sharply
uh complicated chess and it looks like
it's going to favor white wow big big
result if that does happen but of course
plenty of hard work ahead for Hikaru
converting advantages is one thing
especially when you're a porn down if
the attack doesn't work uh things could
turn very quickly but impressive
Confidence from Maxim Vash gra either
way I want to learn from him just uh his
body language so positive despite the
fact he's in trouble I share your fears
and concerns I would not like to have
this position from black but I also
trust Maxim to be able to hold difficult
positions and the most tempting move to
me is just jumping with the Knight up
over to G3 going into the F5 square but
I do think black is just in time to
bring the Rook out from the corner and
slide his own King back so this is
interesting all games in this event
every single match promises excitement
Maxim Nakamura big round for these two
players who did lose their first game so
it's extremely important to get that
confidence back to get going on the
scoreboard now the two players who did
win their first round are facing each
other it is Fabiano Carana taking on
alira
fua and there we've got them on our
screens and it looks like fabbi is the
one who's in a think right now is there
is there a favorite in this uh in this
matchup
Robert you're asking a very difficult
question uh I would say that Fabiano had
the better year of Chess but we spoke to
Ali Risa and he was saying I took this
year to focus on me I wanted to uh get
into different so social circumstances I
wanted to just explore other things
outside of Chess but next year he said
he promises in 2024 he will be playing
much more chess so he's still focused
right now in this position I would say I
like Whit's pawns all these Pawns in the
fourth rank we make have a fifth Pawn
joining if that pawn pushes up once
Square to D4 but I do like this position
for Fabiano I also know from experience
that he's well versed in these type of
ideas and structures yeah that being
said fua as well from the white side I
see him as one of the world's leading
experts on the Italian game um this is
the Italian opening and uh yes a set of
light squared Bishops have been traded
off yes it's a bit quieter uh right now
but um fuja I'm wondering how he
activates his pieces maybe the black
queen needs to move maybe that black
rook in the corner gets into the game
and black is active too so white has the
space white has the beautiful porn
structure but no real weaknesses in the
black Camp objectively roughly balanced
still a long way to go how would you
guys be uh approaching this type of
position uh is it about maneuvering is
it calculation time already I think it
very well might be right uh you
mentioned Robert that you like White's
position for me I think that black is
has set up quite a bit of play already I
love that Bishop on A7 that's eyeing the
diagonal The Rook is already lifted to
E6 I'm dreaming of it Landing on G6 at
some moments the Knight on H5 and G6
eyeing the F4 Square David I agree with
you it's calculation time and having
played uh well these kind of positions
with the black pieces I feel that aliar
should be happy with the opening outcome
now is there anything Direct in this
position that's the big question and uh
always when your opponent has a king
that can potentially be targeted you
should look at going for it as quickly
as possible and one question uh you
mentioned sliding that Rook The Rook
lift the theme of the day so far can
black throw a knight into the F4 square
and say I'm clearing the path for a rook
if you take me I will replace that with
another Knight I'm not sure whether
black even flicks in a check first of
all maybe you do and once the other
Knight lands suddenly it's three pieces
three is the magic number here one Rook
check threatened uh you're threatening
to take this Pawn with the black Bishop
you're threatening to maybe deliver
Checkmate within two moves with the
black
queen this looks scary looks very scary
how does white survive this uh this
attack it looks scary but if I trust
somebody to have studied scary lines
Fabiano is definitely at the top of the
list but I'm with you this to my eyes
looks like black has a blossoming attack
that might end the game very quickly so
we'll see if ala does go for this
because it's quite committal I you see
the engines saying it's about level but
when you give up material and the engine
says it's equal that might mean you
either have a repetition by force or you
have to prove it move after move and
over an extended period of time we quite
often see mistakes made by the attacking
player yeah so I do Enis a long long
think here from fuja it is that
committal as you mentioned Robert and no
way back you're essentially saying I'm
sacrificing I'm going to Checkmate you
or I'm going to lose on material and uh
that type of decision is well it takes
courage and it's a really tough one um I
think he might go for it it is his style
Alara it really is right he's known for
his creative aggressive play and it is
the moment he's paused and the fact that
he's gone into a think this has got to
be the move that you're looking at
because otherwise you just Blitz out a
normal move like Queen to D7 or queen to
F6 but I think if black plays slow here
white gets the time to bring that knight
from F1 to E3 block out the diagonal and
then you've lost this moment to actually
go for the direct line that you were
pointing out David and I I noticed the
evalar didn't move after sacrificing the
Knight so it it looks like it approves
huge moment will Ali RZA fuja go for the
critical Knight to F4 or will he take it
safe here we will check in on that and
right now this is the view of the
playing Arena the T
is high as the players get into round
two and we will move on to Wesley so who
plays with the white pieces after his
win against takkaru Nakamura against the
17-year-old Dennis lazic and wow A lot
has happened here my first feeling I
always like black in these positions
yeah Wesley so it feels like Nakamura
woke the bear he poked the bear and
suddenly Wesley's taking risks because
what Wesley's done is very committ it's
Knights against Bishops yes white has a
better Pawn structure uh everything
connected black has two sets of doubled
pawns on the C file and f file some weak
squares as well but yeah the potential
of Black's pieces here especially that
white king in the corner he's got to be
feeling nervous Wesley the best part I
would say though of Dennis laz's game is
his clock he's actually ahead on time
and Magnus made a point of this in those
interviews saying Dennis is a great
player he can hang with everyone here
except when he gets in time trouble so
the fact that he actually is the one in
the lead on the clock I think that bod's
well for his chances and on the other
hand I would say that for Wesley he's
like let's make this a long game I'm one
of the most precise players in chess
history so let me give you a terrible
Pawn structure double F pawns Double C
pawns the bishop pair it's not really
reigning Supreme across the board and
those Knights could hop into F5 at some
moment as long as you cover up your king
side so I do think that Wesley's playing
a long battle here yeah a long battle
and this last move it hinted a couple of
different plans white could start
throwing pawns towards the black king uh
you could start pushing the B Pawn maybe
breaking the center with the D Pawn
either way he's saying to Dennis how do
you improve Black's position Black's
Bishops look perfectly poised like you
say not quite doing that much work but
uh how to improve them big question
Black's Queen how do you improve her
Black's Rooks I think they're pretty
much optimally placed right now no easy
no natural moves and uh here might be
where Dennis starts to burn some of his
clock and uh yeah I don't know who to
pick I think ultimately it's balanced
and okay it's just who Maneuvers their
pieces better who does better with their
minor pieces Dennis mysterious move but
I think the idea is to create a Escape
Square for black d square Bishop the
bishop can Retreat now back to A7 it's
going to be hard to break through
against that black king a lot of Pawns
around it a lot of shelter there and uh
yeah a long game guaranteed in this one
as you mentioned Robert I hear you guys
I'm still liking the bishop bear I'm
still liking the open G line I'm still
liking a potential F5 someday far away
uh I do like the Bishop here but for
Dennis lazic it will be critical to not
go down on the clock and uh we will keep
an eye out on this one Wesley taking a
bit of a think uh will he start
expanding this position on the queen
side will he go for the break on F4 this
is a big big moment for him I want to
check in on the Hikaru game uh as that
one is really heating up I've got my eye
out on that one and it seems like the F5
square is quite the theme of the day
today yeah white has landed a knight on
F5 in that game as white will likely do
in this game at some point in the near
future Wesley's Knights look poised F5
is a night nice Outpost for those pieces
but uh still some vulnerable squares
around wh King so you can't rush and uh
yeah maybe we jump over to that game
that you mentioned uh Tanya Hikaru can
he bounce back that preparation I was
critical of Maxim Vash graph but um that
one looks still actually in the balance
looks like Maxim playing confidently
playing quickly he has stabilized and in
these positions he's still a point up as
well so even if it was bad prep
sometimes you feel confident thinking
you're in prep like maybe he wasn't
actually in the line that he thought he
was in but you you feel that confidence
oh I know what I'm doing and then after
the game if you lose like okay I I
misremembered so Maxim Still Remains
upon PA a head his King is in the center
of the board all of his pieces seem to
be defending one another and hikaro
needs to prove that he has enough
compensation which I do believe he does
for the sacrifice Pawn but for now Maxim
he look looks very cozy in that secret
lab chair yeah I've seen that body
language too often Maxim is one of the
top players I've faced the most uh with
the same generation and ever since he
was young he would have this pose you
know when he's confident you know when
he thinks he's doing well and it seems
to be one of those times Maxim happy to
be a pawn up um I've also been on the
wrong end of his Bluffs sometimes he's
not doing so well but he still acts the
same and uh here it's just about whether
Hikaru can break through one beautiful
piece we mentioned that White Knight on
F5 but the rest of the pieces not quite
contributing as much right now and uh it
feels like Hikaru needs to speed up in
terms of activating his pieces black has
really done a good job of covering
everything I like Black's position I
don't see the attack I think that black
has everything under control the C3 Pawn
it's eyed by that Queen over there the
Knight on A6 can slide back to C7 to be
a defensive piece it also jump forward
to C5 if it needs to get into the middle
of the board so I think that Hikaru
surely has some good options here he's
got some good squares but at least the
way the game is going and the way Maxim
looks right now I'm starting to like his
chances with the black pieces especially
when you consider the clock situation
yeah I'm going to admit I'm going to eat
my words I'm I was wrong Maxim playing
so quickly in the opening maybe he knew
uh what we didn't maybe he'd seen a bit
deeper and realized yes the computer
favors white but only with a series of
difficult accurate moves and uh Hikaru
okay showing some indecision that white
Rook landed on B1 very recently just a
few moves ago now it's kind of zigzagged
well it's just dropped back in the same
direction staring at the black D5 Pawn
but there's a knight in the way that D5
Pawn can be protected Hikaru uh showing
a sign of uh yeah maybe nerves getting
to him the turn is that strong you can't
take a single move off because these
players will punish you if you make a
mistake and Maxim uh he is doing very
well right now as he is a pawn to the
good his king is not really in danger at
the moment it can be later in this game
so I think he should be happy with the
position he's been able to obtain and of
all the people who lost in the first
game Maxim he probably had the best
match overall he did take it to
armagedon after making a comeback in
with that game to win against Fabiano
Kiron and right now looking confident
getting that initiative going playing
with speed right now up on the clock as
well Maxim vasher lra uh crazy things
happening on the Fabiano alira board we
will check we will come back to this one
but let's check in and go straight to
there the sacrifice that David was
talking about ali RZA fuja has gone for
it the Knight did land on F4 after the
big think and it is uh Fabby right now
who's got some critical critical
decisions to be made with his King in
the open fabulous Fabby he is facing a
Checkmate in one threat right now fua
did sacrifice the Knight and is now
threatening to jump with his Queen to
take on H3 that would be the end of the
game but uh Fabiano does have two ways
to deal with this either a knight can
land on F5 theme of the day as Tanya
mentioned or the other white knight can
drop back to G1 that looks a bit shaky
retreating o I would not be uh showing
too much faith on that one but he does
retreat rather than jumping forward and
blocking that black queen and uh now
tactics in the air that surprising the
engine hates the move and Knight F5 that
looked like a natural jump forward after
Knight to G1 is that suggestion Rook
takes Knight as the top move that's not
an easy move to play because there's no
direct Checkmate but the problem is
white is lacking defenders in front of
his King Robert I don't know if you guys
noticed it but Ali Resa just leaned back
the moment Knight G1 was played he is
thinking about Rook takes Knight with
the queen jumping into H3 we're going to
see that on the board I have no doubts
yeah Rook takes Knight let's follow
through with that variation removing the
key Defender pouncing now on H3 that's
guaranteed wh King has to retreat and
take this rook and now suddenly a
monster threat of Bishop takes Knight
removing thei final Defender and
delivering a nasty mate on G2 and at
first I thought okay you can just BL uh
block sorry the black Bishop with a move
like Pawn to C5 uh now if this Knight
stays on the board no Checkmate but
black simply plays a calm move like H5
and white is stuck white can never
defend the king and Simple Plan Rook
lift Rook across to E8 and uh once The
Rook slides across it comes to G6 game
over within three moves this is so hard
from a human point of view yeah you say
Simple Plan once you get to that
position you're right it is simple if
the pawns on H5 black is going go Rook
E8 Rook e 6 Rook E6 Checkmate thank you
very much but to see all that in your
head when there's so many options for
white that is the tricky part not to
mention that instead of C5 Queen G4 also
comes to mind you have to calculate so
much in this position and I think that's
the key point the move H5 that you
pointed out to me I was like wait that's
a mysterious move why not get the Rook
into the play already but you want to
take away the key G4 Square stopping the
queen from coming in offering the trade
Rook takes Knight is on the board we're
going to see this being played out this
is just genius from fuja he needs to see
this H5 move however uh let's go to the
live position he's going to play Queen
takes H3 that's the most logical
followup I don't think you need to
consider anything else Knight takes Pawn
potentially but there we go the most
natural move threatening Bishop takes
Knight with a Checkmate Queen to G4 we
did mention as an alternative Robert and
uh now this would be met by Bishop takes
Knight removing the defender of White's
Queen and after Queen takes Queen I see
what he missed Knight takes Queen and
after you go if you're King to G2
there's Knight f for check and you save
both of your pieces and if you go King
to H2 instead of King to G2 Knight takes
F2 Rook takes E3 Knight G4 check so
there is this Fork at the end that saves
black because white was up excuse me a
lot of material but black is able to win
this Rook with interest so this is such
a deep line ala fua he is a calculating
monster right now and he's holding
nothing back wow this is beautiful
geometrically everything works for black
if you cannot play Queen G4 eliminate
White's uh sorry black best defender
there Black's best attacker even then uh
yeah simply no way to guard your king
long term White's King is doomed and uh
I think you might have to just trade
Queens off give up the White Knight and
hope to survive in that end game but
that is horrible for white and uh kowana
big
trouble big trouble here for Fabby and
we often see that this is really the way
if you want to get your chances against
the world's best players against the
world number one or the world number two
here Fabiano kwana who looks impossible
to beat right now just getting them in
these complicated positions from the
very start and and to me it all comes
down to that decision of going in with
Knight to F4 David when you suggested
that move we saw the evalar say that
white is doing fine but it poses so many
practical problems which even the
world's best players can often not
navigate through exactly that's my
advice to players in general uh even if
you're playing someone higher rated than
you even if you're playing someone
significantly more experienced attack
them that's how they uh that's how you
win games essentially that's making the
opponent uncomfortable they want to be
respected they want you to play Slowly
they want to kind of have the time to
dictate the pace to impose their will on
the position but if you attack them good
things can happen and here Fu has backed
it up with solid calculation and
sometimes those top players they miss
the sixth move of a line and that's
exactly what's happening to fabbi so
full credit to Al zaa he's holding
nothing back and I think for fabbi he's
looking at his current position does he
go for David C5 which cuts off the
Bishop from the Knight on E3 he can go
for that uh Queen G4 that looks so
miserable but maybe there are decent
chances to survive that you will have a
rook for a knight but for that exchange
down the black will have like three
pawns for it so it's it's too much
material material things are heating up
in this match uh let's head over to
where the action is happening we've got
Danny with us to talk more about this
big game Danny what's going
on I just couldn't sit on the sideline
any longer with all the action happening
first fuia sacks on G7 and Knight F5 as
the killer blow against Notre Beck now
he sacks a knight on F4 he doesn't value
his Knights he's gone full tale gone
full
tail this is amazing stuff Danny and he
really doesn't stop like you said gives
up the Knight gives up the rook and
we've been talking about this is this
the way to play against the world's best
to try to win the
game I I think it's the way you you want
to play if you want to win this thing I
mean he probably heard me saying that
Fabby was uh was my pick I think I think
I maybe pissed him off a little bit or
something because fuia is is coming out
like a wrecking ball if he wins this
game as black I mean you get white on
the second game even harder to imagine
him not starting with 2 so I think fuia
is is bringing the Heat and I I love it
Denny we heard from Fabiano after his
Armageddon win what was fuja like in
between the
matches he was chill he was hanging out
in the uh in the lobby everybody headed
back up to their room once they had the
uh the break between the rounds but no I
mean fua is calm and he I I said this
after having dinner next to him last
night that he seems focused and he seems
poised and it's been interesting to just
think about Fu's career in terms of
everything that he's been through over
the last couple years you know being
dubbed by Magnus as the only guy he
would play A world championship against
really struggling in the candidates and
in some ways maybe it's taken a little
bit to find his footing but you got a
Vibe you got a vibe from fuia last night
and I'm I'm excited to see if this
continues
yeah Danny you mentioned the up and down
couple of years that F has had after
reaching number two in the world do you
think he could be a dark horse to win
the event
even I why not right I mean Magnus
himself was basically dubbing him his
successor if this guy shows up playing
the type of Chess that we know fuia is
capable of uh regardless of the fact
that maybe he didn't playing as many
events this year as a guy like Fabiano
did the fact is that we know what he's
capable of and if you're winning games
with the black pieces against a guy
who's been as hot as Carana this is uh
this I don't think anybody else in that
room is looking at this and they're
happy seeing the uh the fire coming out
of
fuja it is a fire on the boat Dan you're
going to love the way the game has
progressed it's exactly the line that we
were looking at uh in the studio we will
check in with you soon thank you for
joining us and have fun in Toronto and
keep us uh updated with everything that
goes on there thank thanks for letting
me jump in
Danny with all the news coming in from
the players and he mentioned that aliisa
was quite chilled between breaks and
he's playing some really he's got no
chill in this game I mean the line that
David pointed out H5 on the board no
more Queen G4 I'm liking black chances
more and more what a game this has been
so far he's a whole Rook down but he's
playing like nothing happened he's just
going single-mindedly one track mind
here for that white King David this is
exactly the plan that you mentioned get
the pawn to H5 stop that Queen from
coming to G4 and with all the chill that
Dan's been talking about simply get the
Rook the final piece into the attack
Rook E6 Rook G6 coming up next but look
at Fabby being resourceful he gave up
his Rook for a night saying please take
my Rook that gets rid of one of the most
imposing attackers in the position and
white has already had a rook for Just
Two pawns so he said please take my Rook
that's not going to happen then he
slides his Queen on over to F1 please
trade Queens with me I need to save my
king and I think Aliva needs to play the
move Queen to F3 here slide that Queen
over um the engine it went back up a
little bit for white but it does look
very scary with that Rook lift coming E6
to G6 uh I don't really know how to
continue this attack perfectly but I do
know that white is in grave danger and
may have some only moves yeah still
looks extremely scary for White and
objectively the evaluation bar still on
black side there um the engine here I
think I would play the same uh Robert
the engine says don't of course don't
trade Queens Queen F3 good as well but
even stronger Knight takes Rook getting
rid of an attacker not obvious I think
uh because the Knight looks so valuable
there but now slide your Rook up and
white is just powerless white has to for
example walk into a self pin dropping
the queen back and then dropping the
Knight back to block this check but now
you can start simply munching on pawns
start taking this Pawn for example even
a move such as A5 unleash the bishop and
white is pretty much stalemated white is
stuck forever at the right time start
pushing this Pawn forward use it as a
battering ram and just eliminate the
remaining defender on G2 this is just
game over but not obvious this first
move especially to trade off when you're
going for the attack I'm going to push
back on that I don't see ala fuja
trading Queens here I think he's going
to go for this idea and he's picked up
the Rook David we are going to see this
attack through immediately plays the
move Rook to E6 now touching the one
minute Mark and really nicely pointed
out by you once he's got all the pieces
of white clamped up defending the white
king you think about opening up that
Bishop on A7 the final piece will join
the attack alira playing flawlessly it
looks brutal for a fbby to defend and
this is the complete opposite of the
game between Magnus Carlson and nordbeck
abusar that is a very peaceful Affair it
looks very level slightly better for
Magnus but all eyes are on this game
here because if fuja can do what he did
to Fabby at the candidat back in 2022 he
had a terrible event but suddenly in the
last round fuia crushed Fabby from the
black side he's trying to do the same
and I don't know how you defend your
points are very well taken here The Rook
Li coming in White's going to be all
sorts of tangled up yeah and meanwhile I
was going to say that this is by far the
most exciting game of the round suddenly
lazic blunders in one move in what was a
level position uh so we might have to
check in on that one a bit later but uh
right now fua he is the one making the
magic happen Fabiano he has to just go
passive he has to curl up into a ball
try to defend these next few moves but
black should with best play be
winning maybe with even less than best
play be winning in this position you've
got all the forces into the attack uh
and Fabiano kanana playing the best
chess of his life for Ali Resa to be
able to do this with the black pieces uh
in about 25 moves yes it's not over
there's still a job to be finished here
with Incredible play so far do you think
it's about ali rza's style of play and
his uh creativity his well his very
often just Fearless I can't think of
another word when it comes to attack
that perhaps gives him these chances
against someone like Fabby and Fabby
does quite well against ala overall he
scored some big wins against him um
including in the grand Swiss back in
2021 and he beat him in the first half
of the candidates in 2022 but ala is
combative and we heard fabbi say that he
was like he brings a fight every single
game Fabby considers himself in the same
vein and the fight is just being brought
to White because White's pieces are all
sorts of defensive here the queen on F1
stopping a checkm on G2 but now how do
you actually win this game for black
because even if you take on C5 white
will bring that Rook into the game and
he starts with H4 and the engine creeped
up a little bit for white but still
heavily in Black's favor yeah how much
do you think a role the clock will play
here um will that help white defend or
will that help fua in his attacking uh
Ambitions here you're up a piece for
white that's the good news but you might
just lose in a couple moves because the
queen moves Pawn to H3 it's looking very
dangerous I think that's going to help
fer more easier to attack than defend
right with the clock ticking and 30
seconds Fabiano he's living life on the
edge both on board and clock it looks
desperate you have to try and bring the
white Rook across to defend but simple
two move uh two move concept move the
black queen push the hn as you say I
think what white is counting on is that
when you move the Queen the white king
steps up on H2 or probably H2 where you
just sidestep the pin stopping the idea
of H3 so that is a defensive resource
still possible for Fabby uh taking
advantage of that Queen leaving control
of the H file and ala pauses oh goes on
the other side of the board A5 what a
move what a classy classy move there
he's simply breaking that black Bishop
out of jail he's going to add in a
attacking piece and that will overwhelm
White's defenses as soon as the black
Bishop's out look at that white king
it's going to be stared down just full
board awareness there fantastic and now
I think there are tactics in Black's
favor because he dragged that Bishop up
to C3 Queen F3 goes Queen G4 but the
point is that Rook on C1 is loose in
many lines I thought Queen F3 was the
way to go but it's clear that Queen G4
is also very strong y King has to move
out of the pin on the G file and okay
what's he going to do he's pushing
kicking that white knight away at the
very minimum there will be a Perpetual
check here for black you can give a
bunch of checks with the black queen
white king how is it going to survive
simply still no Checkmate White's Knight
is holding the key G2 Square you need
that black Bishop to join the attack
somehow how do you get through how do
you break through here land a killer
punch wow and you've got to do all of
that under 10 with under 10 seconds on
the clock and he gives a check and I
don't believe that he's going to repeat
in this position he he goes for it yeah
he takes that pawn C5 David ask how how
do you break that Bishop into the action
you take the pawn in its path and if
white tries to keep the position closed
you push the pawn forward you need to
get rid of this night on E3 and uh here
we go FHA gives another couple of checks
now he gets his Bishop out and that
white knight is going to disappear it's
threatened right now if black plays
Bishop takes KN it is game over white
collapses Fabby playing that move with
just two seconds on the clock and it's
handshakes as he resigns Ali Riza fuja
with the black pieces a flawlessly
executed attack takes the lead in their
match one what a performance what a game
what a dominant display from fuja from
start to finish he brought it to fabbi
he was not going to get a closed
position and get pressed he's just
destroyed Fabiano in that game game of
the tournament so far early days but uh
this just fantastic fantastic stuff and
uh here we see Nakamura Deep In Action
Now against vasher lra this one we
joined a lot earlier this is now uh kind
of middle game end game phase but Maxim
Vash grive on the back foot he's
defending retreating The Black Queen
both sides under the one minute Mark
what is happening
here lot of indecision there Panic there
by Hikaru as he wasn't sure which piece
to move they're playing on seconds
Hikaru with 7 seconds on the clock Maxim
7 seconds on the clock you want to get
that Knight into F5 but is there enough
time The Rook was hanging and look at
Maxim he's trying to trade off that rook
and the Rooks are gone and oh no the
queen got stuck again on C8 the engine
went crazy but that Queen did recapture
isn't black just up a couple pawns here
black is two pawns up you're right
Robert and that should normally be
decisive but Queen and Knight often do
so well against Queen and Bishop and uh
the White Queen the White Knight do have
squares Black's King not too safe in the
corner uh so anything could happen but
wow Nakamura picking up the queen
putting it back panicking the clock is
ticking I've never seen him this nervous
before yeah maybe it's the birthday
Jitters I mean he is not having a good
time today Wesley so took him down and
right now against Maxim VRA he's on the
back foot and he's barely getting his
moves off he's still a few pawns down as
well he's giving some checks with the
white knight Landing his Queen now but
the black king is running Maxim should
be winning this game he should be taking
it wow okay he needs to go for checkmate
look at the shake of the head there
Nakamura he is not happy at all
oh he's never seen Hikaru like this and
the King just runs the king just runs
and it's all extra pawns it's all Maxim
V one's been picked up but it is that B
Pawn that's going to be decisive and
what has happened there he's just
dropped his Bishop Maxim vasra suddenly
and it's game on again a big blunder on
the board um ignore the the life board
there in the corner it's chaos on the
physical OTB board here right now
suddenly it's a three result game white
has an extra Knight black has bunch of
Pawns running but Nakamura just as he
was shaking his head Vash lra blundered
and uh wow twist and turns predict now
and maybe with the inerted board
incorrect we can zoom in on the actual
board to see what's happening because
parent that Maxim made a mistake giving
Hikaru a new chance and Hikaru he needs
to make the most of it because he's off
to a bad start he's been struggling but
when your opponent blunders you need to
capitalize and he has a chance to repeat
the Moose Hikaru look at the body
language is he going to bail out with a
draw he can keep checking the black king
it handshake a peace agreement in what
was one of the most chaotic games of the
event absolute drama the Champions chest
of finals as this one ends in a draw
Maxim VRA was winning then blunders the
piece and eventually ends with a
repetition and we see him and Wesley so
as they watch the action on Magnus
Carlson taking on nbec Abdus satro moves
are coming in quick what is our update
on this one wow this one the moves are
coming along quickly but Magnus he has
an advantage in Practical terms is it
enough to turn it into a full point it
looks like nbec is trying to hold a
fortress white has a king Knight and
pawns black has a king bishop and pawns
and level material is there a
breakthrough two end game experts and uh
let's try and get that board up there we
see it it's going to be hard to break
through Black's defenses here should be
a draw with best play yeah the Knight is
clearly better than the bishop because
the bishop has to just move back and
forth can't attack a single piece with
all of White's pieces on light squares
but the Knight can't get in if that
Knight could get to E6 could jump via C5
and E6 then we' be talking about a win
for white but black is just defending
everything there is no path forward
Black's Bishop just needs to remain on
this diagonal to control all those
squares of the Knight to come into that
E6 square that you pointed out Magnus
might get in a trick with the Knight
coming to 86 instead it's never going to
be captured yeah and you can tell
magnus's body language suddenly he
relaxed a bit he doesn't look too
excited anymore he did set a small trap
there he was threatening to take a pawn
with the white knight White's G6 Pawn
promoting is the only winning idea but
ultimately uh black holding everything
together and Black's King actually
snaking around now uh should still be a
draw neither side able to make
progress if anyone can push this end
game it has to be white with that pawn
structure and the night playing it might
be a repetition at this point with the
night jumping into G4 but Magnus Carlson
wants more he continues to try and has
NRA after that first round loss got a
sweatshirt change going on in this one I
didn't even notice but you know some
players are very superstitious and so
with the writing on the wall he brings
his Bishop back to E7 he's going to go
back and forth he's in no issue no
problem for black whatsoever there's
only one thing the white can do try to
attack the pawns and black just defends
every single one so Magnus is heading to
the H5 Square to Target the G7 pawn and
threaten the sacrifice on F6 uh but once
it does get to H5 black just shuffles
with the King yeah and uh even the worst
Bishop can be a good Defender and there
we see it is a
draw fantastic hold there confident hold
there by another back Abdu satro with a
draw with the black pieces he will be
going ahead against Magnus Carlson with
white in round two he should be very
pleased with this game you're always
pleased when you draw against Magnus
Carlson with the black pieces and I
think Magnus is going to be a bit
disappointed we know their history
between these two I know deck has scored
a big win against Magnus in the past but
game two it's a two game match I think
Magnus will just have to calm himself
and if he holds steady then we'll go to
Armageddon well there is one more game
to be played in all the matches before
potential Armageddon uh to come up and
of course the action does uh continue in
this one David what were the big
highlights I think it was that chaotic
fight between hikara Nakamura and Maxim
Vash gra I just want to show a action
replay of how that finished how Maxim
let the win slip from his grasp here
Maxim Vash gra as black should be
winning Simple Plan would be to push the
B Pawn forward to promotion once it
reaches B1 of course that would be game
over simple and strong instead Hikaru
was allowed back into the game by a
careless slip Maxim sought a Pawn on F2
and he took a pawn but Loose pieces drop
off as we mentioned and this walked into
a simple double attack Queen to F5 was a
check hitting the king hitting the
bishop and a couple of moves later after
another check winning a pawn uh Hikaru
was able to take the bishop and in the
end the game fizzled out to a draw
Hikaru maybe could have pushed it on a
bit more but I think relief was the name
of the game for him and in the end a
fair result after a Topsy Turvy
encounter absolutely and the match
remains level in that one as it does
against uh with nbec and Magnus Carlson
meanwhile wesle so and fua take the win
in their matches Fabiano Carana and
Dennis lazovic has have to win on demand
to take it to Armageddon and what a game
it was by alira fuja against Fabby in
round one just the Flawless attack
sacrificing the Knight sacrificing The
Rook let's hear it from the winner of
round one ska is with
ala here with man of the moment Ali Resa
Rua with the black pieces winning
against Fabiano how' you feel right now
yeah it's it was a very tense game um I
think he blond he didn't play very
precisely in the opening and this
sacrifice is very typical so it's very
difficult to play this in Rapid game
yeah with white take us through that
beautiful Knight F4 sacrifice that you
did play yeah um it's very typical I
lost many games myself like this so it's
it's a very typical one but it's a bit
unexpected so um I think he's still okay
but he has to play very precisely so
you're on fire have we underestimated
how well you will play here yeah I mean
if I play my best I think I have chances
always so um lately the results are not
so good in other tournaments but now I'm
trying to be back in shape so looks like
you are one more game against Fabiano
you will have the white pieces what kind
of strategy will you have there yeah of
course he has to play very sharp lines
um I will play solid and I just need
draw so I'll try my best but um still
Anything Could Happen awesome to follow
your games thank you so much Al R and
good luck back to you guys wow thanks
Kaa and alza well the job isn't finished
yet he's expecting a sharp line sharp
play by Fabiano caruana but sharpness is
where Ali Resa also thrives Robert it's
also the kind of positions that he
enjoys playing yeah there's something a
little bit uncomfortable when you only
need a draw sometimes you play it too
safe even when the position calls for
some tactics but ala he thrives in the
Tactical territory he just proved that
in game one so I don't think he should
be worried getting the white pieces
against Fabiano here in game two yeah
for me it's just nice how honest the
players are how relaxed they are he's
basically giving away his match strategy
he's saying I'm going to play solid
therefore Fabiano should be able to
guess which openings he's going for
maybe Berlin but uh yeah these players
uh bringing their best and I mean we're
off to a fiery start this whole day full
of excitement so many decisive games and
that was the highlight so far yeah I
thought that was just a brilliant game
with the black pieces against uh Fabby
to finish it off like that and it's not
about making the objectively best move
right you just place something which
forces your opponent to think and often
go wrong giving the opportunity to your
opponent to go wrong how important is
that in these time format it's essential
and uh that's why certain players excel
at Blitz rapid chess even bullet chess
you got to set the traps you've got to
set the Practical problems and often the
opponent won't react in the best way you
have to be ready for that you have to be
sharp anded when it came to calculation
fua was able to back it all up so uh
yeah definitely a key skill in Rapid and
Ali RZA said that in that interview with
K he was like well it might be
objectively okay but it's not a good
position to play from the white side
when you have no time on the clock and
he showed why it was not easy to play
for white he won the game but Al is in
just phenomenal shape right now yeah
even kowana top of his game fantastic
year was unable to defend that Whirlwind
of an attack That's How Strong it was
how practical it was just amazing play
we are seeing on day one fighting
fighting ambitious chess all around and
there is uh another big game coming up
as some players are playing catchup uh
chess.com is partnering with displayed
beautiful collection of Chess posters
printed on shic and durable metal nine
gorgeous display designs from our CCD
collections mittens is back and you can
bring her into your home with a poster
explore designs from chessable chest kit
and more use the command displayed in
chat or head over to display.com chest
to shop now using the code Chess at
checkout to claim a discounted price
don't go anywhere as we will be back
back with game
two ah what a beautiful
day what in the
world chuggers is attacking they're
[Music]
everywhere we have to
fight take that
Checkers hey what are you doing those
are my
discs do you work for Checkers no I work
for disc craft why are you attacking me
I'm not I'm here at a disc golf course
throwing
discs those aren't Checkers no these are
prototypes of new discs for Paul McBeth
and you're in my way and you ruined a
bunch of
them who's Paul McBeth oh my gosh PA
man first of all I'm a huge fan second
of all I am so so sorry the green pond
can get a little out of control
sometimes and um but you know honestly
in his defense there's a very long
history between chess and checkers that
I I could tell you about if you if
you've got a few a few hours Danny I
really don't have the time right
now okay no yep I get it I feel you on
that um can we can we replace the
discs right now with the holiday season
and the disc this costing thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of dollars I
don't think there's much you can do okay
um there's got to be something man
anything actually I think there is
something chess.com is a proud sponsor
of the inaugural chess.com Invitational
presented by Discraft join Paul McBeth
and chess.com Danny and Eric from
February 23rd to the 25th in Brooksville
Florida
this is the disc golf tournament you
don't want to
miss so disc golf huh yeah it's like you
take a disc and you're just
like that's basically what you do can I
try I mean
sure yeah it's like that but you're like
trying to throw to like that basket
hundreds of feet away it's not like that
I
mean I mean I mean not really you kind
of want to like you want to like behind
you you want to like explode through
it's
like okay kind of like
that yeah
okay oh my gosh did they all go in like
that that was amazing pawns
[Music]
work
anyone who has played even a small
amount of Chess especially online is
familiar with the concept of an opening
trap we've all fallen for one at some
point or another in many cases a failed
opening trap will leave you with a
terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number two legal mate this opening trap
if if your opponent cooperates can lead
to one of the most beautiful and famous
checkmates in chess named after s deal
it dates back all the way to the 18th
century it occurs in an Italian game and
in this position we play Knight C3 black
might play Bishop G4 pinning the Knight
to White's Queen and we can play H3
forcing black to make a decision about
the light squared Bishop if they retreat
with Bishop H5 this allows the brilliant
Knight takes E5 where a free Queen is
offered if black takes the bait and
grabs the queen can you spot the famous
mate in
two that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the
[Music]
opening have a friend or family member
who loves chess give them a chess.com
membership today and see them take their
game to the next level you can choose a
gold platinum or Diamond membership for
1 month or one year want your gift to
arrive on your friend's birthday or on a
holiday gifts can be scheduled to arrive
up to 90 days in the future all premium
plans include an adree experience
unlimited puzzles and lessons and unlock
all Bots go platinum to add unlimited
game review or Diamond to unlock
insights and Coach explanations give the
gift of Chess
[Music]
today
don't miss out on Twitch drops during
the CCT finals watch four cumulative
hours of Chess on chess 24 or chess
channels and unlock free 14 days of
diamond membership on chess.com connect
your account at go. chess.com connect to
redeem and enjoy 2 weeks of Premium
features and for now you don't want to
miss out on game two that is about to
come out off round two on our day one
and we've got Dennis lazic right now
with the white pieces and we have got
lift off in the other games as Dennis
waits for his opponent to arrive where
is Wesley that's uh the big question
right now Wesley so won the first game
but yet to arrive in the playing H there
we see him jump up onto the stage but uh
we're beginning with whoa Max the graph
against Hikaru Nakamura and Hikaru plays
a line of the Petro is it the Damiano
variation where
black basically blund as a porn but
there are tricks involved yeah this is
an opening that used to be considered
terrible but suddenly has found a little
bit of a Renaissance you know it's
regained some popularity and I think the
reason why is it's quite forcing so uh
if you are going to suffer in some
positions you might want to force the
issue so you're like oh I'm slightly
worse but I know what's going on other
times you struggle to even find an idea
so it seems like Hikaru all that playing
on the internet all those tiered lists
of openings he's found one that he likes
in a position that he just wants to hold
against Maxim and shout out to camel
pcker who did a chess bow course I
believe on this exact variation of the
Petro defense and uh yeah white is for
now a knight ahead a knight up but that
Knight is pinned in the center on E5 it
will drop and Maxi Vash grav clearly
hasn't looked into too much detail in
this one uh and he is the first to pause
this is one that I was told I was 5
years old you know it's terrible for
black don't even need to look at it
don't need to analyze it and I haven't
looked at it since so I'm in the same
boat as Maxim Hikaru though has done his
homework and he's got more time than
what he started with the blitzing it out
and that last move by Maxim he does pick
the pawn in return for giving up the
Knight that's an extra Pawn out of the
opening where is Black's compensation in
these openings there will be quick
development so when you're up a pawn and
in this case it's going to be a pawn E5
when the Black Knight gets out it
already attacks the pawn so black has a
very clear plan I'm going to start going
after your extra Pawn I'm going to
develop and white has to spend some time
protecting that pawn sometimes in
awkward ways so I look at this position
I would not want to play it myself from
the black side but I can tell you hikaro
he studied this line he knows that he
can get into a pos position where he
feels like a draw is the likest outcome
yeah and uh if that white Pawn on E5
does disappear it's basically
symmetrical a draw would be extremely uh
likely to occur and uh right now Maxim
needs to decide what to do to defend
that pawn either with White's F Pawn
White's Dart squared Bishop can come out
to F4 as well or to just let it fall Let
It Drop and uh try to prioritize quick
development as well uh White's Knight
can come out White's Bishops both can uh
spring forward either way as the
evaluation Bar says it's within the
Realms of equality but white is the one
who has to choose the uh path the route
that this game will take I would be S
tempted as white to actually defend that
E5 pawn and I see Maxim has gone for the
other way that he just trades it off to
me Knight C3 looks like a draw
offer until you see this move
potentially threatening the C7 square
but black gives a check and okay a trade
of Bishops now and Maxi Vash gr he's
banking on the fact that White's King
will be fine in the center now that the
Queens are off the board White's King
has the C3 Square to hide for example
Black's King also forced to uh put
itself on a bit of an odd square and
suddenly Maxim's blitzing again yeah
Maxim is just making every single move
in an instant and his last few moves
have made sense he attacked the C Pawn
he traded off Bishops when he was in
check he now kicks that Knight out of
the center and the Knight goes to G4 so
this is a bit of a committal strategy
from Maxine when you push pawns forward
you leave some squares behind but at
this moment that King on d8 is that a
good piece defending the loose Pawn C7
or can it be victim to an attack along
the defile yeah white needs to get those
Rooks centralized white needs to connect
Rooks black needs to connect Rooks it's
very symmetrical very drawish but white
has the first move here white can
potentially create some threats Maxim's
go going for his Bishop attacking a pawn
small margins here I think draw most
likely but Maxim still the one asking
the questions wow so even though the
game looks pretty level there is still
fight on in this one we will check in
with this uh let's head over to Ali RZA
fuja who with a spectacular win in game
one against Fab uh took the lead in his
match Fabby has to win on demand to take
it to Armageddon Fabby playing with the
black pieces how where will he create
his chances uh and we've got some
interesting opening approach here by
Fabby he's playing provocatively we see
what the engine says it's very obviously
better for white in this opening looks
like one of my online Blitz Games but
the point is he's just trying to muddy
the water so they both know white is
better here but how do you actually
improve your position you're going to
Castle King side that Rook on h8 now has
a newly open Line staring in that
direction are you going to push a pawn
in the center or does that actually
allow black to to maybe close down the
center and attack on one of the flanks
so these questions are not always easy
to answer even if both players recognize
that white is ahead Yeah you mentioned
the word provocative Robert that's often
just breaking the rules giving the
opponent the center giving the opponent
easy development here giving the
opponent the bishop pair as well often
what we're taught not to do in the
opening but you are giving the opponent
an unfamiliar situation and fua he's got
so much Choice that's why he's been
burning time on the clock he's already 3
minutes down and uh this one definitely
won't feels out to an easy draw so step
one achieved you've got a game you've
got a position and already we see the
evaluation bus slide down fuja now
clearly playing with a draw in mind he
wants these Central pawns to be traded
off now he wants the Queens on the
defile potentially to disappear as well
and uh I don't like this decision it
looks like white could have just
developed very naturally uh but instead
suddenly things are getting a bit more
concrete and Fabby I think that will uh
make him a bit happy here ala fuja
playing the matx situation more than the
board with that last move E5 trying to
get some trades in he needs only a draw
for the match Victory and if Fabiano
tries to avoid the trade on E5 and moves
the Knight White's own Knight will jump
on to E4 the Central Square putting more
pressure on D6 forcing Fabby into the
trades uh which is what Ali rzza wants
right now in his interview to Kaaya he
said that he's expecting Fabby to go
into some sharp lines but looking at the
position the bishop bear the opening up
off the center to me it looks like the
only player who can play sharp here is
white well he played with some ambigu
right there was no direct counter from
Fabby he just moved his pieces about and
now I think that I knew he wasn't going
to trade Queens but I was going to say
even if he had traded Queens I still
think there was life left in the
position and the reason why is because
this E5 Pawn if he instead of captured
and traded Queens on D1 this E5 Pawn at
some point will be needed to be defended
and if you push that pawn up to F4 then
you going to play G5 is black and just
try to collapse that structure in the
center it's not I'm not saying that
black is better but at least it gives
him an opportunity to have an
asymmetrical Pawn structure the game
itself I think looks like a Scandinavian
and it's one of these positions where
black is super duper solid and white has
a bishop pair and more space yeah I do
like this bishop on G2 I must admit uh
long term if the center ever opens up if
you can somehow uh kind of leave it
forward with this Pawn to D5 and blow
open the center White's Bishops will
Thrive but for now it's imbalanced
enough and it's still not clear where
White's King goes will it feel entirely
safe on the king side on G one with
Black's Rooks on this semiopen file as
Robert pointed out earlier um still some
questions to be answered fuja now he's
hesitating from taking this porn I'm
wondering whether he first brings his
Knight back to F6 uh at least uh this
Pawn isn't running away on D6 anytime
soon yeah it's going to be a very kg
position but still life left and uh
Fabiano I think he'll be feeling
positive about these developments
despite the fact that objectively white
might still hold an advantage uh still
the pawn structure not symmetrical and
uh chances later
on position is heating up and the clocks
are leveling out right now a big
decision for Fabby does he take the pawn
immediately or does he moved the Knight
away to continue with development I
think either ways white wants to get the
pieces on the center he comes back with
the Knight to F6 at least controlling
the E4 Square yeah the pawn on D6 isn't
going anywhere he knows he can pick it
up on the next turn and he is taking
away that Knight E4 jump from White so I
think Fabby is playing this well I also
like the fact that he's doing well on
the clock he's got 12 minutes and all
rais in the other hand he's down under
11 the position is favorable for white
none of us are going to dispute that
fact but I just think that in terms of
getting chances from the black side this
is a pretty ideal type of position near
early going should we guess where the
kings are going which way is white is
white going to slide to the right slide
to the left uh who's going to Castle
King side Queen side and we already have
a result coming in Maxim VRA Hikaru
Nakamura just ended in a draw that's one
Armageddon confirmed wow so that opening
we saw we actually saw the the majority
of the game in the end uh Nakamura just
played two or three accurate moves and
draw agreed they're waiting now to
submit their Armageddon bids right off
the game the players are required uh to
give in in writing their bids for the
clock for the time how much time are
they willing to bargain for the black
pieces and right now Hikaru and Maxim we
saw them on their seats are they
thinking about their bid are they
thinking about whether they want black
or what do you think what is going to be
the strategy in that one I don't know I
think Karu wants black that has been his
uh kind of consistent uh preference
throughout this season of the Champions
chest or at least online and his draw
there with black was effortless but uh
you never know you never know Maxim I
think is more dangerous with white so
that might cause some hesitation and you
should be a goldfish and you know forget
those mistakes when he had the white
pieces against Maxim he was in trouble
throughout that game before Maxim
blundered away the advantage and then
the game ended in a draw so I think for
hikaro he's willing to bid a low amount
of time he wants that draw
we will find ad and with the way the
quickness with which a draw was reached
in that game too it's clear that both
wanted to take it to the Armageddon
which means more fun for us and Magnus
Carlson there having a little bit of a
peak on what just happened but then back
to his board as it is his move against
nybeck we will do a deep dive on this
one I do see has White's Rook jumped
into Black's Camp White's Rook is on A6
just near the clock over there on the
queen side on the far side of the board
um it is has been a very classical
opening both sides uh kind of playing
very logical moves in this Spanish uh
the Roy Lopez opening and M Magnus here
showing a mark of respect to his young
opponent by playing pretty much His
World Championship repertoire uh Magnus
gson he's played this before in
high-profile games when he wants to lock
things down when he just wants to
survive and uh be solid here we see
Bishops leaving the board who would you
guys prefer here I would say white maybe
because of the pown center but black has
has some trumps as well I'm picking
Armageddon in this one I think
Armageddon is the likely result here the
position remains closed for now there
are no weaknesses to Target for either
side and I like what you said there
David that it does feel like Magnus has
the utmost respect for no de Becca buar
how could he not the kid has beaten him
before can I still call him a kid he's
like 19 years old and feels like they
stay teenagers forever but nck I mean
he's growing before our eyes he's played
so many online events he's taken his
talents in person winning the world
rapid a few years ago go so he can beat
Magnus Carlson he's done it before and
in this position I don't think that's
likely just by the nature of it it's not
too much tension I think this should be
a draw and I don't think Magnus is too
worried yeah I love this old photo of
NOC when he was 9 10 years old with
Magnus he was a fan initially then he
rose through the ranks and has beaten
Magnus maybe in the two most high
high-profile high stake encounters
between these two uh at the world rapid
championship in 21 and in Vian and uh
both of those were Queen end games this
one's a middle game I don't see anything
too wrong too weak with magnus's
position no real Targets in the black
camp but uh it looks like like at least
nobec he's going to be happy with how
this match has gone relatively painless
draw with black in the first one and
here with white if he can somehow apply
pressure um he'll start to get
confident um yeah still roughly balanced
though for now balance B when you're
playing against Magnus it's not over
till it's over Magnus will make uh not
back up to satro Tred to earn that draw
in this position uh speaking of their
previous encounter I think another
moment that was there at the Tata steel
Wan where nck had this fantastic run he
actually beat Magnus in that tournament
but at the end it was Anish who won it
after nck lost the last round and magas
was one of the first to go on and sort
of not a back finish second but just
tell him that you know what it's uh it's
fine and I remember that moment so these
two have so much respect he also
congratulated him after that phenomenal
performance overall uh but right now
they're over the board and it's that
story of when your Idols become your
Rivals for NC yeah you can't idolize
them too much you can't to show too much
respect but uh here clearly both players
just a bit Cy um it's all about mind
game it's all about psychology because
on the board they've been playing
perfect chess up to this point and
another player who has been playing
perfect chess today is Wes liso and he
is up against the youngest player of the
Champions chestar final Dennis lavic if
you're a fan of the Underdog Story then
Dennis lazic is the one to watch out for
what a platform this is he started a day
with a loss against Magnus but Magnus
was very appreciative of his play and
said that he did put up a big fight and
now it is against Wesley what do we make
of his chances in this one well he lost
the first game to Wesley and Wesley's
been in some of the best form of the
tournament he beat Hikaru in The Opening
match and I look at this position and I
say let me do a quick count math may not
be uh my profession but I do think that
black is up a pawn here and in
compensation for that pawn white has a
lot of pressure down the C file that
Knight on C4 is ready to move at any
moment the bishop is loose the Knight
behind it the queen behind all of those
minor pieces so I do think that white
does have compensation and Wesley needs
to be careful here because things can
start getting a little tricky I feel
sorry for Dennis he's been thrown in at
the deep end facing Magnus in the first
uh in the first match of the day he was
so close there so close but not close
enough in the end uh to holding that
draw in the end go down to a match
defeat against Wesley in the first game
of this round he was so close again he
did everything perfectly he was close to
achieving the draw and then blundered in
one move and uh both matches he started
with a black now he needs to win with
white and he's taking risks he's given
up a porness he needs to do uh he needs
to create something imbalance it somehow
and uh yeah the more I look at it Robert
the more I think you're right there is
compensation and black does need to be
accurate Black's Bishop on C8 the light
squ Bishop still needs to come out no
obvious moves here and some loose pieces
in the black Camp um this one really in
the balance hanging on a knife hedge
right now if Wesley's accurate he should
be fine of course uh maybe even more
than fine but I don't see a way I don't
see an obvious way yet and Wes's in for
a deep think we see he's been spending
over four minutes on this turn he
recognizes the magnitude of the moment
that he cannot just play a quick Choice
and then find himself defending the rest
of the game and so for Wesley so he's
one of the most accurate players in
chess history he knows when the
situation calls for a deep think
it's a tough moment though because if he
Retreats his Bishop which is in the
Queen's sight then that Knight still
moves out of the Queen's passing Bishop
A7 Knight C4 to E5 and yeah you can play
Bishop D7 to defend that C6 square but
that doesn't look very good because D4
will hang in some of these positions and
there are so many pins and tactics in
the air yeah suddenly look at those
white pieces uh Queen Rook lined up
Knight perfectly poised in the center
Bishops fetto and uh their x-ray vision
exerting extreme pressure and Wesley in
the end does play a move Bishop to D7 uh
roughly balanced and uh yeah for now
let's take a step back and see whether
Dennis can find compensation for that
sacrificed
porn tnis lavic trying to create his
chances uh by sacrificing upon for uh
initiative against a player who's
considered the hardest to beat amongst
the very best in the world Wesley saw
needs only a draw for this one and we
are going to keep our eyes out on this
one Meanwhile we're going to check in
with our crew in Toronto as James is
joining us with an update James what's
the atmosphere like in Toronto right
now the atmosphere in Toronto is AB
absolutely crazy it's fun out here guys
of course there's so much chess right we
have the food everything's good but of
course um right now on the chess board
things are very explosive as we saw fuja
especially in the round one there was
able to take out Fabiano which is really
really strong there of course especially
as he was sacrificing pieces and Etc we
saw mvl as well as he's playing I mean
guys there's so much chess going on so
I'm excited I'm just here in Toronto
watching you guys all the way in Oslo so
it's been very very fun what about you
guys over there oh we're having an
awesome time calling the action as well
and seeing all the updates that you guys
are bringing us uh from the onsite and
what about Dennis lazic we've been
talking so much about him James here
this is such a big opportunity for him
how is he feeling and he starts the day
with Magnus now he's up against Wesley
uh did you manage to catch hold of him
what's going on with his mindset right
now yeah of course in the first round of
when I'm able to draw Magnus in any
format I'm going to feel good so of
course hey he lost the match but he did
actually you know end up drawing Magnus
so that feels good at the end of the day
that's exactly what I would be feeling
like I drew Magnus I just got to keep
playing and keep hoping for the best
obviously Wesley's giving it to him but
at the same time look I got to play this
one thing at a time I am the lowest seed
you know I got to go out here play I've
won title Tuesdays before I've played
these guys before I just got to get out
of my own head and play the 64 squares
absolutely it's uh it's got to be
feeling good if you're able to hold a
Magnus in this one now with such short
turnaround time between these games uh
James between game one and game two of
the round what do the players get up
to you know actually they come out and
they like stretch a little bit you can
see some emotions they grab some snacks
they get some water right you know me
and F did a couple push-ups kidding we
probably do that later but of course at
the same time the guys they just get
right into the right mindset you can
tell everybody around here is very
focused and of course Arbiter is doing
great job of hey got got to get back to
the games fair play check is on point I
mean everybody here is just really
serious right it's a very serious Vibe
here a lot of money on the line a lot of
Pride on the line too as well I mean did
you see first prize Tanya were you
paying attention to the cash money that
is in first place of course there's a
lot of focus here and a lots of emotions
but they don't wear it too much on their
face in fact I saw fuja being very very
calm as you can just tell he's walking
around you know got the swag going got
the I'm I'm Mr Gucci Resa feeling good
you can tell he's in right mindset here
everyone else too as well so nice nice
atmosphere great Vibes all together
James I must admit you're giving me
massive fomo right now it looks like a
great time out there in Toronto uh
what's been the highlight for you so far
I know it's still early days but uh
what's been the moment you've enjoyed
the
most you know what actually the chess
part I love Toronto it's nice out here
and I'm I'm a Toronto in fact they said
take out the other te that's how they
know I'm not from here but at the same
time here it's been very fun I love
everything about Toronto but the chess
part has been the greatest in fact
really seeing that fuja game was
probably the biggest thing for me two
games in fact sacrificing on both games
which is really insane playing great
chess great form here Dark Horse in way
we had some picks of course as we saw
some people wanted to pick fua there but
they're like oh Magnus first hikaro
Wesley and not so much forja of course
so we're starting to see that and
especially if he close out the match I
mean he's really going to be on good
fire in good form great to see the chess
absolutely James well we're here in Oslo
it's definitely torono for us uh as
we're calling the action from here and I
want to ask you before you go there's
been a quick drop between Maxim and
Hikaru we go into an Armageddon between
these two have you seen them what are
they up to right
now yeah with that Armageddon of I
actually saw how uh hikaro looked in the
in the cam we all saw it I'm sure chat
was going crazy he like hikaro looks
bored kind of thing just kind of sitting
around and having a good time right but
the AR Armageddon is not anything but a
good time there I'm not sure who
actually won the Armageddon there I
think it was hearu but if hearo wins the
Armageddon I'm thinking he'll probably
take black there he'll take black and
then hopefully hope for the best here
obviously move very fast that's why he
went to the Armageddon he was very
comfortable going in that second game
through the Petra off and just all right
cool go through the motions do our thing
get to Armageddon real fast because I am
you know speed Champion also mvl being a
speed Champion too as well but I'll get
those two results especially if I draw
or win with black so you know best of
luck to both Thanks James and we will
check in with you in sometimes in
sometime and it's been uh fantastic
having this chat with you meanwhile some
fantastic decisions being taken on the
board Knight takes that Side Pawn it's a
little bit of a tactic based on the B
Pawn advancing next to Fork the bishop
and the Knight what is our evaluation
after this whole tactical sequence black
cannot be worse here so black was up
upon to begin with now is up a full
piece but there's a work so this Pawn on
B4 is hitting both the Knight and the
bishop gaining the material back but if
black just slides the bishop back to
defend the queen a queen trade likely on
tap I think the Dennis somehow needs to
get out of it but there's no way to do
so because if he moves his Queen then
Knight jumps back into uh C6 or C4 and
suddenly black is up material so this is
a position where the Queens are coming
off and I don't think Dennis has any
chance to win yeah just to show that uh
Point Robert if the Queens do disappear
you could probably take in either
direction here with black with the
bishop or The Rook but uh at the very
end we would see a position that is just
totally level for example black can park
Bishop on A4 everything's coming off the
board Rooks will be eliminated it's too
symmetrical too drawish and of course a
draw favors Wesley so in the match he
actually plays a more ambitious move if
we backtrack uh to the current position
E5 instead he's going to try and hang on
to this Pawn even and uh for example if
white takes this bishop then black
actually has a beautiful Square on C6 uh
he'll park a bishop or a knight on this
square and it's the C pawns it looks
like Wesley so has the advantage now he
could play a move such as Bishop to C6
and yeah I really don't think lazic is
uh likely to win this game anymore
simply a blocked out Bishop black has
beautiful Central pawns and Advantage
Wesley Advantage Wesley things looking
good danis lazovic in a big trouble and
it looks like he will not be able to
take this one uh to Armageddon meanwhile
the other player trying to take it to
Armageddon is uh reigning US champion
Fabiano Carana after his first round
loss against Ali RZA fuja some very
committed Decisions by Fabby in the
opening with the black beast is trying
to create those chances that he needs
this is what we have currently on the
board the bishop pair is still alive
meanwhile Fabby trying to create play
against the queenside pawn there is an
attack on uh C4 which has been defended
the F line open the bishop PA still on
I'm still liking White's position white
objectively is better I've never for a
second doubted that but I do still
believe that it's the type of position
where black can get a win white has to
go wrong for that to happen but it's a
messy position no Clarity it's not like
you can just trade into an endgame so
right now Fabby is using the clock as
his 17th piece James we just had him on
the show he loves to say the clock is a
weapon use it as the last piece and I
think that is going to be important as
Al is about to dip down to three minutes
yeah he'll have more than half an eye on
the clock right now Fabiano because
actually Black's position is so solid
it's hard for white to break through
through so it's guaranteed almost at
this point that fua will be burning more
time I do like however this dodge of The
Rook trade uh saying no I'm not
exchanging Rooks because Black's Rook on
F5 does make a bit of an odd impression
it's almost trapped uh White's light
squared Bishop can easily Target it um
that being said still a long game ahead
still plenty of tension and 3 minutes
against 5 minutes you need to use that
you need to hustle the opponent here
Fabby drops back big threat The Black
Queen Bishop lined up now on the
diagonal White's G3 Pawn threaten
and wh's King just reminding fuia here
that he's not entirely safe he needs to
take a precaution now he's about to
touch the White Queen I believe oh no he
drops his Bishop back instead defending
but still you could see how the fear of
ghosts might be put into him here and
retreating bit loose now for white
expecting the Black Knight to retreat
and still game
on White's got a big threat of the cwn
moving forward with the fork so we are
expecting a night move and it does
retreat it might be time for White's
Bishops to start attacking that black
Rook on F5 uh I am I do love the bishop
pair and there we see Bishop lands on e4
uh hitting that Rook on F5 not too many
squares for the Rook you might play
Knight E7 and give the Rook up that way
your knight gets into the position and
start going after the white king I like
Rook A5 better because it doesn't give
white the most obvious of choices in
response the bishop is just chasing The
Rook The Rook can in fact slide back
along the a file and why I still believe
Fabio has some chances to win this game
he's worse according to the evaluation
bar we've said it all game but where is
the clear plan for white it seems like
black is quite solid yeah at some point
fuja might just lose patience and try to
break through in the center push White's
dewn forward uh but you have to time it
well if black can keep things blocked if
black can keep things closed then the
clock will play an even bigger role and
anyone who's played the French defense
the carakan defense knows this position
it's bad you're worse but you're not
dead and uh that's all Fabiano can hope
for right now and Fab impressively
continues to play fast he's uh got a
clear plan of bringing the knight in and
the bishop moves to D2 and I saw a
reaction from you there Rober what
happened just looks strange to me but I
get what he's going for he wants Bishop
F4 but the Rook on D3 Bishop on D2
pieces are now all doing their part and
I am looking for Fabby at some moment to
try to strike with his F Pawn he needs
to rip open the kingside inste he play
Rook d8 first he's keeping the status
quo can hardly fault him for that as Ali
rais it down to 2 minutes and 15 seconds
I like it Fabiano just Bing his time
Black's Rook has done a real journey
here got on a real Adventure round to F5
back to A5 A8 d8 he's just kind of
waiting uh just lurking and all the time
F's clock is dropping down and down and
further down and Knight F5 momentum
black it feels that way I would prefer
to have Black's position I mean now you
see the G3 Pawn is threatened D4 is
under attack if you take this Knight on
F5 no longer does white have the bishop
pair and that D4 Pawn will be loose and
I think that that pawn that would
replace the Knight on F5 is looking very
strong will that just happen yeah this
is all happening and Black's Rook
suddenly has a beautiful open file to
look at I I'm looking at this white king
and I'm thinking fuja might be in
trouble long term no matter what happens
no matter what disappears off the board
this king is not safe anymore while
Queens remain this is clearly nice for
black because the King on G8 Ultra safe
the King on G2 a bit exposed and the D4
Pawn is loose which is why the Rook came
to D1 but now Rook E8 Rook E4 I can see
black progressing here making very
natural improving moves I would be very
concerned if I'm all especially with the
clock down under minute 45 he doesn't
allow the move Rook to E4 and
challenging on the E file he wants to
try and trade off as many of those heavy
pieces as possible it is a lot about
King safety Fabby is going to try and
grind this out but I do like this move
Rook to E3 uh to try and trade off the
pressure on the E file it's a good idea
you don't want that Rook landing on e4
but you can see how this game the
trajectory of it is going in Fab's
Direction now he plays Queen D7 a very
natural slight Queen adjustment to
protect the Rook you're thre to trade
bring your next rook d8 and take over
the board's only fully open file look at
oi raz's clock as well down under a
minute 30 I think Fabiano's executed
this game to
Perfection wow and we are getting an
update that there has been a result on
the Wesley so lavic uh game in that one
and it looks like Wesley has wrapped up
his match
yeah Wesley for the second match in a
row uh both matches today he's agreed a
draw in a favorable position Wesley had
a big advantage against lavic there
lavic offering a draw accepting he loses
the match but gets another half point
and it's fed rated this rapid tournament
uh lavic gaining there but uh Wesley
he's going to be the happiest player of
this round so far and in the meantime
fuja does lose patience he does play D5
and there we see Wesley the Victor
watching the match with interest as
things heat
up big moves happening on the board in
this one and it looks like Fabby is
really going for it and you mention it
the turnaround it's been moved by mov by
from uh Fabiano and f4 on the board uh
eyeing that G4 square if white does get
greedy with the F4 Pawn you can't take
it Rook takes Rook Queen takes Rook
Queen lands in with a massive check we
get too focused on the evaluation bar
often when we watch chess games but the
way this game has been going from the
start has been in FAO Direction in my
opinion and you see look at his Queen
going F5 say take my Pawn on F4 go for
that extra Pawn there's going to be some
checks on C2 this looks very scary for
white and Al Ra's clock there's less
than a minute there yeah you can tell
it's hustle mode from Fabiano he senses
weakness he's just blitzing still three
and a half minutes he's playing
complicated moves quickly and often
that's better than playing the best move
slowly and uh right now fua down 30
seconds he needs to guard the second
rank whes King is really vulnerable to
checks right now he uses his Rook to
block the black Queen's entry into the
white position Into the Heart of White's
camp but it feels shaky this is really
hanging by a threat for white right now
but what's really helping all the r is
that P Pawn on D5 because what black
ideally wants to do is bring the Rook to
join the queen in the attack but as soon
as your Rook leaves that last rank that
pawn goes up one square and will try to
continue pressing forward so Ali Raza
he's holding on by a thread but that dwn
is maybe the Saving Grace he should
still be saving it object ly he hasn't
done too much wrong um yes momentum has
been turning in Black's favor but still
breaking through against this white king
as pieces disappear not easy and Fabiano
now hits one of White's pawns White's B2
Pawn on the queen side now vulnerable uh
but maybe not the most important uh
factor in this position but look at the
clock now down to about 20 seconds is
fuja and he moves his Rook back so the
eval bar has stayed towards the center
he's making the correct moves but we'll
see if Fabby can trick him here really
impressive how Fabby keeps up the
pressure on the position and on the
clock as well the objective evaluation
doesn't matter at all he does capture
the G3 Pawn does white have time to take
it back because then there are a few
checks coming in yeah wh's King is weak
maybe you use this black pawn as a
double agent you use it as a shield for
Whit's King and he's banking everything
on that uh on that Ace card this D6 Pawn
he's pushing forward for Glory now and
at the very least it will deflect backs
pieces and what Fabiano may want to rely
on is at some moment a queen trade could
be good for him because that pawn is
extending quite far you can maybe Chase
it down but that doesn't look like it's
the case the queen on F3 perfectly
located the King on G2 is actually safe
that umbrella Pawn is shielding it from
any sort of checks so I think that Ali
Rea he's doing everything correct here
and I don't actually see what Fabby does
from here excellent defense there by Ala
playing on seconds and Fabby comes in
with that Queen he has to win so he has
to create his chances attacking The Rook
the queen now steps back a check can be
given on e4 but white will simply go
forward with his King capturing the G3
Pawn Yeah the white Kings out in the
open now but black cannot land a check
with his Rook Black's Rook unfortunately
uh it wants to be the piece delivering
the killer blow but it can't kind of
bypass its own Queen and Black's Rook
will be forced passive within one move
if white just gets the time to push the
D Pawn One More square and I think he
just doesn't have time he cannot
coordinate his pieces perfectly for the
attack just the perfect time for Ali
Raza because if that Rook could jump
over the queen as you're saying rookie
three check would be devastating for the
white king so it looks like ala he may
be down to 15 seconds but he's one of
the best Blitz players in the world he's
doing well incredible nerves there ala
to just go forward with that King in a
heavy piece uh major piece position here
Queen E3 check Queen E5 check so many
checks on the board but it just feels
like he has this understanding that as
long as that Rook remains behind the
Queen the king is safe the most that
black can do is Repeat with checks yeah
don't try this at home don't put the
white king out in the open on G3 when
you're facing heavy pieces queens and
Rooks but uh this this is one of the
exceptions forua due to the White Pass
de Pawn due to how far Advanced it is
he's holding things together with active
defense I think there's some tricky
moves that Fab can go for if he slides
his Queen along the fourth rank maybe he
is threatening Rook E3 checks so if he
just goes I don't know Queen C4 or queen
B4 one of those type of moves you're
attacking some pawns on the queen side
and threatening that Rook check which
could land a check meing attack against
the vulnerable white king yeah it's far
from over it's definitely not settled
yet forua not entirely safe but he's
been doing so well this far and uh yeah
I think one of those moves Robert he
needs to try something Queen back to F5
Queen somewhere get that black Rook into
the game and I I think it's clear that
Fabby realizes that there isn't anything
concrete in the position but he's
looking for the most dangerous option
the most difficult to counter which
might provoke a a mistake by Ali Resa
but look at the speed with which Ali
Resa uh reacted to that queen move
offering a trade and in this position a
rook Pawn ending is fine for white yeah
certainly will be and Fabiano he's
desperate to make this the third
Armageddon match of the round because
Magnus and abusar Drew their match and
look go queen5 he wants queen G1 check
and Al yeah check me that's not scary
but now this D7 Pawn hasn't gone too far
at some point Queen C7 check followed by
Rook takes D7 will be in the air and he
defends it he centralizes the queen if
the Queen's are traded off does black
have time to come in with the King to
the center Fabby says not trading that
off going for the king but it's only
checks because the Rook is tied down to
d8 yeah it's just like having an empty
board a queen alone cannot deliver
Checkmate a queen needs uh some backup
some assistance and he's doing
everything perfectly for he's bullying
Fabiano here with the prospect of the
Queens coming off the board and Black's
Rook just cannot play a part it's hard
to envisage any way of breaking through
here but he's trying he's trying and now
the clocks are the main factor in this
position and what just happened there
was a check on H1 and fuja he's down
under 10 seconds so this game it's still
has plenty of life left in it but Alli
raises Pawn on D7 it's just too powerful
it's restricting the black rook and
fabby's pawns may be pressing forward
over there on the queen side but to what
end yeah to what end and uh right now
okay Fabby he's going for those Queens
side pawns he's trying to destabilize
white somewhat Queen to D4 uh the life
board has frozen so let's focus on uh
the board in front of the players right
now but still everything under control
everything protected from fua and
Fabiano desperately trying to create
threats Pawn drops and oh he tricked him
it's check and Rook takes D7 now because
the Rook takes the Rook the queen was
hanging there has to be a meeing attack
against the white king suddenly White's
deep on the pride and joy of his
position has disappeared this has to be
mate as you say no shelter White's King
is hiding in plain sight here out in the
open in the center of the board Rook E7
check cuz if the queen takes it there
was Queen E1 instead he goes Queen G1
check but there simply must be a maing
attack against that King where is it
going to hide yeah Robert I think you
spotted a win uh an immediate win for
Fabiano but he's still doing the
business here Black's King Super safe
white just has to try and blockade not
allow Black's Rook to give a check any
check is fatal Queen F1 where's that
King going Queen C1 check forcing the
king back and then oh he goes here
instead and there's going King C2
because the queen is hanging on B4 then
oh he has to go forward Foria but look
at that white king out in the open oh he
steals the pawn with check that's one
pawn another Pawn will soon drop every
move is a check giving white no time to
breathe amazing defense by Ala until it
wasn't till that very last moment and
just collapsing under pressure and now
he's got a play move but he's almost
giving up yeah he he is really upset
with himself right now and I think that
Fab just got to give a few checks here
he can also at some point even think
about trading Rooks and taking the G5
Pawn because he have so many extra pawns
but Fab he wants to deliver a Checkmate
there we go it's more checks but Fabiana
doesn't have too much time either and
still failing to find the knockout punch
where is it White's King dancing back
and forth black has all the queen checks
in the world you got to be careful not
to repeat the position either that's a
nice try forcing the white king forward
to defend the white Rook black just
needs to coordinate use the black Rook
too he's to give a check Queen D2 that's
a big check where is that King going he
might have to go up but then he can play
Rook C7 to coordinate his oh there Rook
H4 check yeah suddenly The Disappearance
of White's H Pawn opens up a line
against the black king so black has to
keep giving checks and he trades Rooks
he's going to take this Pawn on G5 but
then you give up the A4 Pawn oh my
goodness now all but B2 is hanging but
there might be a draw Queen H4 to
d8 oh he's got to be careful now a
Perpetual being threatened by white a
check on H4 and a check on d8 so you
don't have time to pick up the B2 Pawn
instead he does a go for pushing his own
Pawn defending the H4 Square it was a
great move by Fabiano because he
recognized it's not about the quantity
of Pawns about the quality you want to
push those pawns forward and try to get
a new Queen ala will quickly try to push
Pawns of his own but Fabiano that g Pawn
that could be a very good asset for him
this is still a race and Fabby now picks
up the B2 Pawn Fabby has to win this
game to force an armag again and a
little indecisiveness there by Ala will
cost him the A4 Pawn but F7 is hanging
watch out he's still in it but he nearly
let nerves get the better of him there
King D3 fabon should give a bunch of
check gain a bit of time on the clock
and then decide to do decide to what to
do about this Pawn on F7 he comes back a
check and protects good move there
protecting with a check not allowing
white to push the a pawn but White's
King is so close to Black's passes this
is not clear at all and Black's King is
very far away normally when you're head
two pawns you trade Queens to win the
game but any Queen trade would be great
for white because of how advanced that
pawn is away from Black's pieces can
that pawn queen F6 check and take on A6
wow what does he missed that pawn is
just hanging I think he just missed it
look at that look at the reaction there
from FIA a shake of the head he knows
now he is losing he has to take on F7
but then there might be a queen check
Queen E2 check and if you trade Queens
black should win the king and pwn in
game and you've got to go back to G1
move it's there he he trades the Queens
by force and it will be the F3 Square
where the queen will land on a training
into a lost King Pawn ending and it's
handshakes Fabiano Carana does it he
takes it to Armageddon What A ferocious
comeback from Carana he was relentless
in his attacking motifs and all of a
sudden we have a third Armageddon fuja
had it in his hand but for Fabiano give
him all the credit in the world amazing
play there by Fabby he just kept
building up the pressure till fuja
collapsed and he's still thinking about
it but there's no time to think as the
players have to give in their Armageddon
bids and we see Fabby will go into his
second Armageddon of the day right there
signing it off we've got three big
Armageddon coming up what a around this
has been what a game this was what a
marathon 94 moves packed full of quality
in the end that's listen in as the
players make their preparations for
Armageddon wow and there we see uh the
Arbiter Jud that she is informing the
players of when the armagard will start
we've got three big ones coming up for
Ali Resa fuja he did everything he could
to defend that position but Fabby just
amazing incredible play there just kept
going kept putting the pressure asking
the questions until it was too much for
Ali Resa David yeah three draws in this
round but this was clearly the Highlight
bouncing back in a musn situation with
black is the hardest thing to do in
chess and he did it Fabiano Carana with
a bit of help from the opponent in the
end fuia had defended a horrible
position so well for so long but in the
end it was just this slip Pawn to A6 the
blunder putting the pawn on a vulnerable
Square allowing a double attack a check
and ultimately after this Pawn dropped
yes he could take on F7 but the forced
Queen exchange was decisive and just to
explain why fuia resigned in this final
position after the queen trade black has
to play the very accurate move King to
H5 a diagonal opposition here if the
white king steps forward the black king
steps forward and the pawn simply pushes
if likewise the white king steps across
you have to step across with your king
gain the opposition Force the white king
out the way and you can bully white
backwards eventually this Pawn would
step forward and promote
and game 101 but uh classy stuff and
from a distance it's so natural for Al
Raza to think that trading the Queens
would result in a draw but then a king
H5 diagonal opposition you always want
to initiate the opposition in King and
pwn games Fabiano he just had that he
earns the tide match and three armagedon
I keep saying it but I am so
excited theaction is only getting
started three Armageddon out of four
games just unbelievable and there we
have it it was only Wesley so who was
able to wrap it up in two games Magnus
Abdus satro goes into an
armag Fabiano Carana against fuja with
that comeback win also going into an
Armageddon and it is going to be Hikaru
Nakamura the five times US champion
taking on Maxim vrav also in the big
Armageddon and there he is it is going
to be more chest for these two in just a
few moments get
ready
[Music]
the Chess World Championship has been a
prestigious title for well over a 100
years but often times the prize money
was lackluster chess in the 19th century
developed without an international
governing body World Championships were
negotiated between players with
Challengers expected to raise large
enough Stakes to entice a title holder
to compete the first official World
Championship in 1886 had a substantial
prize purse fitting for an inaugural
event subsequent championships failed to
generate substantial
purses it would take 35 years for the
world championship's prize purse to
surpass the amount raised for the first
championship something magical happened
in chess a new Challenger from the
United States pierced the Iron Curtain
and threatened to end Soviet dominance
of the
sport Bobby fiser won the candidates
matches in 1971 earning him the right to
play spasi for the world title fiser was
different than other players of the time
he didn't just want to be the best
player or the most dominant or even the
most famous he wanted to be
paid fiser grew up in abject poverty in
Brooklyn New York and was highly
motivated by money and earning what he
believed chess players were worth the
story lines were interesting and diverse
USA versus the
USSR West versus East capitalism versus
communism the world was ready to see
these two superpowers battle it out on
the chest
table fiser demands continue to impact
almost every variable of the event
including the location the chess board
and pieces and of course the prize purse
fiser even had the audacity to demand a
share of the ticket sales and broadcast
royalties for the
players at one point it looked like the
event might not even happen fiser
claimed the prize money was too low
despite it already being the highest in
history Fisher's calculated moves paid
off when a wealthy business owner
doubled the prize purse raising it to
$250,000 or $1.7 million today Fischer
and spasy shared a prize purse bigger
than all the previous World Championship
prizes
combined after their match Boris sposi
stated to the Press how grateful he was
for Bobby fiser and how the money from
this event was going to change his life
Bobby fiser single-handedly raised the
profile and catapulted chess into a
mainstream sport followed by millions of
people fiser had ensured that not only
he and spasy but every World
Championship competitor after them
earned a deserving prize
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bz sisters
come on look at
this the chess.com Community streamer
program is growing every day whether
you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your your stream promoted on
the game's largest platform simply link
your account at chess.com settings
connected accounts set your category to
chess on Twitch and start streaming
you'll get an adree experience on
chess.com you will pop up on our list of
live streamers your chess.com profile
will feature your Twitch stream and your
stream will be linked to your games on
our play server type command Community
streamer in chat and start growing your
stream
today
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com
Mount them in seconds with a tool-free
magnet kit and swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
get ready to compete in tomorrow's Loi
girl Arena we're hosting two Blitz
Arenas tomorrow December the 10th with
big prizes for the top three finishers
in including Unlimited Edition chess.com
Loi girl vile you must join the LOI girl
club on chess.com to register for the
arena so use the command Loi in chat to
enter and right now it looks like the
players have join the Armageddon Club
because we've got three big Armageddon
coming up and we've also got the bids
coming on with between Hikaru Nakamura
and Maxim vasher lra and something that
we've never seen before just happened
that's Hikaru submitting his
bid and he bust start laughing as they
realized that they submitted the exact
same bid have we ever seen anything like
this in the Chess World no I don't think
we have and they were laughing because
the odds are not very high that they
would bid the same exact number but
that's how much these players know about
each other that even when it comes to
bidding they're right on the dot unreal
what are the odds this submitting the
exact same time for the armagen bid
unreal stuff is happening in Toronto and
Kaa did catch up with Maxim VRA to ask
him his bidding
strategy I am here with Maxim vrav
getting ready for armagon I haven't seen
your bids but I'm hearing rumors you
guys tied the bits is that correct yeah
we tied the bit the first time how uh
random and incredible is that yeah I
guess we both s um like which time we
should get more or less and some of this
uh this happened and I don't know how
the bidding ended uh you maybe can tell
me uh we don't know like we did a second
bid this time it was correct but we
don't know we will come back later to
know ah so you are as blank as me you do
not know what's going to happen here but
how do you feel about this one ending up
in Armageddon now against the speed
demon Yar Nakamura I'll just play I'll
try to
um better prepared uh now for for the
next game and we'll see how it goes are
you nervous not really cool Frenchman
thank you and good luck Maxim all right
we don't know the bids you guys this
will be exciting back to
Oslo K we are so excited about this one
as the players are ready to go Hikaru
starts with the black pieces Maxim very
cool and calm in his interview with Kaa
saying he's super chill about things uh
it looks like Hikaru perhaps won that
bid because we see him with the black
pieces and there we have it that was the
winning bit by Hikaru Nakamura
eventually at 9 minutes and 39 seconds
so he starts with black he needs a draw
to win the match meanwhile Maxim bidding
at 10 minutes and 2 seconds so he would
be happy with the white pieces it's
still a bit on the higher side yeah
he'll get 15 minutes with the white
pieces Hikaru will be over 5 minutes
behind on the clock so it's a nice time
Advantage but draw odds I think they
compensate for one another I'm still
thinking about the fact that these two
players got the exact same bid on the
first try it really reminds me of the
time earlier this season when Magnus
Carson got inside hikaru's head and bid
1 second under winning the bid that time
these players they know each others they
know each other so well and uh here's
the second armagedon match between Alara
fuja with white against Fabiano Karana
oh one second apart very little
separates these
two amazing stuff we saw Hikaru and mvl
bit the same amount and here just the
second apart and it is who won the bid
with one second and against the black
pieces Ali RZA with white and the time
Advantage will have to win and the third
are mdon Magnus Carlson gets why did nck
out strategize him with his bid it was
nck who did win the wiid and starts with
black look at magnus' bid David I'm
curious what you think you know Magnus
super well 10 minutes 28 seconds he
probably woned the white pieces yeah I'm
surprised I'm gobsmacked actually
especially the way the games went Magnus
didn't really have any chances in the
earlier games to be that confident to
bid that high and want the white pieces
to win on demand now shows extreme
Confidence from the Norwegian here
Magnus he means business oo and look at
that stare by n it looks like he's
equally confident with the black pieces
there he's got to win on he's got a
Magnus has got to win on demand nck
needs a draw but he starts with the time
odds we're ready to go it's going to be
three
Armageddon I think the most
nerve-wracking part for the players is
just this moment here they're now seated
in their chairs the games are about to
begin but for notbe Abdus satar he is
one of the coolest customers you could
possibly imagine he is not afraid of the
man sitting across from him yeah he's
got ice in his veins Abdu satoro and
okay he'll need them uh to work well in
order to secure the draw necessary here
5 minute disadvantage and black against
the world number one it's all stacked
against him and uh I think the one thing
that's guaranteed Magnus will try
something a bit spicy in the opening he
needs to surprise early on Magnus
Carlson has been adventurous with his
opening choices in the Champions Chester
will we see another Surprise by Magnus
early on and we see there Maxim with
white what will be his opening choice in
a must win a game and it's handshakes
and we're off with the Armageddon we're
off with the Armageddon we see a
handshaking Magnus against Abdu satoro
and uh it looks like an E4 opening here
and something else we noticed is
somebody checking off move numbers and
why is that important everybody at move
60 their increment begins they get one
second added per move so you see people
standing with score sheets just checking
off each move that's played important
stuff and the players will be looking
over they will be seeking reassurance
later uh that they are gaining that
increment at move 60 and in the meantime
some very quick moves uh almost a
replica of their earlier game Magnus
here um just I'm really surprised I've
got to say playing right down the line
that gave nbec a draw earlier in the uh
in the day I think he just wants another
long maneuvering battle Magnus Carson
but no surprises here nothing new Under
the Sun in this one as uh both players
getting off to a fast St it seems like
they're very familiar with one another
and you see notbe doing his patented
stare he looks up at Magnus saying what
do you want from me now Magnus is the
one on the clock so Tanya in the early
stages seem seems like even if we
haven't looked at the position yet
advantage in favor of nybeck especially
because Magnus is the first to slow down
uh and the one thing when you're playing
against Magnus is you cannot allow that
to get into your head the fact that
you're playing against world number one
and I think that's exactly what this
younger generation does so well and of
course one of them notc I just don't
think that Magnus has that same effect
on the younger generation as he does in
some of with some of his own compatriots
and his colleagues and this is our other
armagan which is underway Maxim Vash lra
against Hikaru Nakamura and we're seeing
quite a non-standard position in this
one yeah bizarre position uh but it has
arisen from the same exact opening uh
from earlier today this variation of the
Petro defense which has a dubious
reputation black is yet again a pawn
down but with threats on the board with
tricks in the air and this does hint
that Maxim Vash gra spent the break
after that quick draw in the previous
game going back to his hotel room check
checking out doing some research and uh
coming up with a new idea but Hikaru
again the first to make his opponent
think I'm surprised that Hikaru repeated
the same line just because it feels like
has a dubious reputation and AAR is
maybe trying to prove everyone wrong
this actually is something that can be
held at the highest level and I think
Maxim just moved his King over there was
a knight on B4 hitting his C2 Pawn he
slid his King to D1 he's saying I don't
need the right to Castle I'm up a pawn
yeah he's up a pawn and in the meantime
the other game ongoing is alera against
Fabiano Carana Fabby With The Wind in
his sales right now after that win on
Demand with black he's black again he's
a different opening this time far more
solid opening from Fabiano but uh yeah
he needs to speed up it is f with the
clock Advantage let's remind everyone
watching the players playing with the
black pieces need only a draw to win the
match and uh with white you've got to
win in the Armageddon and for Fabiano we
heard him speak to K earli earlier today
he's saying well if I had the white
pieces I wouldn't know what to play cuz
I have to win with black I feel like I
have a good understanding a good
repertoire and against Ali Raza who now
was forced to win from the white side I
think U Fabby and the early going
probably not too unhappy but I just saw
a rook move up the board W Rook lift
it's the theme of the day we've said it
multiple times and this is a uh kind of
accelerated Rook lift in that one with a
white Rook landing on H5 but we'll get
to that this is Magnus gson against Abdu
satoro and quiet quiet stuff I did check
went out 20 for the first 16 moves this
was an exact replica of their earlier
game but nobec was the first one to
launch a surprise putting H the Black
Knight on B6 forcing Magnus to think and
in the meantime we look at the clock
it's about a three and a half minute
difference here so less than it was to
start the game uh looks like Abdu sator
in his comfort zone there's some
tactical opportunities for sure later in
the game if white plays Knight D5
opening up that Bishop to slice across
the board but what I like about magnus's
position is the Knight on B6 is restrict
Red by that pawn on B3 a pawn three
squares away from a knight usually wins
that Showdown and you see notbe he is
thinking on magnus's clock yeah he's
thinking on magnus's clock and I think
the last move that he made is The Rook
lift to D7 we see it on our live board
right now and Magnus is the one with
head in hand trying to figure out a way
forward and I think the idea that nck
has here is to try to transfer the queen
to the king side with Queen E8 and queen
G6 and that's why Magnus is going for
this queen side break creating chances
on the other flank yeah he's trying to
open up the position trying to uh at
least for the first time make Abdu
satoro think here it's starting to get
tactical it's really coming to life this
position I've said it before armagedon
chest there's two strategies with white
either you go really direct really test
your opponent from the off or you keep
as many pieces on the board as possible
and only later change the pace of the
game Magnus has gone for that latter
strategy finally he is initiating some
tension some threats Robert mentioned a
white knight planting itself uh in the
center on the D5 square and after St he
has to act energetically to fend off
that threat but the problem is he
doesn't have so much time because he may
have to make a critical moment and only
spend 30 seconds where in a classical
game he might spend 30 minutes I mean we
see this position here Knight E3 to D5
that looks extremely tempting as White's
next turn because you are just throwing
your knight in the opponent rook's face
please please please take me on that
square and open up some diagonals and
files for my pieces
this type of position it looks very
difficult for black the eval bar may not
be as impressed as I am but I think
Magnus feels comfortable right now with
the white pieces wow and he's landed a
knight I'm really surprised abdor
allowed this one but okay he's trying to
trade off pieces later he'll try and
evict this Knight with a pawn and uh
Magnus meanwhile preventing that he's
putting pressure on this Black Knight to
stop the black C Pawn from ever moving
this Knight it looks like a granite
statue right now on the center of the
board it's super powerful and uh
pressure on black uh this one looks easy
to play for white but really far from
Clear what Abdus Toro should be doing I
don't like Black's position and you may
want to play C6 you're not going to get
that anytime soon as you mentioned so I
feel like white has the easier plan
moves like Bishop to A5 that Bishop on
D2 not doing so much on its current
Square so I really like mag's position
and his four-minute lead on the clock is
also something I appreciate nearly five
at this point yeah still far from
decisive black is solid enough for now
but no easy moves translates into
burning time on the clock and not sure
what's happening here but this is the
other game this is the other clash
between Maxim Vash gra and hiar Nakamura
on the board also a crazy position what
on Earth is happening in this one you
would think that black needed to win
this game just looking at the position
where white is a pawn ahead I count six
pawns for white only five for black but
white does not have the right to Castle
so that was the position between Maxim V
lrav and hikaro Nakamura we're getting
the game back here between Magnus and
Abdus satarov I really like magnus's
position still I don't see a plan for
black I think that being under seven
minutes and being under some duress here
Magnus in great shape yeah Magnus in
great shape he's now pausing and then
he'll switch up the pace speed up once
he's decided upon a plan uh multiple
moves Bishop to A5 I quite like from
Robert you could push the white a pawn
forward Black's Knight is really
unstable right now um You can trade off
dark squ Bishops potentially but Magnus
spoiled for Choice Big Time advantage
and I think a of a favorite right now uh
in this Clash at least still quiet but
if things living up it should favor
white yeah huge favorite I would say I
really like this position for white I
think nck you can see his body language
he's trying to you know be stoic and say
I've got this but I'm just looking at it
and I don't really see Black's plan
where some of White's moves do see much
easier and Bishop A5 one of year he
might stop on B4 before eventually going
to A5 but I think that black has a
difficult time dealing with some of
these threats and you can never really
take on D5 that just helps White but a
minute and a half on this move that's
quite a long thing you've got to play on
the clock as well especially with NC's
moves ideas not being so clear for him
it's critical for Magnus to keep the
pressure on Long think strong think
maybe if he comes up with a good move
but uh yeah Magnus in the tank right now
and I like uh nbec how he was giving
Magnus a bit of a stare from time to
time he looks at the board he stares at
Magnus he looks at the board stairs at
Magnus the Mind Games now head in hands
abor he's realizing that Magnus a bit
unsure about how to proceed in the end
pushing his a pawn very logical a
trademark of Carson's pushing his flank
pawns like this but uh still good for
white love that move because I kept
looking at a bishop move he says let me
kick that Knight out of B6 we already
established that black does not want to
take that my knight on D5 to help white
improve the pawn structure and I'm going
to play A5 next to kick your knight out
of the B6 Square really really like how
Magnus is doing this yeah yeah Simple
Plan and a strong plan just to highlight
Robert if Knight takes Knight then
actually you could take in either
direction right now but at the very
minimum you can take like this land
queeno C4 backward Pawn big targets big
Advantage wow some pressure on nbec and
the current position if black does try
to stop the threat you don't want to
really happily put your own Pawn on A5
because it can become such a big Target
for that Bishop on D2 as well a
long-term weakness so some difficult
decisions here to be made by nck does he
allow magnus's Pawn to advance to A5 or
create a weakness for himself by pushing
the a pawn we will check in on this but
let's head over to our other Armageddon
as Hikaru
Nakamura faces Maxim Vash lra the crazy
position that popped up earlier what on
Earth is going on in this one wow it is
wild I had to do a quick count here
white is still a pup uh Hikaru
sacrificed a pawn as early as move three
move four in this game uh but in return
black does have a relatively safe king
for now black has the bishop pair I'm
not sure who's King of saer actually
thinking about it now but Maxim's last
move throwing the the white B Pawn
forward this should not be touched that
pawn is poisoned if a trade happens
White's Rook on A1 would suddenly be
activated so Hikaru needs to uh refrain
and uh not uh give into that Temptation
instead he needs to decide how to break
the tension I'm sorry I was listening to
you but I have to be honest Fabiano
Carana Uncorked maybe the move of the
day in his game against Ali Raza fuja it
was an unbelievable move from him and if
we can bring that up at some point that
would be unreal because you said that
first Fu's win that might have been the
game of the day but if Fabiana can take
this third game in Armageddon I think
we'll be talking a new game there it was
really I see your face there it's nasty
oh wow yeah that is uh just yeah one of
the most brilliant moves we'll see uh
but we'll come to that in the meantime
let's focus on this one and Nakamura I'm
really surprised uh I actually thought
he was going to maybe offer a trade of
Queens because long-term blacks Bishop
pair would gain in power if the Queens
disappear but instead he's going for
that white king he's trying to crack
open break open the defile and wh's King
sitting there in the center of the board
kind of breaking the coordination
between White's Rooks it's a clear
Target that being said he's given up a
second pawn and blackking not looking
entirely safe either um this is brave
brave stuff from hikara Nakamura I was
going to say any other player I'd call
it Reckless but this is uh courageous
stuff and uh yeah I not sure who I'd
pick here it's just in the balance and
clock times yeah the White Queen looks a
aggressive but it actually doesn't have
another check and the G2 Pawn is loose
The Black Queen on C6 is eyeing that
diagonal the D3 Pawn is loose I think I
would prefer Black's position just
because he only needs a draw and I could
see the white king being in danger yeah
even if the Queens come off black has
great compensation long term with the
two Bishops so I think I would rather
take Karu but the clock times may play a
factor later absolute Chaos on the board
in both these matches that we've checked
in with and a big decision right now for
maxim VRA both Kings out in the the open
it's really anyone's uh game this one
but for white you have to win on demand
in the Armageddon but let's head over to
what Robert called the move of the day
by Fabiano Carana in a thrilling
sequence and we will Deep dive into this
one David what happened yeah we have to
rewind we have to backtrack and show an
action replay the current position
Fabiano is up material he's up the
exchange Rook for Knight white has an
extra Pawn but not the most relevant
Factor White's King very vulnerable as
well but let's jump in let's deep dive
and uh show a position just a few moves
back it was here where white down on
material but with good compensation some
tension on the dile black's Queen
uncomfortable Black's King a bit of a
target white played Knight to H4
threatening Queen to G4 lining up on the
very weak G6 porn and Robert I think
this is the move you mentioned
deflection is the name of the game yeah
I thought I something went wrong I
thought there was another dgt error but
here Rook E1 was played that deserves at
least three exclamation points the whole
point is if that Rook takes on E1 Knight
D3 check is a fork you can't take that
Knight on D3 CU The Rook on C pins the
pawn that otherwise would capture the
Knight it was such a beautiful shot from
Fabiano that was only available after
the White Knight just jumped out to H4
so to be able to see that understand the
tactics in the position Fabiano he's
trying to earn this match Victory that's
always the most s satisfying tactic
right sacrifice on an empty Square uh so
unexpected White's Rook is the glue
holding everything together so deflected
away and win the game this would have
been a family Fork a royal fork and
would have been decisive instead fuja
had to Simply backtrack with his Queen a
really sad move Rooks came off the board
and now if we catch up with the current
position Black's material advantage
should be decisive uh simply taking this
Pawn looks very very juicy maybe there
are options but black ahead of material
and big favorite to win this game fabi's
chess just keeps on giving I mean with
the kind of stuff that we saw in a game
two of round two his comeback Victory
and rookie won there uh completely in
control and you can see that there is
some desperation here by Ali razza he
goes for Knight takes pawn and there's a
big trick if black wants to capture that
night a huge discover check on F4
winning the queen so Fabby needs to
avoid that yeah we have to jump back in
because it's crazy uh as you mentioned
Tanya poison Knight King takes Knight
would walk onto a vulnerable Square
discovered check and the queen would
drop next move um this would be
disastrous for black so you cannot take
this night what do you do instead wow
another deflection oh my goodness this
so beautiful because Knight E2 check if
the queen takes it now the black queen
will take the Knight on D5 and you
Knight on G6 is hanging and after Knight
F4 can I actually play Move Queen E5
here and say let's get those Queens off
the board I'm up a rook for just a
knight and pawn it's too much material
with Queen A1 check the Knight hanging
everything in the air black is clearly
the side in charge yeah and if you don't
take this knight uh there are problems
as well uh what has he gone for he has
hoovered it off the board if King to B2
I think he might have tried the
beautiful Knight to C3 forcing the
knights off the board forcing the Queens
off the board and at the very end you
pocket this night winning AME for black
tactics Galore this is Fabiano showing
off freestyling and most likely winning
this game Knight comes in with a fork
but black at least has a check on G5 uh
to uh get out of that but look at that
Fabby just so on point he doesn't care
he just pins that Knight on E7 this
looks like game over for Ali Resa this
looks like match over you can take the
queen and then you lose your queen or
you go Knight F5 check saying please
take my knight I'll get your Rook that's
good for white after Knight F5 check the
king simply slides back to a square like
fa protecting The Rook I me Fabiano has
done everything exquisitly starting in
game two of this match saabi today just
looks like a player how do you and where
do you fight against him I mean just all
his games have been incredible aliv rzad
did win that first game getting those
tactics in they just impressive
impressive stuff by Fabiano all day long
yeah this game in particular it's a
masterclass in counterattacking in uh
kind of accelerating your own threats
ignoring the opponent's threat picking
off loose pieces here White's Queen is
undefended so you can pin win it's just
uh want a study for everyone at home all
of these tactics it's kind of blow after
blow after blow never retreating never
backing down and he deserves this win if
he takes it and it's not just the
Tactical the attacking portion but even
strategically just outplaying ala in
that game two that we saw the comeback
win by Fabby and this Armageddon just so
on point his Armageddon against Maxim
earlier in the day just incredible play
there and queen has moved up to E3 uh
black can you actually just go off for a
trade on G5 uh is that an option how is
there a way to take advantage of the pin
on uh on the Knight actually I really
like this move from fuja both players
bringing their aame here Queen E3 does
threaten to take the black queen white
tonight if it kind of Retreats now takes
the black queen would then defend its
own Queen Knight to F5 still in the air
as a threat Black's King not entirely
safe Queen to G5 you mentioned tan can
be blocked by White's F Pawn still not
over so despite I mean this must be
frustrating for Fabiano playing some of
the best tactics of the day and it's
still not winning yet but this is I
think the classiest approach very classy
just the calm Queen E5 now the queen
trade is offered the Knight on E7 is
loose now Knight F5 check is what we've
been talking about but I think the black
king can even go up the board to G6 and
with the Queens off the board there is
just no chance that black loses this
game on the board I'm looking at the
clock fa 2 minutes left he's on move 34
so there is a chance that he get in time
trouble and knights are tricky you've
got to watch out for those folks as well
uh so it's not over he can pick up the
B7 Pawn but Fabby wants to just move the
Rook to the B file then picking up the
B4 Pawn it's all about the clock right
now that is Ali resa's hope Ali Resa
really playing resourceful some
incredible stuff but Faby just look at
the confidence he just marches up with
the king I think he's going to do this
he's going to get the job done in this
one yeah he's winning it's not a
question it's just the clock 2 minutes
online I think he would win this every
time but over the board it's just
physically hard to get that many moves
down he needs to reach move 60 as we
mentioned to get that increment uh the 1
second increment I believe uh but no
guarantee you get there um this one will
go on a long time but it looks like
Fabiano should should be in time and he
has got plenty of time per move a few
seconds so he does have sufficient time
to get this match Victory all he needs a
draw and it looks like in the other
matches there is chaos there too so all
three Armageddon games they brought the
fire absolutely and uh Fabby there he
did check with the Orbiter what move
number I think that was that is crucial
because after move 60 they get an
additional 1 second on the clock Fabby
playing fast trying to trade out the
piece the pawns but it looks like that
does favor white in this position it
does favor white if white were wanting
to draw this but unfortunately you need
to win and uh for fuja every Pawn that
disappears means you're uh unfortunately
further and further away from winning
this game even even a night Fork at some
point if all the pawns disappear won't
be sufficient I think here Fabiano is
just aiming to trade everything off he
doesn't even want to win uh why why go
for that when you don't need to H just
bring the Rook around you got to be
careful where you place it but bring the
Rook around and go for those pawns he's
doing it with the King instead wow all
right this looks like uh Fab's got
everything under control let's head over
to our other Armageddon we do see the
evalar seems to say that Magnus is
getting the job done on his board Magnus
taking on nck up doat Magnus has to win
as he is playing with the white pieces
and we see there head and hands for nck
I also see no pieces for black like I
see what he's doing but I don't see
where his pieces are and it looks like
it's a rook end game actually where
white is two pawns ahead this has shades
of Carlson lavic from the first match
yeah big Shades there he was two pawns
up as well and all not all the rook and
games were drawn this is an exception as
well white simply has too many connected
pawns too many pass pawns and this the
elevated level these players play at is
Elementary stuff White's King is simply
going to join the party now he's going
to centralize uh Magnus he's the king of
end games as everyone knows and okay
first he targets this weak black ewn as
long as he leaves himself with two extra
pawns ideally connected Magnus is
guaranteed to win this one and look at
the clock as well hope slipping away
hope fading out for Abdus satoro uh
hopefully we get time later there were
some highlights some tactics uh earlier
in this game but Magnus full control why
does Magnus is not in control it's rare
occasionally happens occasionally
happens but not today as he takes down
uh another youngster what a day it's
been for Magnus cson what a start it's
been for Magnus taking it in the
Armageddon against nbe Abdus satro a
confident win with a white there we
still have action on in the other boards
yeah some big action actually dramatic
stuff elsewhere as uh Magnus wraps up
his win here and I have no doubt he's
going to go and check out those other
boards right now and we should go check
out the other boards as uh there we see
a Magnus walking past and having a look
at the other Armageddon and Hikaru
against Maxim I saw a little headshake
there by Hikaru Hikaru looks very upset
with himself it's something we've seen
multiple times he just hit himself in
the head wow whoa It's the Hikaru face
when he misses something he has missed a
few things now missing a knight white is
simply a whole piece up Maxim should be
winning this uh Hikaru he's just playing
a few more moves here oh suddenly he's
sped up Suddenly a change in body
language the hustle mode is on this is a
check the black king
moves that hustle mode lost it for a
whole of one move and now again despair
on Hikaru well sometimes you try to will
yourself back into a game in Hikaru he's
not even looking at the board anymore he
is ready to throw in the towel it would
appear and that was a check and look at
Maxine bring his Rook back cuz hikaro
does have a pass Pawn we see it one
square away from promotion but we might
not see the pawn on the board anymore
after that move yeah white simply has an
extra night white white has an extra
Pawn no sources of counterplay left to
Black anymore Hikaru he's going to keep
pieces on he's going to Hope somehow
that he wins that white knight or
somehow gets a few checks against the
white king but hope fading in this one
as well he continues to react and this
has been a disastrous day for Hikaru
losing the first match now on the brink
of defeat of the second one on his
birthday I was about to say it's not
just any day it's hikaru's birthday and
it is difficult to play on your birthday
we've all had that experience where
you're distracted because you just want
to celebrate but you have a big event in
hand and for hikaro he you see the pain
on his face that's not the face of a man
who is celebrating anything today uh
Hikaru looks like he's on the brink of
giving up but it's really not over till
uh handshakes with him we know how
resource he can get any chances at all
in this one David normally I would say
no but it is Hikaru Nakamura he saved
worse than this multiple times
throughout his career here we get a
closer look at the clock and
unfortunately it's 21 seconds for Hikaru
almost 2 minutes for Maxi Vash grav and
I think that means there's minimal hope
another check the White Knight dancing
around the board drops back to a nice
defensive post and more checks Black's
remaining porn disappears and with it I
think the game yeah that's uh The
Disappearance of the pawn and all hope
for Hikaru Nakamura he's down a piece
he's down two pawns and I think he's
just willing himself to make a move I
mean this is uh painful and it was
self-induced we will rewind and look at
the game later but Hikaru was playing
stubborn defense and he went for a trick
and you see the handshake he can't
believe it he's beside
himself and it is Maxim vrav who takes
the win against Hikaru Nakamura and you
can see the relief in him he's has got
to be feeling good after taking down one
of the most uh difficult toughest
opponents to be so resourceful even in a
lost position Magnus does it Maxim does
it and what happened on our third
Armageddon Fabiano Karana he drew his
game with the black pieces so he gets
the job done as well against Ali Resa
seemed like we had some very great games
on fireworks but Fabiano we knew he had
it under control Magnus he seemed to be
in good shape but that game we just saw
hiar Nakamura shaking his head he's
disgusted with how it went and as I said
it was self-induced it's an unfortunate
situation on his birthday yes here K
Nakamura with the two losses but things
are just getting started here it's just
day one let's take a look at our results
of round two and that we have it Maxim
winning in the Armageddon Magnus winning
in the Armageddon Fabby drawing his game
taking the Armageddon and then it was
only Wesley so who managed to wrap it up
in just two games what a day we've had
what a round two we've had and at the
end of day one this is where we are with
the Wesley so Magnus Carlson Fabiano
Carana the top of the leaderboard with
two victories Ali Resa and Maxim getting
one win on day one while nbe Hikaru
Dennis yet to get started on the
leaderboard David what a round this was
what a round what a start just f starts
everyone playing ambitious chess it's
not about how you start however it's
about how you finish and still plenty of
games ahead plenty of days ahead so hope
for Hikaru but uh yeah it's been full of
twists and turns full of blunders in
that last round uh full of brilliant
moves as well and uh in the end I think
it is about that self- induced that
self-inflicted moment and uh let's
highlight the moment where Hikaru let it
slip here with black he is a couple of
Pawns down but he has the most important
Pawn in the position hikara Nakamura one
square away from promotion and uh the
simple the most natural move Rook to H1
probably would have got him the decid
result and would have guided this game
towards safety white here in the next
couple of moves would be forced to give
up uh some material by taking on G2 and
black should be relatively safe Hikaru
thought he'd spotted a blunder though he
went for the very ambitious Bishop takes
E6 check but it backfired badly and
after Rook takes Bishop a check he
suddenly realized the white king can
simply attack this black Rook no time
now to take the Rook on E6 and at the
very end white is simply a piece up
White's extra knight uh he saved it and
uh first giving a check deflecting the
black king taking this Pawn we saw the
rest of this game Maxim guiding it
calmly smoothly to Victory Nakamura a
hallucination a blunder and in the end a
loss a big win for Maxim in the
Armageddon and the other big win in the
Armageddon was Magnus Carlson he's had a
fantastic day one and Ka is with the
world number one here with Magnus CWS
and that is two for two on day one how
do you feel
I feel really good um you know I didn't
have any chances in the first two games
and um winning on demand and Armageddon
is always hard um and I don't think I
got uh too promising a position but I'm
very happy with the way I managed to
introduce a little bit of dynamism in
the position um suddenly there were
there were tricks he had to spend a
little time and he chose chose the wrong
plan and I think after that when sort of
my weak Pawn on C4 get transposed into a
very good one on D5 I think he was
already in very bad shape and many
people were shocked to see how high you
went in the bidding what was uh the
thought behind that um I thought you'd
need more time over the board first of
all um and also like you shouldn't
always bid low like that's it's a bad
strategy to be
completely consistent in your in your
bids so that's one of the reasons why I
went a bit lower basically yeah so
basically to be unpredictable for the
rest of the tournament as well yeah
right well um uh what a day minus you
you win two out of two uh against lasan
Abdu saturo but tomorrow is a huge day
you have Hikaru and Fabby tomorrow is
that a day you've been looking forward
to I didn't know whom I was playing
tomorrow but uh that it's um yeah
obviously that's uh that's on paper a
very difficult day uh but yeah um I got
two wins in my bag so that feels PR good
so I have a little more room for for
sure do you think it could be an
advantage that you did get to play some
um Armageddon here on day one to sort of
get that game going yeah I think so um
and the good thing for me is that I felt
very very calm playing so um I'm
definitely have positive experiences uh
from from that and and it's certainly
useful and in terms of all the other
players has anyone surprised you today
is anyone looking stronger than maybe
you would have
thought um yeah I mean obviously Wesley
winning two in a row looks looks good
but
um I think um
Alesa yeah well he lost the second game
so I shouldn't say that um yeah I think
for everybody else it's been a bit up
and down H I hear rumors there's a
Toronto Maple Leafs game going on
tonight is that something you want to
relax with and enjoy um probably not um
I I think Saturday Saturday games are
pretty pretty busy but never never all
right well Magnus congrats on a good
first day and good luck tomorrow thank
you thank you for joining us yep that's
Magnus CRS winning two matches here on
day
one two wins for Magnus quite a a good
start on day one playing against the two
youngsters what dramatic day of Chess
we've had today we saw some amazing
Armageddon some bids like we've never
seen before David who impressed you the
most on day one of the
finals they might not have won both of
their matches uh but I'm going to say
alera just for some of those tactics uh
actually one player who did take some
nice wins Fabiano just some of the
tactics the speed the Highlight for me
was all those Armageddon so much drama
so much content there packed into one
and uh the chess was uh chess was the
winner
Fabiano shown an incredible ability to
rebound because he lost to Maxim then
won the Armageddon he lost to Ala won
two in a row or drew the arm again but
to win the match but I have to say
Wesley so we didn't talk about him very
much because he was so dominant that we
didn't get much gameplay from him he won
game one and quietly Drew game two in
both of them and then he disappears no
Armor gets from him so Wesley has been
in great form yeah just amazing play by
the players all around and for me it's
got to be the Aliva win against Fabby I
mean that was a fantastic game
sacrificing a knight sacrificing a rook
and then going on uh to Checkmate uh
Fab's King in the middle of the board
some fantastic play out there and we got
a big day two coming up Robert what are
we expecting how are the players going
to switch it up the ones and Hikaru he
hasn't scored yet what are we expecting
tomorrow from him yeah the players that
are 0 out of two already need to think
is it time that I have to go all in
maybe I'll lose the match badly but you
need to win so for players like hikaro
and of course Dennis and Noir Beck it
might be the last time they really ever
a shot to catch some of the leaders yeah
and the Fantastic thing about this
format is that everyone's strong but
that's a downside for some of the
players imagine Hikaru tough start tough
birthday tomorrow he's playing Magnus I
mean we're we have so much more to look
forward to and uh I'm hoping the players
continue this vein this energy that
they've been showing us today so much to
look forward to with a big big day two
coming up it has been a dream star to
the Champions Chester final and while we
are going to sign out from our studio
from from Oslo we're going to head to
Toronto and joining uh Danny and James
with Fabiano Karana what a day of Chess
we've
had thanks Tanya Robert and David we are
here with the guy that I guess both of
you David and Robert said maybe had the
day the day for everyone here you win
two Armageddon matches with black you
got you got to be feeling pretty good
right now e baby come on yeah especially
after the second match I mean it was
yeah I was uh so close to losing the
match of course I uh the second game was
absolutely insane I mean I I was happy I
got a fight from the opening but then so
many twists and turns I was definitely
much worse at some point than I was
probably checkmating him and then I
definitely messed that up as well and
should have been a draw at some point
and that was crazy so the Armageddon I
was just happy to be there yeah what do
you say to yourself faio in rebound
games like this of course I mean it
hurts to lose obviously but you have to
bounce back and make it all the way
through Armageddon What kind of mindset
do you go through with that I think
experience helps a lot I don't get
overly emotional when I lose the first
game of the match anymore because I it
happened it's happened so many times
that I'm a bit numb to it and I think
that's a good thing because you don't
want to be really emotional whether you
have to win the game or whether you have
to actually I would say I get a bit more
nervous when I have to draw a game after
winning my first one and I mean we saw
that in the first match I messed that
one up against Maxim uh but I think
experience definitely helps in this in
this format it's interesting cuz is it
even harder to lose the game against
Maxim right would you rather be the one
who wins to force Armageddon or would
you rather be the one who was up and
then lost right mindset matter there I
think it's it's very interesting you'd
you'd assume of course that it's better
to come uh back come back from from A
Loss because you have those positive
emotions but the excitement can also get
to you right and like you're you're
thinking I'm back in it and you you get
that like flood of good emotions but
also maybe a little bit too much
excitement so luckily I didn't feel
anything in the Armageddon game against
ala I just felt pretty calm and I I
think it was a decent game like maybe he
had some Advantage at some point he he
played Super aggressively Rook H5 it
didn't feel right but to refute
something like that when you don't have
increment and you have I probably had
like seven minutes at that point or
eight minutes it's really tough so um
yeah he was definitely putting the
pressure on but some at some point it
just fell apart for him I don't know
exactly which moment cuz I thought the
exchange sack is still pretty unclear uh
but yeah when I when I played W that's
the moment when I was thinking like it's
almost over I I know we're not going to
show chess here and it's unfair to the
fans but if anyone wants to go over the
game on the chess.com event server it's
nice to get a brilliant symbol you know
what I'm saying right rookie one you had
everyone was falling out of their seat
on that one I think Robert almost almost
almost slipped out of the chair there I
I did have this one I saw this one
coming before yeah so how early did you
see it I know we little but everyone can
what I mean I saw that rookie 8 there
are some ideas it already was like in my
mind um but like even a bit before when
I played Rook I was thinking like okay
Knight D3 somewhere yeah because if his
Knight moves from D5 then somewhere
there's Knight D3 right so that was
already in my mind and rookie was with
the idea of Knight
H4
looks like we're back in the studio with
uh some technical hiccups there but we
will get Fabby back on but what a day
it's been for Fabiano caruana with the
the chest that he shown yeah it's a
shame for him because he was just about
to talk about that sick rookie one move
that he found I did almost follow my
chair in the studio when it happened and
for Fabby he should be proud of the day
that he had coming back and tomorrow
it's another day but as you said before
the the games don't get any easier every
opponent is super tough yeah these are
after all the eight best performers of
the Season playing in Toronto right now
and this is the action coming up
tomorrow round three starts with look at
that matchup it is Fabiano Carana
against Magnus Carlson that's world
number two playing World number one uh
We've also got Ali RZA fuja against
Hikaru Dennis lazic against NC Abdus
satro Maxim takes on Wesley so but guys
it's got to be all eyeses on Fabby
versus Magnus yeah one of the players of
2023 continuing his great form winning
those two Armageddon today kowana I mean
I want to go back to Fab I want to hear
more about those victories against
Magnus Carlson I mean that is Juicy to
say the least fuan against Nakamura just
a nice uh a nice appar te as well a nice
side dish and uh yeah just fantastic
games uh a lot to look forward to I'm
I'm going to pick a matchup that you may
not expect lazic against Abdus satar I
think that will be a lot of fun and
considering both hers lost their first
two matches one of them has to come out
with a match win that means they're
right back in the thick of things so for
nck you can't Overlook the fact that
lvic is super solid you can't take it
for granted but one of these two will
get right back in the hunt oh some juicy
juicy matchups coming up uh tomorrow and
of course fabulous is Magnus they played
a world championship match together so
that's one that we're super excited
about and we're going to head back back
to Toronto to talk more with Fabiano
Carana we're back here in Toronto back
again with Fabiano I'm goingon to go
right back to the question I was trying
to ask uh before the Oslo crew stoar
thunder so you've won two matches in
comeback fashion you got to keep your
own adrenaline under control and now
you're playing Carlson tomorrow so how
do you how do you get yourself in the
right mindset for that oh it was a long
day I'm just looking to rest a bit
tonight and little Clash Royale maybe
maybe we're in the same Clan now we are
we
are no it's uh it's of course going to
be a really tough match I there's
there's never an easy time with Magnus
um but every match is tough here I don't
think that I'm going to have a single
easy match and we already see like some
favorites are struggling um some some
players are pulling ahead a bit yeah I I
don't think that uh I think it's too
early to say what's going to happen and
also uh I don't expect an easy match in
any of these so it's not like
um yeah it's not like of course Magnus
is a huge challenge but it's not like
I'm expecting to break in any round yeah
obviously it's easier said than done but
now that you are 20 is there an is there
a different x's and O strategy literally
because all you really need is just to
hold water although I guess if you know
you got to go to Armageddon no matter
what so there's no real way to get out
of the uh the fire yeah I don't think
there's like you can't play it safe here
because you you should be shooting for
for top two spots and also it's not like
you can draw a game and and Coast or
anything yeah so so um yeah of course
you just try to to win every match it's
uh not like that's very likely to happen
but you you do your best every match and
um I don't think there's like a meta
strategy May no I can't imagine yeah I
can't imagine there's no meta strategy
because you got to winner go home I love
I love the format there's no way to draw
your way through this thing you're going
to get Armageddon so hats off to the
format right there you answered the
question good good luck good luck with
some Clash Royale we're going to pull up
the standings here as as Fab
gets the well-deserved rest that he
wants to have and uh right at the top
you see Wesley so and Magnus Carlson
with two points there they are in theory
sitting with slightly better tie breaks
than Fabiano right now because it took
him two Armageddon victories to get his
two points but otherwise all three of
those players are are looking pretty
good after that you've got fuia and Vos
lrav both with a single point of piece
having having gotten to the Armageddon
stage before losing and then you have
Abdus chov hkar Nakamura and Dennis loic
all looking for their first match
Victory obviously I I don't mean this
disparagingly but I think a lot of
people knew that the younger players
Notre Beck and lavic might struggle I'm
not sure everyone anticipated hikaro
Nakamura being there but because it is
his birthday even though he's maybe
having a tough day right now we're not
going to let him end on a on a bad day
we've got this cake we're hoping hikaro
is watching somewhere um I'm G put I'm
gonna put my hat on Levy would you like
some of the cake bud you right over
there there you go buddy at it Levy gets
a hat Big Buddy there and then I'm going
to get myself a hat without ruining my
my earpiece know what I'm saying that's
cute look at that yeah wait you didn't
think I would go all out on this we're
not done bro get one of these in your
mouth there you go that's what I'm
talking about yeah okay they don't make
as much noise as I anticipated this went
differently in my head yeah but um
either way we do wish a very very happy
birthday to Hikaru Nakamura happy
birthday bro I'm going to I'm going to
this is a pineapple cake really custom
this is cake this is not a pineapple I
know you're thinking you're thinking
that looks like a pineapple it's
chocolate I don't know that I'm going to
do this well so I'm going to cut right
there there we go candy you want a piece
oh my God that's frosting in the middle
my goodness there you go you get the
first piece take that right okay and
then I'm going to blow out the candles
here on behalf of hikaro while you take
while you take a bite of that and uh I
guess if I blow out the candle that
probably is going to blow out the lights
on the show here in a minute happy
birthday Hikaru well wishes for for
better results in future
games and uh and yeah for the whole crew
here the boy hidden is it good it's
hidden right now okay it's good for the
whole crew here we've got plenty of
Chess up ahead this whole week in
Toronto the uh the games have only just
begun and we cannot wait for more so
join us join us
tomorrow and uh for for everyone here in
Toronto you know I think this is it this
is it for us we'll see you for day two
of the 2023 Champions chess tour
tomorrow for everyone the crew in Oslo
the crew here have a great night tune in
tomorrow and we'll see you
then he's going for more he's going for
more in this position he's string mes
again Wesley so the magic continues in
Toronto what a game start to finish this
just looked like an Al I show this one
Maxi B actually resigns offering the
trade Rook takes KN is on the board
we're going to see this being played out
this is just genius from fuja Ali R of
fuja with the black pieces a flawlessly
executed attack and he went for a trick
and you see the handshake he can't
believe it he's beside
himself
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]